RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY- AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IN THE CAPITAL BUT SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
WITH THE USE OF THE VIDEO
MEETING SERVICE. OUR PANELISTS
FROM STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACADEMIA COMMERCIAL TESTING AND
A HEALTH EQUITY ORGANIZATION
WILL ALSO BE PARTICIPATING
THROUGH THE VIDEO SERVICE. IN
ADDITION TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR MEMBERS
WILL NOT BE WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING REMOTELY EXCUSE ME
TODAY AND FOR PANEL IS PLEASE
MEET YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS.
ARE IT PERSONNEL MUTE AND
UNMUTE THE VIDEO SERVICE WHEN
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY EIGHT ELIMINATING ANY
BACKGROUND NOISE AND
INTERRUPTIONS. I ASK THE EVERY
TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION BUT YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FIRST. BRAWL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING. TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL PROVIDE
THE PARTICIPANT TO THREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC COURT IN THE HEARING
ROOM WE WILL BE ASKING THEM TO
TESTIFY USING THE TELEPHONE
SYSTEM BECAUSE WE DO NOT AT
THIS POINT. I SECURE SYSTEM FOR
SANITIZING THE MICROPHONE. WE
NEED TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE. AND
AGAIN JUST ASKING EVERYONE TO
KEEP THEMSELVES ON MUTE AND
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY. OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM TO THE DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETINGS OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND
IT'S CLOSE TO THE MET SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE LACK TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS AND A FEW
TECHNICAL ISSUES AS WE PROCEED
TODAY. PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR-
PATIENCE DURING THIS TIME. SO I
JUST WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE
I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE
DURING THE FIRST. HEARING ON
THE SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
WHERE WE ARE CHARGED WITH
REVIEWING THE STATE'S RESPONSE
OF THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
IN THE COMING MONTHS ARE
COMMITTEE WILL PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN EXAMINING
ASPECTS OF OUR STATES RESPONSE
TO THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
A NUMBER OF AREAS. THIS WILL
HELP US ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THIS MOMENT. THE OF
THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE AND ENSURE
THE STATE IS WELL POSITIONED TO
RESPOND QUICKLY AND
APPROPRIATELY IF THIS. CASE IS
A FUTURE PANDEMIC. AFTER
EXPLORING THESE ISSUES
COMMITTEE WILL BE MAKING
SUBSTANTIVE POLY OR POLY
COMMENDATION. TO ASSIST IN
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF TODAY
TO PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE. IS
THE- HEARING. FOCUS ON COPING.
TESTING BOTH. ANSWER LOGICAL
AND CONTACT TRACING. OUR
WITNESSES TODAY INCLUDING
NUMBER OF STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS ACADEMICS AND OTHER
EXPERTS YOU CAN SPEAK TO HELP
THINGS BEGAN. WHAT WE HAVE
ACHIEVED TO DATE AND WHERE
THINGS ARE HEADED IN TERMS OF
THE PANDEMIC. A TESTING
ACCESSIBILITY AS WELL TO ALL
WHO NEED IT AND THOSE- AND I'M
SORRY AND DOING THE CONTACT
TRACING THAT IS ALSO NECESSARY
TO STEM THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS. PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
ARE GOVERNOR AND OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ADEQUATE TESTING IN CONTACT
RAISING OUR FUNDAMENTAL IN
ORDER TO BEGIN TO SAFELY EASE
SAY HAVE A MEASURES. REACHING
FOR EVERYONE NEEDS A CO. SAYS
ACCESS TO ONE. APARTMENT ARE
ABLE TO QUIT REACH A TO TAX OF.
IRIS OUR CRITIC APPS MAXIM IT
CHEN THAT. NEW INFECTION ARC
AND BEFORE THEY TURN A NEW
RAPIDLY GROWING OUTBREAKS. AND
ESPECIALLY BEING A MEMBER OF LA
COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE THE BULK
OF THE CASES. I AM- ESPECIALLY
HONORED TO BE CHAIRING THIS
COMMITTEE AND I THINK- MY CO
CHAIR OR CO CHAIR SENATOR PAT
BATES FROM WITHIN A GAL. AND
MANY OF THE MEMBERS THAT ARE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. DOING THE
GREAT WORK DURING THIS TIME. SO
WITH THAT A WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE ROLE OF THE MEMBERS
PLEASE. SENATOR GONZALEZ HERE.
SENATOR BATES. HERE HERE YES
HERE SENATOR BARGES. PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SENATOR CABALLERO.
SENATOR DODD. HERE. SENATOR
JACKSON THERE. SENATOR JONES
THERE. SENATOR MCGUIRE AIR.
SENATOR PAN PRESIDENT. SENATOR
UMBERG THERE ARE. AND SENATOR
WIENER. OKAY THANK YOU SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH OUR
SPEAKERS I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE
PUBLIC COULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX- AGAIN
THAT IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE
USE THIS ACCESS CODE. NINE
THREE SIX EIGHT FIVE ZERO EIGHT
AGAIN THAT IS. NINE THREE SIX
EIGHT FIVE ZERO EIGHT. SO THIS
AFTERNOON WE WILL BE HEARING
FROM TWO PANELS OF WITNESSES
WITH QUESTIONS FROM SENATORS AT
THE END OF EACH PANEL BEFORE WE
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
VERY FIRST PRESENTER. DOCTOR
CHARITY DEAN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA IS THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ALSO THE CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORONA VIRUS TESTING
TASK FORCE. WELCOME DOCTOR DEAN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY I'M
DOCTOR CHARITY DEAN I'M THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND CO CHAIR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TESTING TASK FORCE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY WITH MY CO
CHAIR PAUL MARKOVIC- WHO IS CEO
AND PRESIDENT OF BLUE SHIELD.
AND I'M GONNA GIVE A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND ON HOW THE TASK
FORCE STARTED WHAT OUR GOALS
WERE. ON THE ACTIONS THAT WE
TOOK IN SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACED I'M MORE TALK
ABOUT HOW WE'RE EXPANDING
TESTING WILL TOUCH BRIEFLY ON
SEROLOGY TESTING IN AND COVER
NEXT STEPS. SO BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND- IT WAS CLEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDED TO RAPIDLY
SCALE UP TESTING AND THE
GOVERNOR LAUNCH TO BE TESTING
TASK FORCE. AS A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE WE KNEW
THAT GOVERNMENT ALONE ON
COULDN'T SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND
THAT WE NEED EVERYONE AT THE
TABLE. AND SO THE TIME WE
LAUNCHED WE KNEW THAT
CALIFORNIA WAS DOING SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
THOUSAND P. C. R. S. DIAGNOSTIC
TESTS PER DAY. AND WE KNEW THAT
WE NEEDED TO SCALE UP FROM
THERE AND SO THE GOAL THAT WE
WERE GIVEN WAS RAPIDLY SCALING
UP TESTING GOAL OF TWENTY FIVE.
I THINK PER DAY BY THE END OF
APRIL. I WE HAD A MID APRIL
GOAL OF TEN THOUSAND TEST PER
DAY. AND WE WERE EVEN ABLE TO
MEET THAT GOAL OF TEN THOUSAND
PRESS HAS PRETTY MET APRIL AND
THEN MEET THE GOAL OF TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND TEST TODAY BY THE
END OF THE MONTH. AND TODAY
WERE IN THE LOW THIRTY
THOUSANDS TEST PER DAY. I'M FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND THE STRATEGY
THAT WE USE TO MEET THAT GOAL
AND THAT WERE USING MOVING
FORWARD. IS TO TAKE A REALLY
CAREFUL LOOK AT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS NUMBER ONE IS
LOOKING AT. WHAT IS THE
INSTALLED CAPACITY ACROSS THE
STATE. IT'S OUR TASK FORCE ARE
THROUGH LOTS OF. PHONE CALLS
AND EMAILS CONDUCTED ALL. DOING
CLOSE WITH THE HAAS. TO DID.
WHAT IS THE INSTALLED CAPACITY
OF THE HIGH THROUGHPUT
MACHINES. WHO'S DOING TESTING
HOW MUCH PCR TESTING CAN THEY
DO PER DAY. AND THE THROUGH THE
DATA THAT WE GATHERED WE ARE
ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT
CALIFORNIA- HAS INCREDIBLE
CAPACITY TO DO PCR TESTING. BUT
THERE ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN. OUR TEST
THREE ASIANS- KITS AND
CARTRIDGES THAT WERE NEEDED FOR
SPECIFIC MACHINES. SO WE'RE
ALSO WORKING ON WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS AND DISTRIBUTORS
OF THOSE MACHINES AND
CARTRIDGES. TO PROBLEM SOLVE
THE SUPPLY CHAIN WHERE WE CUT.
AND THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE
DISCOVERED THAT LACK OF THE
SPECIMEN COLLECTION KIDS WAS A
REAL BOTTLENECK FOR THE
COUNTIES SEEKING TO TEST PEOPLE
THAT MAYBE THEY HAD THE
INSTALLED CAPACITY OR THE
ABILITY. TO DO THE PCR TEST
WITH THE MACHINES. BUT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE SPECIMEN
COLLECTION KITS AND SO IT
BECAME REALLY CLEAR THAT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN WAS A MAJOR HURDLE
IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS- TO SOLVE SOME OF
THOSE PROBLEMS AND WE'RE
GETTING A LARGE SHIPMENT OF
SAID SUPPLIES FOR SPECIMEN
COLLECTION KITS AND THIS WEEK.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO IN THE
FUTURE OF THE TESTING TASK
FORCE WAS ABLE TO PROCURE SOME
OF THOSE SUPPLIES DIRECTLY FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
ALSO THINGS. IN FROM FEMA FROM
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS- AND THEN
SOME OF THE LOCAL LABORATORIES
OF COURSE OUR GOAL TO CONTINUE
TO. GROW UP YOUR SUPPLY. OUR
OWN THROUGH THE SMALL I'M
MECHANISM. ONE THING THAT
BECAME AND AS WE BEGAN TO RAMP
UP TESTING CALIFORNIA WHAT'S TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CALIFORNIA.
IN GUIDANCE SIXTY IT. AND THE
REASON THAT SOME IS WHEN
TESTING WAS SCARE. ARE FOR AND
PUBLIC HEALTH WAS ON TESTING
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY GROUPS.
AND IS TESTING EXPANDED WE KNEW
WE HAD TO EXPAND THE GUIDANCE-AND WE DID THAT AND THAT
INCLUDED A SYMPTOMATIC
FRONTLINE WORKERS FOR EXAMPLE
THOSE WHO WORK IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY. SO OUR
GUIDANCE HAS EXPANDED- WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THE TESTING
CAPACITY AND NOW THE GOAL IS
REALLY TO EXPAND THE SPECIMEN
COLLECTION SITES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
PAUL MARKOVIC TO SPEAK MORE
ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU. EVERYONE
ON MUTE WE HEAR A LITTLE BIT OF
FEEDBACK. ALL I'M SORRY. WE DO
A LOT OF FEEDBACK. GO AHEAD
IMPRISONMENT. I DON'T NOW IF
YOU HAVE SOMETHING ON YOUR
COMPUTER YOUR SYSTEM THAT MIGHT
NEED TO BE TIED DOWN. PHONE TWO.
WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW. LET'S GO
BACK TO DOCTOR DEAN. COME BACK
TO THE- ALL. SURE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES IT'S HARD OKAY SO
I LET ME JUST ON TALK A LITTLE
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
WE'RE EXPANDING THE SPECIMEN
COLLECTION SITES ACROSS THE
STATE. LAST MONTH WE WERE
EXCITED TO ENTER INTO A
PARTNERSHIP WITH OPTIM SIR. AND
THE GOAL OF THE OPTIONS OUR
RELATIONSHIP WAS TO ALLOW
PRESSMAN COLLECTION SITES
ACROSS THE STATE TO EXPAND. AND
LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA. COOL WAS
TO STRATEGICALLY PLACED SO
SPECIMEN COLLECTION SITES IN
THE PLACES OF GREATEST NEED AND
WE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT WE CALL
TESTING DESERT THAT'S NOT JUST
A GEOGRAPHIC DEFINITION IT
MIGHT BE IN A HIGHLY POPULATED
OUR REGION THAT HAS TESTING
CAPACITY BUT NOT ENOUGH AND-
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T ABLE TO
ACCESS IT. LOOKED AT THE MAP
AND WE LOOKED AT A FEW
INDICATORS- LOOKED AT POVERTY
WE LOOKED AT ABILITY TO TASK
RACE ETHNICITY HOW POPULOUS THE
REGION WAS AND THEN WE LOOK AT
DRIVING. AND SO ACROSS THE
STATE WE WORKED WITH OUR
COUNTIES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED.
AND THE COUNTIES ARE WERE THE
ONES ACTUALLY CHOOSE THE BRICK
AND MORTAR LOCATION OF THE
SPECIMEN COLLECTION SITES. WE
MADE RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON
THE DATA THAT WE HAD- BUT THE
COUNTIES ARE TRUE PARTNERS IN
THIS AND ESTABLISHING ON THE
LOCATION FOR THE SITE. AND
OFTEN SERVED PROVIDES THE
SPECIMEN COLLECTION KIT. AND
HAS THE CAPACITY TO DO A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO TESTS
PER DAY SPECIMENS COLLECTED PER
DAY. AT EACH SITE. SO THAT
BRINGS AND TEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ADDITIONAL
SPECIMEN COLLECTION KIDS IN THE
CALIFORNIA. AND THE DATA SYSTEM
IS INTEGRATED WITH OUR STATE
DISEASE COLLECTION SYSTEM SO
THAT BOTH THE COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. CAN DAY AS IT
COMES IN RAIL. I'M LOS BE ABLE
IT HELLO LEVEL AND- THIS IS
ABOUT WHAT. AND CO. THEY TO
PRIORITIZE THE SITE FOR AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE SOME
COUNTIES ARE PRIORITIZING FRONT
LINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
pLOCAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. TO
ENSURE THAT THIS CERTAIN TIMES
ARE BLOCKED OUT AT DOCTOR
SERVICE SITE FOR THE FRONT AND
HEALTH CARE WORKERS THEY'RE
ALSO DOING MESSAGING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THE TEACHER CLEAN
PLACING THE SITE. IN LOCATIONS
WHERE POPULATIONS ON THAT ARE
HISTORICALLY UNDER CLOSURE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO ACCESS HEALTH.
AND SO IT'S A PART THE STATE
AND THE COUNTIES WITH THE GOAL
OF QUICKLY SCALE AT SCALING UP-
OUR ABILITY TO COLLECT
SPECIMENS- WE KNOW AS SUCH A
HUGE EFFORT STANDS UP. TO
EIGHTY TESTING RATES OUR SPRING
COLLECTION SITES WITHIN TWO
WEEKS- WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
THERE'S GOING TO BE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE IMPROVED IN
LOCATIONS. OFTEN SERVICE
WORKING HARD SAYS- TWO WEEKS OR
CHANGES TO THE WAY THAT WE DO
THE OPERATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
IT STANDS SAFELY AND ENSURE
THAT THE RIGHT DATA IS
COLLECTED. AND AT THIS POINT
THERE'S A AND FOUR SITES ARE
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE EXPECT
OUR APPLE GO UP OVER THE REST
OF THIS WEEK. AND I SO WANT TO
SEE ARM IT'S BEEN PARTNERS
BETWEEN THE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THERE CAN TO
EXPAND AND GROW I COLLECTIONS
THEY HAVE AS ACROSS THE STATE.
THOSE ARE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY RENDON FRIENDLY
THERE EIGHT TO BE A DRIVE THRU
ASIDE AND MANY OF THOSE
LOCATIONS WERE AS OPTIMIZER
SOCKS ARE CURRENTLY WALK IN.
LET ME JUST IN AND SEE. AN OVER.
TO PAUL THE ADDED OR FOR SHOULD
MOVE ON WITH. SEROLOGY THAT
WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU DOCTOR
DEAN A MISTER MARKOVIC. AT OKAY
OKAY PLEASE CONTINUE ONE THANK
YOU I THANK YOU AND I SO WANT
TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON SEROLOGY IN
UP TO THIS POINT WHAT I'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IS YOU SEE ARE
POLYMERIZED CHAIN REACTION OR
MOLECULAR TEST THAT DETECTS THE
VIRUS THOSE ARE DIAGNOSTIC TAX
IF YOU HAVE A POSITIVE PCR THAT
IS DIAGNOSTIC FROM BEING IN
FACT WITH THE VIRUS THE TYPE OF
TASKS IS KERALA. TO BLOW PASSED
AND LOOKING FOR THE SINS OF
ANTIBODIES AND ALTHOUGH WE ARE
VERY OPTIMISTIC AND ON THE
TESTING TASK FORCE WE HAVE A
TEAM OF REALLY SMART LABORATORY
SCIENTISTS OR DIE WAITING THESE
NEW SEROLOGY TESTS MANY OF THEM
THE PAINTING AND WELL BEING
BUDGET WE'RE IN A VERY CALM
ROACH AND HERE'S WHY. DON'T
KNOW IF THE BODY AT THE POLICY
TO. IS JUST. AFTER PROVIDE
IMMUNITY TO READ. WE ALSO ARE
TAKING A CAUTIOUS APPROACH
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW HOW AYE
SENSITIVE OR SPECIFIC SOME OF
THESE SEROLOGY TESTS ARE AND TO
BREAK THAT DOWN INTO PRACTICAL
TERMS THIS THROWS YOU TESTS ARE
GOOD AT TESTING A WHOLE
POPULATION AND TELLING US WHAT
THE PREVALENCE IS. HOW MANY
PEOPLE AND NOT. WE THANK OR IT
DID WITH COBRA NAY. AT SOME
POINT. WHAT IS NOT GOOD AT
DOING IS DIAGNOSING ON AN
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL WHO MIGHT HAVE
IMMUNITY AND SO WE'RE REALLY
TAKING A CAUTIOUS APPROACH I
WERE EXCITED THAT NEW SEROLOGY
TESTS ARE BEING DEVELOPED AND
ON THE TESTING TASK FORCE WE
GET. INCOMING INCREASE. ABOUT
NEED TESTING WE DO EVALUATE
EACH ONE AND WE ARE AYE
PUBLISHING GUIDANCE ON SEROLOGY
THAT'LL BE ON OUR WEBSITE IT'S
REALLY INTENDED FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. I'M SOME COST IN WORDS
OF SOME PEOPLE WONDER HOW
CONCERT YOU TEST BE USED. SO HI.
BUT I'LL JUST TOUCH ON NEXT AND
WHERE WE'RE HEADED. I'M WE ARE
EXCITED THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
MEET AND EXCEED THE GOVERNOR'S
GOALS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE FOR PCR
TESTING. HOWEVER WE NOW SEE THE
OUR BENCH MARKET THAT WE REACH
AROUND THIRTY THOUSAND TEST PER
DAY. AS BEING THE NEW- THE NEW
BASELINE AND WE'RE RAMPING UP
EVEN MORE FROM THAT AND ARE ALL
BY THE END BAY. STREET SEE OUR
AN- TODAY. AND WE'RE HOPE EVEN
BEYOND THAT THAT WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO REACH EIGHTY THOUSAND
TESTED IN THE- CALIFORNIA. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT AROUND FIFTY
THOUSAND STRONG HASN'T BEEN
DONE SO FAR CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE TRACKING THAT INFORMATION
AS WELL. WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE COUNTIES INCLUDING THE
WORLD COUNTIES- SOME OF WHOM
DID NOT RECEIVE AN OPT IN
SEARCH SITE. WE ARE HAVING
PROBLEM SOLVED PROBLEM SOLVING
MEETINGS WITH THEM EVERY DAY I
TO STRATEGIZE WITH THEM TO LOOK
AT THEIR CLINIC SYSTEM THEIR
HOSPITALS. WHAT OPTIONS THEY
HAVE AND THERE ARE MANY TO RAMP
UP TESTING IN THEIR IN THEIR
JOB SECTION. SO I'LL GO AHEAD
AND STOP THERE AND BE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS THANK. THANK YOU.
DOCTOR IN PRE BATON WE HAVE.
LOST MISTER MARKER WHICH WILL
GO AND HAD. OVER TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER. WHO IS SUSAN FINELLI
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR POLICY
AND PROGRAMS WITH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
WELCOME IS AN ALLEY GOOD
AFTERNOON- I WANTED TO FIRST
START BUYING- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY-
AND THEN I WILL JUST GO THROUGH
A QUICK. OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WITH
CONTACT TRACING AND THEN
ADDRESS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE'RE NOT ON THE AGENDA SO
FIRST OFF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
EVERY CASE AND CONTACT IN THE
STATE SO AS WE CONFIRM CASES
PARTICULARLY AS WE START TO
LOOSEN UP THE STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE'LL BE ABLE TO. GO TO
THE POINT WHERE WE FIND THE KEY
FINDER ARE. FACT LEFT AND MOVED
YOU ARE THOSE CLOSE CONTACT YOU
I SAW QUARANTINE ISOLATE ANYONE
INFECTED AND PORTANTINO ANYBODY
OR EXPOSED TO MIGHT BECOME.
ATTENTION IMPACT AT. WE WANT TO
OFFER A QUALITY TRAINING
PROGRAM THE STAND UP ON NEW
LARGE NEW WORK FORCE THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH THIS
GOAL. AND A ROBUST DATA
MANAGEMENT COMMUNICATIONS WERE
TO STREAMLINE AND SUPPORT-
CONTACT TRACING. BY LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS AGAIN
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD BASS OFF
OF WHAT ALREADY EXISTS IN OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
CERTAINLY TO WORK WITH THEM AND
TO PROVIDE. THEM WITH A WORK
FORCE EAT. QUESTION SEVEN. MORE
ON EACH AT SO FIRST OFF IN THE
ARM HE SENT CONTACT MANAGEMENT
MEANING SPOT WE WERE TO BE SURE
THAT THEY AT FIRST OFF IT EASY
TO USE THAT WE HAVE A ONE STOP
SHOP WE'RE LOOKING AT TRYING
DREAMED ABOUT I WAS IN OUR MORE
I'M CONTACT. THAT WE WANT THE
SYSTEM TO BE AN END TO END
SOLUTION AT NIGHT YOU MAY FOR
THE WE ARE LOOKING AT A DATA
SYSTEM THAT WILL CONNECT TO OUR
DISEASE I'M REPORT. HOW SYSTEM.
WARM WELL ABOUT BACK IN FORTH
TO A COMEY. EACH I EACH LOCAL
JURISDICTION WILL BE ABLE TO
YOU AND WORK WITHIN THEIR CASE
SAYS AND HAVE THOSE ISOLATED
CASES FOR THEIR JURISDICTIONS
OF THE SYSTEM WILL ALLOW IT TO
YOU I'M HAVE SCRIPTS THAT
TRIGGERS AND CASE MANAGEMENT
FUNCTIONS IT WILL EVEN HAVE
THINGS LIKE AUTOMATED- SYMPTOM
CHECK SO THAT THEY CAN TAX
PEOPLE ONE GAME INFORMATION.
FROM THAT WORKS IN TO YOU ARE
WITH MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
I'M- NOT DEVELOPING SYMPTOMS.
THE FORCE EXPANSION WE ARE
BUILDING ALL OF ABOUT EIGHT.
LOCAL CONTENT ESEARCHERS
BURNING TO. LOCAL CHURCH. IN
THAT THEY WERE BE ABLE TO. RE
DIRECT ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OTHER COUNTY EMPLOYEES AND THEN
IN PHASE ONE WE'RE HOPING TO RE
DIRECT ABOUT TEN THOUSAND STATE
EMPLOYEES TO THAT'S AFTER. AND
SAID THESE CONTACT TRACERS
WOULD BE I'M- RIGHT NOW WE ARE
PARTNERING I'M WITH YOU SEE A
STAFF AND UCLA THROUGHOUT
VIRTUAL TRAINING ACADEMY FOR
CASE INVESTIGATORS I'M AND
CONTACT TRACERS CLIMBED
REGISTRATION FOR THAT TRAINING
IS OPENING UP TODAY I THINK WE
WILL BE TRADING. ROUGHLY FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THIS WEEKEND
SO I WENT AND TO GET FEEDBACK
ON THE TRAINING THE TRAINING
WILL INCLUDE EVERYTHING FROM
BASIC PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE-
EVERYBODY THAT'S COMING INTO
THIS TRAINING DOES NOT HAVE A
PUBLIC HEALTH BACKGROUND. I
BASIC EPIDEMIOLOGY AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONTACT TRACING
ISOLATION AND QUARANTINE I'M
BASIC PRINCIPLES OF HEALTH
PRACTICE CULTURAL SENSITIVITY
AND I. ABSOLUTELY OUR PRICE
INCOME AND- TRAINING SO THAT
PEOPLE WILL PROTECT THE
INFORMATION. THIS COURSE WILL
INCLUDE HEALTHCARE COMPETENCY
OR SKILLS BUILDING AND
COMPETENCY BUILDING SO THAT ALL
THAT WOULD ALL BE LARGELY
VIRTUAL THERE WILL BE
INTERACTIVE SESSIONS WHERE
PEOPLE WILL GET TO INTERACT AND
I'M DO YOU SORT OF A MOCK
INTERVIEW. WITH A PERSON ON THE
OTHER. WE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
SOME PRACTICE IN INTERVIEWING
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW. BEING IS
ABOUT BUILDING A SORT OF QUICK
RELATIONSHIP WITH SOMEONE SO
THAT YOU CAN. GAIN INFORMATION
THAT YOU NEED TO AND NOT MAKE
AND I'M SURE THE PERSON THAT
YOU ARE INTERVIEWING. I WERE
THEM FOR AND WHAT WE'RE TO DO
THAT HOW WILL IT PRIVATE AND
WHY ULTIMATELY GOING TO
PARTICIPATE TO PROTECT YOUR
COMMUNITY AND YOUR FAMILY SO
THAT WE REALLY CAN I'M-
MEDICAID THE SPREAD OF THIS
DISEASE. ZERO I THINK SOME OF
THE OTHER QUESTIONS THAT CAME
UP WAS- HOW ARE PEOPLE WORKING
RIGHT NOW I'M CONTACT THREE
SAYING AND I THINK AT AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW WE DID A LOT OF
CONTACT. EARLY ON IN THE SPREAD
OF THIS DISEASE. LARGE LEAD TO
IDENTIFY THOSE EARLY CASE US
AROUND OF THOSE CASES SO THAT
WE COULD PREVENT THE SPREAD AS
WE WERE DOING THE REPATRIATION
EFFORTS AS WE ARE DOING THIS
PROBLEM MONITORING. A LOT OF
CONTACT RACING UP AND AS WE
SAW. LARGER COMMUNITIES HAD
SOME OF THE LARGER COUNTIES HAD
COMMUNITY PRIDE MONTH MOST
GREAT. STOCK DOING CONTACT
BECAUSE THEY WERE FOCUSED ON.
THE THINGS AND GETTING FOR ME
ABOUT. HOW TO MAKE SURE OF.
OTHER THINGS BE. THAT WE BE
PREPARED FOR THAT. RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE. TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES WHO ARE CONTINUING
THEIR CONTENT FACTORY SAYING
LARGELY BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
SMALL NUMBER OF CASES AND DO
THAT CONTACT THREE SAYING. I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THAT WAS
NUMBER SMALL. I'M BUT- THAT IS
A SIGNIFICANTLY BY CAP ME IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
RESOURCES THEY HAVE ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS. AND SECOND HOW MUCH
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO IN THE
WAY CONTACT. GRANT AS YOU KNOW
AT THE START TO OPEN UP THE
STAFF HOME OR- THAT THE WE WILL
SEE MORE CASES AND THE BEST WAY
TO REDUCE THAT NUMBER OKAY
SAYS. YES TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
ADEQUATE TESTING AND THAT WE
CAN ACT BACK TO CONTACT TRACING
SO THAT ANYBODY THAT I'M IS
EITHER. EXPOSED AND SYMPTOMATIC
OR FIRST OFF TO CONFIRM
IDENTIFY THE CASES BUT THEN TO
MAKE SURE WE TAKE WHAT TESTING.
HAS BEEN CONTACT AND
SYMPTOMATIC THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS AN ALLEY APPRECIATE THAT
WILL PROBABLY HAVE WILL MOST
LIKELY HAVE QUESTIONS AT THE
VERY END BUT- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE- GET BACK TO OUR OTHER
PANELISTS THE PRIEST. THAT VERY
MUCH I BELIEVE. UP AND CEO OF
BLUE. CALIFORNIA WHO'S JOINED
US. ON THE PHONE. YES OKAY HERE
CAN YOU HEAR ME ES WILL GO
BACK TO YOU. WELCOME MISTER
MARKOVIC AND YOU'RE ALSO THE CO
CHAIR OF THE CUT A CALIFORNIA
CORONAVIRUS TESTING TASK FORCE
AS WELL SO THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT'S AN
HONOR PRIVILEGE TO NOT JUST BE
ON HERE TODAY WITH YOU I'M
SORRY FOR THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES BUT TO BE SERVING
WITH. DOCTOR CHARITY DEAN WHO
IS THE BETTER HALF OF OUR
PARTNERSHIP- BUT ALSO IN A
PRETTY AMAZING COLLECTION OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEDICATED TO
THIS BECAUSE- I DO I DO- I
THINK AFTER BEING COVERED MOST
OF WHAT WE WANT TO SAY ABOUT
THE- POINTS. YOU CAN GET GEN
THANK YOU. FOR WHO ARE
VOLUNTEERING FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. WE'RE HERE TO HELP. YOU
ANALYZE YOU POTENTIALLY
PROVIDES RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
CERTAINLY NOT TO DECIDE- THIS
IS CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE AND ALL THE APPROPRIATE
PEOPLE IN THE RIGHT AGENCIES
ARE MAKING POLICY DECISIONS-
YOU MAY HEAR ME REFERRED TO WE
A LOT IN TERMS THE TASK FORCE
BUT I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT BE CLEAR. THAT NONE
OF US PRIVATE SECTOR ARE A YOU
CAN DECISION THAT WE SHOULDN'T
BE. I ALSO WANTED TO MENTION
THAT- WHEN IT COMES TO THE
COLLECTION SITE. THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT AND THE ENTIRE EFFORT IT.
WE WERE REALLY CLEAR THAT- NOW
THAT WE- SOLVED A LOT OF THE
SUPPLY SIDE ISSUES. THAT WERE
DISCUSSED EARLIER THAT NOW WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IN THE STATE. REGARDLESS OF
THEIR WHERE THEY LIVE
GRAPHICALLY THEIR ETHNICITY
THEIR INCOME LEVEL THEIR AGE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THIS VIRUS
THERE'S NO BOUNDARY. EVERYONE
GETS APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING. ON THE
COLLECTION SIDE WITH OPTIM
SERVER A BIG PART OF THAT AND
BARELY ARE A BIG PART OF THAT
THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY WAY WE'RE
ENSURING THAT THAT HAPPENED.
AND WHAT WE REALLY ARE LOOKING
TO DO IS ESTABLISH PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE COUNTIES IN THE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTION. MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S HAPPENING AND- AND
SO I REALLY TO THE EXTENT WE
AREN'T THERE YET WE WILL GET
THERE. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
ANY OF YOU ARE EXPERIENCING ANY
OF YOUR COMMUNITY SOMETHING
THAT FALL SHORT. OF THAT GOAL
WE WANT TO KNOW ABOUT IT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE
WILL GET THERE- AND WE WILL GET
THERE WITH YOUR HELP SO WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER YOU
AND- MAKE SURE YOU HAVE TIME
FOR QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR UNDERSTANDING ON THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THANK YOU
MISTER MARKOVIC FOR- THAT
INFORMATION IN YOUR- TIME TO
PRESENTS NEXT WE WILL GO ON TO
DOCTOR AND TO DAVIS THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HEALTH. OFFICER
WELCOME DOCTOR DAVIS AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND GREAT TO SEE
YOU AGAIN. GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
A HAVE A IF THERE ARE ANY AND I
DO WANT TO START BY THANKING
ALL OF YOU FOR ALL OF THE WORK-
AND GUIDE AND THEN AND FEEDBACK
THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US ALL ABOUT
DURING THIS RESPONSE. I WANT TO
START BY REALLY TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT IT IS THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT GENERALLY YOU IN
TERMS OF BROTHER OR FUNCTION- I
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT NOT ALL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT HAVE PRIMARY
CARE. NEXT IN ORDER TO. PROVIDE
THAT GENERAL CARE TO THE
PUBLIC- BUT MANY ABOUT THAT AND
ALL OF US TO HAVE A
SURVEILLANCE- ACTIVITIES THAT
WHILE OF THESE CONTROL ACT. I'M
SO TO START JUST THINKING ABOUT
THE FOUR CORE ACTIVITIES OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE FIRST THING
IS REALLY SURVEILLANCE- MUCH OF
WHAT HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING. WHO
WHAT WHERE WHEN AND HOW OF
THESE PRATT. IN ORDER TO BETTER
IDENTIFY WHAT THESE CONTROL
MEASURES ARE ACTIONS THAT NEED
A YEAH. IN ORDER TO PREVENT THE
CONTROL THE SPREAD ABOUT THE-
IN ORDER TO DO THAT TO. HAVE TO
INFORM AND IT'S FIVE WHEN I
CALLED. YOU ARE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS WHO ARE CARING FOR
THOSE PATIENTS. AND ALSO AT
SCREEN THEM AS WELL AS OUR
POLICY MAKERS WHICH INCLUDE YOU
ARE BORED IT PROVIDES THERE'S-
ANY MARES OR LACK OF OFFICIAL.
WELL THE PUBLIC AND THE- IN
THAT WE ALSO NEED TO COORDINATE
MANY OTHERS IN ORDER EMPLOYMENT
WHATEVER IS NEEDED ABOVE IN THE
FIRST THREE AND THAT DOES
REQUIRE A PARTNERSHIP THAT
OFTENTIMES THE ON THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND IN
CONJUNCTION HEALTHCARE ACT WELL
AT SERVICE PROVIDERS. IN OUR
JURISDICTION. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE ROLE OF DISEASE
CONTROL IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IT IS DELINEATED I
ENTITLED SEVENTEEN SECTION
TWELVE SEVENTY SPEC I WOULD.
DESCRIBE THE EFFECTS SERVICE
BOTH APARTMENTS ARE SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE AND UNDER THAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF COMPLICATED SERVICE.
RELATED TO THE DIAGNOSIS OF
DISEASE IN ADDITION TO THAT IT
ALSO THE EPIDEMIOLOGIC
INVESTIGATION AND APPROPRIATE
MEASURES THAT ARE NEEDED IN
MEDICARE THE HAZARD OF THAT
BACK- POSES TO THE COMMUNITY.
WE LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITIES AROUND TESTING
MANY OF THESE ARE COMPLEMENTARY
AND I HAD COORDINATION THAT
NEED. AND THAT'S NOT JUST BUT
AND ABOUT THE PARCHMENT BUT
WITHOUT BY PARTNERS WELL.
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS ARE GENERALLY
RISK OFF OR UP FOR CARRYING AND
GETTING ATTACKED BY THE SERVICE
THAT THAT THEY NEED OR OTHER
PATIENT CARE. AND FOR ME TO
LEAVE WITHOUT THE REST OF THE
MATCH ARE IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO INVESTIGATE A CASE AND.
I'M I TO PREVENT. IT THE LABS
THAT THE COMMERCIAL LAPTOP THE
RESPONSE OF THE BELL AN AND
GETTING APPROVAL FOR DOING
pTHANK AND THEN ALSO REPORTING
THAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OR CARE. I THANK. IN
THIS AND THEN THE INITIAL
COVERED DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
PROTOCOLS WERE DEVELOPED BY TO
INTERPRET IT IF CONTROL AND
THEN AFTER THEY DEVELOP BACK
GOT BACK DOWN TO A LEVEL THAT
THEY WERE COMFORTABLE WITH I'VE
BEEN SHARE THAT WITH THE STATE
AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH LAB IN
ORDER TO THERE A TESTING BE
DONE MORE LOCALLY WHICH REALLY
CUT DOWN ON THE I AM A
TRANSPORT ABOUT. OUR WAY YEAH
ALL RIGHT. IN OUT. FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT WE WERE FOR ISSUING
AND UP THE PROVIDER IN TERMS OF
WHAT PROTOCOLS WERE NEEDED
BASICALLY- GET AMPLE OF TO BE
TESTED AS WELL AS WHAT
POPULATIONS BASED ON THE
RESTORE THE- THAT WERE OF A-
YOU. PRIORITIZE PROTECT IN
TERMS OF THE POPULATION. WE
ALSO DID- AS I MENTIONED
AUGMENT THE STATE LAB BY
GETTING THE CAPABILITY TO DO
COVERED NINETEEN TESTING BUT
THEN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH LAB BUT
IT IT PALES IN COMPARISON TO.
THE WITH A COMMERCIAL LAB AND
THEIR ABILITY TO DO MORE TESTS
THANK. WE HELP IN THE WHEN AS
AN IN. AMOUNT THE FOR TEST OUT
THAT'S NOT NEGATIVE NOR
POSITIVE I WE DO WORK IN
COORDINATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT F PUBLIC
HEALTH THE LAB. AS WELL AS THE
IF THE IN ORDER TO DISCERN ON
WHAT TO DO WITH HAT. AND THEN
WE RECEIVED AGAIN MOST CASES
THOSE CASE REPORT AND
INVESTIGATE WHETHER COMES FROM
THE LAST- CARE PROVIDERS. IT IS
ALL ABOUT THE FIGHT IN TERMS OF
TITLE SEVENTEEN UNDER SECTION
TWENTY FIVE OH ONE. AGAIN
MAKING THAT THE INVESTIGATION
THE TERM OF THE SOURCE OF
INFECTION AND THEN TAKING
APPROPRIATE THAT. PREVENT THE
SPREAD. WHEN WE LOOK AT CONTACT
TRACING IT IS AGAIN ONE OF OUR
CORE FUNCTION. AND WE HAVE A
DEDICATED ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
STAFF WHO ARE READILY TRYING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS. ADVOCATE NUMBERS FOR
US STARTED. ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED.
A DAY. IT DEFINITELY CREATED
OUT MUCH MORE OF A DEMAND IN A
NEED FOR A LARGER WORK OR- AND
WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE. BUT WHAT
WE DID IN THE WE MADE CONTACT
WITH EVERY A- AND WE WOULD
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO CONTACT
TO GET A LITTLE MORE INTENSIVE
WORK. AROUND OUR HIGHER RISK.
THE STORE AREAS- THAT WERE
HIGHER RISK OF SPREAD AND
NEGATIVE HELP OUT- BUT THAT BE
WITHIN A HOP- LOWER SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY A CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY. OUR OTHER LOCATION-
WE CONTINUE TO DO OUR- CONTACT
TRACING AND INVESTIGATION
THROUGH THE PROPER COLD. AND WE
DO HAVE A REQUEST A FORMAL
REQUEST. IN FOR A SUPPORT ON AS
MANY OF YOU IN OUR CASE NUMBERS
ARE WELL- IN THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED PER DAY. YOU KNOWWE
GET THE THOUSAND OKAY BUT THE
DAY WE ARE. AT THE- AT LEAST
FIVE CONTACT- K. THAT NEED TO
BE- INVESTIGATED OR IDENTIFIED
IN FACT IT. AND WE KNOW THAT AS
THE- EIGHT OR ARE COUNTY STARTS
TO RE OPEN THAT NUMBER WILL
PROBABLY GO UP TO WHAT IT WAS
BEFORE THE FAVORITE MEASURES
FOR US WERE PUT IN PLACE. AND
AT THAT TIME FOR EACH CASE THE
RIGHT EIGHT CONTACT THAT NEEDED
TO BE IDENTIFIED. BASED ON AT-
A CONFIRMED DIAGNOSIS AND AN
INDIVIDUAL. WE ARE LOOKING AT
AND HAVING THE STAFF THAT WORK
AND- THAT INTERVIEW. BOTH AND
MULTI LINK LEVEL WELL A
CULTURAL LEVEL. WE OFFER
IDENTIFIED A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS WERE TYPICALLY OUT AND
ABOUT WRITING EDUCATION I TO
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES- WITH
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND
DIFFERENT CULTURAL ASPECT. ARE
IDEAL FOR CONTACT TRACING. BUT
WE DO KNOW THAT AT THIS POINT
WE DO NEED ADDITIONAL STAFF. IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE. ANYWAY IN
ORDER TO CONTROL THE SPREAD OF
THE WITHIN OUR COUNTY ALL RIGHT
UP THERE ON THE QUESTION THANK
YOU DOCTOR DAVIS WE APPRECIATE
THAT PRESENTATION. AND I WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL
PRESENTER AND OUR FIRST PANEL
WHO IS SUSAN BOSSY MADERA
COUNTY IS PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTOR WELCOME IS BOSSY. WELL.
I THINK YOU'RE ON MUTE. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AFTERNOON.
MY COMMENTS ARE PRESENTED
UNDERSTANDING THAT AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL WE HAVE ALL PUT
FORTH OUR BEST EFFORT TO
STRATEGICALLY AND QUICKLY
RESPOND TO THIS EVENT WITH
AVAILABLE INFORMATION A
RESOURCE AND I DID CONSULT WITH
MANY COLLEAGUES ACROSS ROLE
PLEASE. IN THE STATE TO GIVE
YOU CAN'T STANDINGS WHAT'S THE
STATUS AND RURAL COUNTIES OF
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES.
STARTING WITH PASSED. RESOURCES
FOR TESTING VERY WIDELY FOM
COUNTY TO COUNTY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA YOUR INTENSIVE LOCAL
AND STATE EFFORTS TESTING HAS
INCREASED IN MANY AREAS AND
THERE ARE COUNTIES THAT TO DATE
HAVE ONLY TESTED THOSE WITH
SEVERE ILLNESS AND SYMPTOMATIC
HEALTHCARE WORKERS SO THAT
THERE IS A BROAD SPECTRUM. PRO
WORK WHO TING DESERT DO NOT YET
HAVE ONE OF THE TESTING SITES
PROVIDED THROUGH THE STATE
CONTRACT AND AS DAUGHERTY
INSURED THAT TESTING COSTS
WORKS IS CONNECTING WITH THESE
COUNTIES INCLUDING MADERA
COUNTY AND WE EXPECT OUR SITE
TO LAUNCH WITHIN THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS. THESE SITES ARE USING
HIGH OUTPUT COMMERCIAL LABS
THAT TAKE TWO TO THREE DAYS ON
AVERAGE FOR RESULTS. AND THIS
IS GREAT FOR SURVEILLANCE IT'S
NOT IDEAL FOR CONTACT TRACING.
SO MANY SMALL AND RURAL
COUNTIES. ALSO NEED A RAPID
TESTING ACCESS AND FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE. INTENSIVE AND
RESOURCE INTENSIVE. TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THOSE RAPID TESTS. AS
TESTING IS A PRE REQUISITE FOR
MOVING FORWARD TO RE OPENING
THERE ARE EQUITY ISSUES MANY OF
THE COUNTY STRUGGLING TO
INCREASE TESTING ARE SHORT OF
OTHER RESOURCES AS WELL SUCH AS
PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF AND HEALTH
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE SO FOR SOME
COUNTY LET ACTIONS TO INCREASE
TESTING. ARE REALLY NOT
POSSIBLE. SO WILL NEED THE
SUPPORT OF THE STATE. MANY
RURAL COUNTIES OUT WILL SOON
ALSO COAST FIRE PERSONNEL
COMING FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THIS WAS SHARED BY MANY RURAL
COUNTIES WITH ME AND COUNTIES
NEED TESTING RESOURCES TO
PROTECT LOCAL COMMUNITY. ON
THAT ISSUE THERE REALLY FEELS
LIKE THERE'S A CLOCK TICKING.
MOVING ON TO CONTACT TRACING
OUR ENSURING THE CHALLENGES
THAT- HAVE BEEN COMMUNICATED
WITH ME. ROLAND POOR THE POOR
AS WELL AS CAN BE WITH A LARGE
FAR WORK. ARE OFTEN HOUSE TOO
MANY PEOPLE ONE HOME PEOPLE IN
GRAY OR SHEDS AND EVEN. TO AND
IN RURAL COMMUNITY IT BEEN TO
FIND. THAT PROVIDE ISOLATE
ROOMS FOR KOBE POSITIVE
PATIENTS ARE BROUGHT TO ALL
HOMELESS. AND UNDER HOW
INDIVIDUALS. WE LIKE WE WILL
NEED STATES. AND BE ABLE TO I
ADEQUATE THROUGH HOOKED FOR
SOME COUNT. WHY WE'RE EXCITED
SEE THE CONTRACTORS FLAP FROM
THE- DIGITAL. MANY WORLD DO NOT
INTERNET SALSA AND SOME HOMES
DURING HAVE A LAN LINE AT THE
POINT SO CONTACT TRACER OFF A
NEED TO GO HOMES ENERGY FRIDAY.
I'M FOR MEN PEOPLE QUARANTINE
OR ICE. COULD MEAN LOSS INCOME.
SO WAIT YOU'RE- OR SIX IS VERY.
I WE FOUND THAT THIS PEOPLE.
MAY NOT WANT TO BE TEST BECAUSE
THEY NEED TAKEN TO WORK AND
DON'T WANT TO THE AND IF THEIR
TASK COMES BACK POSITIVE.
SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT KEY ON
SHARE THEIR- AS WELL ANY MAGIC
MIGHT NOT BE THE- SENT WHO
WANTS TO BE THE RE WHY CALLED.
CAN'T COME TO. I'M FOR THESE
AND MANY REASONS CONTACT
RAISING AND- MY MORE OF THE
HAND PROCESS REQUIRES STOP THAT
HAVE COMMUNITY. CULTURAL
AWARENESS AND SAW SKILLS
REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO BUILD.
WITH CLIENTS THAT WERE
INTERVIEWED AND SERVING CORPS
TATIAN CORN TO AND ICE ORDERS.
RURAL COMMUNITIES FROM THE AREA
IS LIKE NOT A PLUG AND PLAY.
IT'S GONNA REQUIRES WORK
ADDITIONAL TRADE ON TOP OF
EVIDENCE BASED TRAINING GOING
TO BE BY THE STATE. AND MANY
BROKEN ACCOUNT IS MAY OUGHT TO
USE A LOCAL SOURCED STAFFING
AND USE THE STATE PROVIDED
GETTING. IN PUBLIC HEALTH WE
BUILD SKILL SETS INTO OUR STAFF
THESE SOFT SKILLS THE CULTURE
AWARENESS THE- TO REALLY.
COMMUNITY CONTACT. IN THE BILL
AND DELIVERING. PUBLIC HEALTH.
HONORING BASIS. SO AND PRACTICE
ARE DEVELOPED ACROSS THE TO OF
PUBLIC IT'S NOT JUST OUR-
DISEASE PRO. AND ON A BASIS
PUBLIC HEALTH USES XIN ABOUT
FORTY STRATEGIES TO PREVENT
ILLNESS AND ALL OTHER HEALTH
WONDER PLEASE SO THANK SUCH
TRANSMITTED DISEASE. CHRONIC EL.
THIRTIES HOMELESSNESS AND SEVEN
YES. AND WE'VE SEEN OTHER
SECTORS ACROSS THE AND ECONOMY
ARE IN. WHEN WE DO ADEQUATE
STAFFED HEALTH. I LOOK PUBLIC
HEALTH A MAN TO RISK TO THREE
LIKE CO. AND WE ARE IN HONOR TO
STEP FOR AND SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY. I'M KNOW WHAT PUBLIC
AND SEE HOW THIS MAN TO. AND
MANDATES THE TO COME WITH
APPROPRIATE RE. AS WE THIS
THREE WE NEED TO PUT LOCALLY
FOR SALUTE IN THAT US AGAINST
THEM PUBLIC HEALTH SCRATCH. I
YOU FOR THIS OP TO PARTICIPATE
THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU VERY
MISSED WE APPRECIATE THAT WORK
THE MOVING ON TO MEMBER
QUESTIONS AS WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE PANEL. ABOUT I. MY CAR TO
RAISE THEIR- ARE YOU CAN FIND
THE LINK ON THE RIGHT OR FEAR
PRESENT LIKE SENATOR JONES YOU
CAN RAISE YOUR PHYSICALLY SO.
I'M HEAD START WITH AN AND
CENTER COVER YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
WE WILL SEE WITH SAN DODD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR THE-
TO SERVE ON THIS COMMITTEE IT I
DO HAVE TO. HERE. ONE
CONGRADULATIONS I THINK YOU
KNOW. THE AMOUNT OF WORK TO DO
GONE INTO THE TWO THE TEST
PROGRAMS. ARE BETTER AND BETTER
WE'VE GOT MORE AMBITIOUS GOAL.
ARE SIR NESTS AYE SIR CAN GROW
THE- IN HIS TEAM THEIR GOALS IN
THIS AREA. BUT I GUESS THAT WE
ME TO A ASKED TO QUESTIONS ONE.
WHY WOULD WE- ALLOW FARMS. TO
BE TO MOVE TO ADD OFFER THESE
TESTS A DIE. TEST. FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND TO THE STATE OF
FLORIDA THEIR LICENSE NO WAY
THEY'RE DOING AREA YOUR SIXTY
FIVE. UP BRICKS IN MORE
PHARMACY IN THE STATE OF. IT
ALSO FOR. YEAH I THINK I MIGHT
ADD JUST ONE AS THEY EQUITY
ISSUE. ALL MAY BE A DOCUMENTED
YEAH WE ALSO HAVE HIGH.
SALVATION ARMY. IT'S A
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR LET ME LOOK LET
YOUR TO THAT NOW QUICK ASK YOU
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR. YES
PLEASE. GREAT YOU AND THE
QUESTION DIRECTED TO. WHOEVER
THINKS THAT THEY CAN ANSWER THE
BEST ALL RIGHT GREAT PERFECT
THANK YOU IF WE CAN HAVE OUR-
ANSWER THAT QUESTION WOULD BE.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THAT
FIRST PLEASE. DOCTOR DEAN. I'M
HAPPY TEARS LOOKING FOR HOW TO
RAISE MY HAND FIRST LET ME
CHECK AND SEE IF MY CO PAUL
MARK OF IT POLLARD ABLE ARE YOU
ARE ON SO. I THINK YES ON SO
TAKE A AT THAT AND SAY WE ARE
ARABS. NUMBER OF HAVING TEST
UBIQUITOUS THIS AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE MAY BE
MANY ENTITY THAT ARE A TO
CONVEY THAT. ON I'M NOT GOING
TO THE BEST PERSON TO SPEAK TO
WHAT ON. HURDLES MIGHT BE FOR
FARMERS CAN TESTS IN OF THE
FOR. I OTHER THAN TO SAY IT'S
YOU KNOW EXT TEST RAPIDLY AS
OUR GOAL. ANYONE WHO IS A TO
COME TESTS WE WANT THAT HAPPEN
IN OUR WILLING AND TO PARTNER
THEM TO HAPPEN. I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE. RULES ARE OUT
OF MY REVIEW REALLY AREN'T.
OKAY GREAT. THANK YOU HI MY
DOCTOR. AND BELIEVE THERE'S A
SECOND. FROM SAN DODD. YOUR ON
MUTE CENTER DON. SENATOR DODD
YOU'RE ON MUTE OKAY THERE YOU
ARE. YEAH WE'RE OFF NOW GREAT
IT. IT'S UNDERSTANDING THAT FOR
COULD DO ALL FLU TO EVERYTHING
BUT THERE'S REGULAR WILL THE
STATE TODAY. WILL NOT ALLOW
THEM TO MOVE FOR SO THAT NEED
TO BE A DOES. I REALLY AS SOON
AS THE- FALL OF THE SECOND
QUESTION IT'S MY INNER THAT AND
CHEN TO ARE. SURE OF WHAT WE
SHOULD BE GOINGTHIS IT AND-
DEVELOP AIDS ARE A- IN THIS
AREA TO. SAY SOME PRODUCTS THAT
ARE BEFORE THE DAY I GUESS YEAH
IN A PART OF THAT IS IT RESULTS
IN TESTING OF INDUSTRY MAY. YOU
THE RESPONSE IN APPARENTLY IT'S
A OF THE- I DO WANT TO
UNDERSTAND. CORD OF WHAT WE'RE
USING TODAY I JUST TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PART OF
HEALTH LOW INTO THAT OR THE-
COMMITTEE IS LOOKING INTO THAT
INDUSTRY AS I THE BILL THAT'S-
COULD BE ROLLED. BOTH THESE
QUESTION REALLY REALLY TO GET
MORE MORE TESTING. OR MORE IF.
THAT'S WE ARE THANK YOU THERE.
THANK YOU SO DODD WOULD ANYONE
TO CHIME IN AND DOCTOR I SEE
YOUR HAND REYES OF THE AN-
QUESTION YOU. IN YOUR ON MUTE
WILL AHEAD AND ON ME HER THANK
YOU CAN'T. I THANK YOU FOR THAT
ON. I WILL CLICK ALL TALK ABOUT
THEIR CRAPPY TESTING BECAUSE
YOU'RE AB. RIGHT THAT RAPID
TESTERS ARE REAL CRITICAL WAS.
MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE THE
FOR. IN YOU KNOW I HAVE RAPTOR
ARE AND FOR PC ARE FOR
MOLECULAR TESTER SOME RAP AND-
I TESTS THAT ARE BEING IN THIS.
I'M YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF THAT
ABBOTT ID NOW THAT'S IN C. R.
MALEK TASK. ON WE DISCOVERED A
YOU THOSE AT THE SAN. ARE YOU
WAITING A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TASKS AND SO I THINK WHAT YOU
MAY BEEN REFERRING TO WAS
CALLED LATERAL FLOW ASK DAYS IT
LOOKS LIKE A LITTLE PREGNANCY
TEST. WHERE YOU CAN TAKE A DROP
OF BLOOD DROP. THAT TEST AND A
POSITIVE ID OR I THE- WITHIN A
YOU KNOW FIFTEEN. FRAME ON.
WE'RE VERY OP. THAT THE BE
PASSED LIKE THAT WELL THAT WILL
HAVE REALLY GO SENSE. AND BEST
CITY. AT THIS TIME BASED ON OUR
VALUES. OF THE STORE TEN OUT.
ON OUR- IS THAT THE BEST SENSE.
AND I IS STILL DONE ON. LAB
MACHINE. AND THAT IS IT LONGER
BUT LONGER TERM AROUND MEAN OUR
CONTRACT A FIFTEEN. ON YOUR
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THERE'S A
NON OF TESTS THE MARK WHERE WE
THIS. SHOULD INDICATE YEAH AND
ARE YOU. AND THAT'S WHY WERE
CAUTION PEOPLE THEY AND- IT
MIGHT BE USEFUL A POP LEVEL
IT'S NOT GONNA. SOMEONE IS
BEING SO WE ARE OFTEN BEING
BALLOTS TO CALM BUT WE'RE
REALLY KERR FOR THE IN YOUR
THAT THAT WHEN IT CARE TO ARE
ICING CHEAPER. GREAT THANK YOU
TO DEAN. APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR QUESTION
WILL. NEXT GO TO UNDER BAKE.
THERE ARE NONE. YOUR WE CAN
HEAR YOU THANK YOU THANK GOD
YOU TO THE SENSOR PRO TEM WE
THIS TO IT SO VERY SO WE ALL
AND WHY WE ARE WHERE WE TO GO
MICHAEL IS SIDE TO THE IN THE
DEMAND ISSUE OF THE CAPACITY
THAT WE ARETO DO THAT. THE
HELPFUL AS WE DO AN OUTREACH TO
HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
MOVING INTO TIER ONE. UP FOR
PRIORITY THAT THEY CAN BE
TESTED. MAYBE SHOULD BE TESTED.
UNDER THE THAT WE STARTED TO I
THINK EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT. THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
WITH SOMEONE LIKE TO COMMENT ON
THAT FROM THE PANEL. IF PASSED
THE IN DEMAND ISSUES. OKAY
DOCTOR DEAN GO AHEAD. I'M GONNA
START I'M GONNA HAND OVER
TEMPLE MARKOVIC SO THERE'S THE
POWER POINT FOR OUR
PRESENTATION WILL WORK BUT
YOU'RE NOT GETTING HERE BUT WAS
PROVIDED DOES THIS SLIDE THAT
LOOKS AT THE BIG FAN THE
MACHINES HI THROUGH THAT ARE IN
STOCK ACROSS. THE STATE. OKAY
S. BUT LOOKING AT THOSE
MACHINES THAT'S WHEN WE WHEN WE
SAY WE HAVE THE CAPACITY IT'S
LOOKING AT ALL THE MACHINES
ACROSS THE STATE AT THAT HIGH
THROUGHPUT AND WE KNOW THAT
ADEQUATE PASSED IN THOSE CHAINS
ON TURN OVER AT. ALL THANK I
APPRECIATE THAT SO THAT THE
CAPACITY ON THE DEMAND QUESTION
THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN ONE IS- PEOPLE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GET REFERRED FOR
A TASK AND NAKED TESTING
GUIDELINES AFTER DEAN WAS
TALKING ABOUT. A YOU KNOW THE
PRIORITY ONE THIRTY TWO-
ETCETERA. AT THIS POINT IS A
KNOT TESTING CAPACITY THAT
THERE'S BEEN GUIDANCE TO EXPAND
TESTING IN PARTICULAR THE FOCUS
ON THE NEXT PRIORITY WHICH IS-
LARGELY ABOUT. AND WORKERS
HOSPITAL THEN MATH- AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND SO I
THINK IT'S HELP THESE ARE
SPECIFIC LOCALITIES ARE LOOKING
TO EXPAND TESTING IN REFERRAL.
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT PLACE TO
LOOK IT'S TRYING TO EXPAND
TESTING AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE'S ACCESS. TO BEEN
REFERRED TO A TASK. I'LL BE
ABLE TO GO SOMEWHERE AND HAVE A
SPECIMEN TAKEN A NAP BUT WE'RE
HOPING THIS NETWORK OF
COLLECTION SITE THAN OTHER
METHODS. FIVE THAT WE ARE. TO
THOSE FOLKS. I AMPLE MEANS BY
WHICH WE CAN COLLECT THE
SPECIMENS. AND SEND TO THE LABS
WHICH ARE RIGHT NOW TELLING US
CONSISTENTLY. PLENTY OF
CAPACITY THEY JUST NEED MORE
STAFF LIMóN SO. THAT'S WHY
THERE'S SO MUCH FOCUS RIGHT NOW
ON TRYING TO EXPAND. REFERRED
FOR CAT AND A PATH TO THE TO BE
ABLE TO BE ON. ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO COLLECT A SPECIMEN FROM
THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANSWER I JUST WANTED TO-
AND I AM I ON STILL YET RUN IT
LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT THERE IS
THAT CONFUSION YEAH COMMUNITY
BELOW ARE. SOME ARE ODD COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE GETTING.
ICE YOU'RE NOT MEETING OR
THOUSAND. OR WHATEVER THAT. THE
IN A SIGN OR THE FIGURE OUT
CAPITA THAT WHAT THERE'S TO BE
SO I SOME GUIDANCE FROM ALL OF
YOU TO HAVE US THE LOCAL LEVEL
I HAD TO EXPLAIN THAT IN THAT
WILL ENCOURAGE PEOPLE. TO
ACCEPT AND WANT TO BE TO WHEN
TO THE ARE OUT BROAD CAN. RIGHT
NOW I HAD THIS. WITH OUR
MINISTRATION JUST THE OTHER DAY
THEY SAID THERE IS REALLY AYE A
MISCOMMUNICATION OUR CAPACITY
VERSUS DEMANDING GETTING TO THE
DEMAND SIDE YOU ALL NEED US.
GLAD TO READ THAT WERE IN OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE IT WILL BE
SOLD. AS CALLING. OUR ISSUE.
THANK YOU ARE NOW ONE OTHER
QUESTION WHEN WE EXPAND. THE
OUR CAPACITY TO GOOGLE AND- THE
OTHER ONE. NUMBER THE AMAZON
AND GOOGLE I BELIEVE ARE THERE
ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT PRIVACY ON
OUT IN ARE WE LOOKING OUT OF
THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS PRIVACY HELLO SIGN
MAJOR PLATFORMS ARE INVOLVED.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR BATES DO
WE HAVE AN ANSWER TO THAT FROM
OUR PANELISTS ABOUT THE PRIVACY
ISSUES AND I THINK MS FINELLI
IS RAISING HER HAND CIVIL.
UNDETERRED BOOKING USING SOME
OF THE APPS IS MAYBE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT- A LOT APPS OUT THERE
pHOW CLOSE SOMEONE IS YOUR PHONE
HOW ALL OF THESE KIND OF WAYS
OF JUST. KEATING THAT SOMEBODY
IS IN THE- PERIMETER OF ANOTHER
PERSON BUT THE APPS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT USING. REALLY ARE
JUST DATA MANAGEMENT AND TOOLS
TO MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT. AND
CLEARLY THE PRIVACY WILL BE
LEFT TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
CONTACT RACERS WHO ONLY BE
LOOKING AT THOSE CASES I'M
DOING MORE OF THE TRADITIONAL
REACH OUT- AND CLEARLY
PROTECTING THE- PRIVACY WILL
BE. IN ALL OF OUR INTERESTS
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT THAT SORT.
APPS THAT ARE MEASURING HOW
PEOPLE ARE MOVING IN AND THOSE
KINDS OFTHINGS AT LEAST NOT IN
THIS INITIAL PHASE. THANK YOU.
I'M CULTURE DID YOU AVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR US. NO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GREAT ARE
WE WILL MOVE ON TO SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
CAN YOU HEAR ME. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I WANT
TO THANK GOD YOU ARE NOT TO
JEAN AND- OFFICERS ON. ORDERING
AMAZING WORK I WAS HEARING THIS
I'M PRESIDENT AND DAMMIT THANK
YOU. I HAVE A IT'S JUST A FEW
QUESTIONS I THINK COLLEAGUES
DOCTOR GENE BUT- HEALTH OFFICE
MAY START TO. THE FIRST IS ARE
WE KNOW THAT ON CONGREGATE
SETTINGS INCLUDING PRESENTS ARE
A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN AROUND
SPREAD OF THE CONTAGION ARMY IN
ADDITION TO OF COURSE NURSING
HOMES ALMOST LL STARTUP. ARE
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAD A CALL
THIS MORNING WITH SECRETARY DO
YOU GUYS AREN'T THEY ARE DOING
A LOT OF FOCUS WORK TRUSTS ARE
PROBLEMS OUR PRISON SYSTEM. I
ARE. A FROM REDUCING
POPULATIONS WE ON THE NATURAL
ARE CONTINUALLY FIRST RELEASING
PEOPLE- FROM PRESENT AS THEIR
TERMS EXPIRE GOING ROLE FOR
WHATEVER REASON. AND THE
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE WE DOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
RELEASING PEOPLE WHO ARE.
POSITIVE THE GENERAL POPULATION
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO TEST OUT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
RELEASED SIR IF YOU DAYS
BEFORE- ARE THERE RELEASED SO
WE KNOW IF THEY NEED TO BE.
ORANGE UNIVERSAL BEING USED TO
BE THOUGHT. TOM ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THERE WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
WINNER. SO RELATED TO NURSING
HOMES AND OF COURSE OUR-
FACILITIES- PRISON FACILITIES
SO ANY ANSWERS ON THAT- FROM
THE PANEL AND I HAVE MISSPENT
FINITELY. I CAN JUST START BY
FIRST OF ALL FOR OUR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY SO WE ARE
WORKING EVERY DAY WHAT ARE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
HELLO I'M CALLING THEM EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND INNER- SURVEY
I'M TO SEE WHAT THEIR IMMEDIATE
NEEDS ARE WE ARE PROVIDING IN
FACT PREVENTION. TRAINING AS
WELL ON SITE INFECTION FROM
LAST YOU. YOU INFECTION ONCE
WE'VE I'M ISOLATED THE CASE OR
MULTIPLE CASES IN A FACILITY WE
ARE SENDING OUT STRIKE TEAMS TO
HELP WITH I'M IMMEDIATE
STAFFING NEEDS WORK OR
SOMETIMES PEOPLE ARE. IN WHEN
THEY HAVEN'T BURKE CASES THEY
ARE ALSO IMPACTING THE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS BUT NOT ONLY
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHO ARE SICK
BUT SOME HEALTH CARE WORKERS
WHO ARE SCARED TO COME TO WORK
AND- I'M SHOVEL. THAT WE HAVE
AND TAKING ON A NUMBER OF ACT
IS TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN THEY GAVE. YOU MAY WANT TO
PLANT ON THE WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING IN ALLENTOWN BECAUSE- OF
NUMBER OF THEIR SKILLS.
FACILITIES ALSO HAVE OUTBREAKS
AND WE'VE BEEN. PARTNERING WITH
THEM- AS WELL AS OUR LICENSING
FUNCTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHERE SOME OF THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY ARE PART OF. A
BIGGER. ROCK PALM MORE SOME OF
THE BAKER. OPERATORS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT THEY ARE INDEED IN
THEIR OWN WORK FORCE AND MOVING
THEM AROUND INCLUDE ACTION
PREVENTION ASSUMING. JUST LOST
WHERE THEY MIGHT BE TO MOVE THE
AROUND BUT IT'S A CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT IT SET UP TO BE
CONGREGATE AT HOME AND SO ONCE
AN INFECTION IS IN LINE I'M A
SAYS IT IS HARD. BY THE TIME
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN CONTROL IT
AND- YEAH OFTENTIMES BY THE
TIME YOU GET ONE CASE YOU KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL CASES
WITH. THE QUICKLY ON THE WORK
WE ARE DOING THE STATE PRISONS.
WE ARE ARE WE HAVE AN
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH PROGRAM AND
OUR SCIENCES BRANCH WITHIN OUR
INFECTIOUS DISEASE PROGRAM. AND
ARE I'M HEALTHCARE ACQUIRED
INFECTION. PARTNERED UP WITH
THE I. AND CDC ARE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE GOOD PROTOCOLS
IN PLACE TO PROTECT THE INMATES
TO ISOLATE. AND QUARANTINE NOT
NOT NECESSARY BUT ALL TO WORK
ON. A STAFFING SIDE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE GOOD
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH PROCEDURES
IN PLACE AS WELL. AND AS FAR AS
AND- I'M PROBABLY A LETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THE PRISONS
TRYING TO DO A WARM HAND OFF
SOMETHING THAT. IF SOME IS. IT
QUARANTINE OR THEY'VE BEEN I'M
WITH THEN THAT THE LOCAL HEALTH
CARE IS AS NOTRE THAT'S NOT
WORKING PERFECTLY AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT SO
THAT WE GET A ONE HAND SO THAT
THEY AREN'T LOSS TO **** ON TAX
WHEN THEY GO OUT BACK OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY BUT NOT MADE THAT
QUESTIONS ARE THESE AREN'T
PEOPLE BEING SINCE WE TEST. IF
YOU DAYS BEFORE. YES SIR WE
KNOW WHEN IS HAVE YOU KNOW
SOUND OFF. THIS PERSON JUST
TOUCHED UPON FOR THIS PERSON
JUST TESTED NEGATIVE. I THINK
THAT IS THE CDC OUR QUESTION
LARGELY I KNOW THAT THEY ARE
TESTING SOME PEOPLE THEY ARE
NOT. THEY CAN'T MANDATE TESTING
AND SO SOME OF THE NOT WANT TO
BE TESTED I'M ALSO TING
PROTOCOLS THAT THEY PUT IN
PLACE AS JAY WHO GETS TESTED
THEN WHY IN TERMS OF- IF THEY
WORK SCOTT BACK TO OUR- I'M QUE
BUT THERE I DO. BELIEVE THERE
AVERAGE FOR THE A LOT. I LOOK
NOT REALLY SHE. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR THAT ON MY CHAIR RIGHT NEXT
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH THE
COLLECTION OF DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
SO THAT WE KNOW. WHO WHICH
COMMUNITIES MIGHT BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY ARE BY
PROVING NINETEEN WE KNOW
BECAUSE OF DEMOCRATIC
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA COLLECTION.
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS
BEING VERY DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED PARTICULARLY AROUND
HOSPITALIZATIONS I SEE YOU ARE
AND DUST IT'S REALLY JUST- JUST
HORRIBLY TRIES NOT ACCEPTABLE
ARE WE KNOW THAT THE LET'S YOU
KNOW COMMUNITY AS WELL WE DID
SOME RESEARCH INTENSIVE TESTING
IN THE NATION. AND 95% OF THE
POSITIVE WHERE IS FEWER THAN
HALF OF THE PEOPLE TESTED RELY
NOT. THIS PERSON I'M BUT I'M
NOT DATA IS EXTREMELY USEFUL
BECAUSE NOW WE KNOW WHERE TO
FOCUS RESOURCES IN ADDRESSING
INEQUITIES I'M GLAD WE'RE
GETTING NOT VERY DISTURBING
DATA. SYNC WITH EACH. ONE AS
FAR S I CAN TELL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ART THESE ARE
COLLECTING ALL ESSENTIALLY NO
DATA ON THE IMPACT. THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY THIS IS. WITH THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY ARE NOT
COLLECTING DATA RELATING THE
LGBTQ PEOPLE ALWAYS MAKES OUR
COMMUNITY AND BEST OF ALL ARE
WE KNOW THAT OF THE TEACHERS
YOUR CALL HAVE INCREASED HEALTH
RISK FACTORS. AROUND INCREASED
RATES OF SMOKING I'M SORRY BE
INCREASED RATES OF CERTAIN
CANCERS ARE INCREASED RATE
HOMELESSNESS AND YET WE HEAR
THE CLUB YOU KNOW EIGHT OUT
TWENTY TEAM. MEMBER DAVID CHIU
ALL PASSED LEGISLATION. WE
THANK OUR CHOIR CHANGES
DATABASE IS TO. OUR COLLECT.
MORE DATA. ABOUT HEALTH AND
LGBT YOUR ANY THAT DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE HOPPING SO ON. WE
AND WITH THE GOVERNOR ABOUT
THIS WE SPOKE WITH CITY PH ON
OUR- DOCTOR DEAN ARTICLE
COMMENT ON WHY THIS ISN'T
HAPPENING ON WHAT IS GOING HOW
THE HELL IS GOING TO CHANGE
BECAUSE WE NEED TO COLLECT A-
HI THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
THIS IS CHARITY DEAN. I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE LARGER ISSUE OF
OUR DATA THAT'S BEING COLLECTED
IN OTHER PLACES- OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
THAT WAS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION WE HAD AROUND
COLLECTION OF DATA FOR THOSE
THAT WERE STANDING UP. ON AND
WE'RE LOOKING OUT ALTHOUGH WE
HAVEN'T LAUNCH THE PLATFORM YET
THIS GOING TO BE COLLECTING
DEMOGRAPHIC AND PERSONAL
INFORMATION LOOK IT UP AND
SERVE SITE THAT'S IN THE WORKS
RIGHT NOW. ON THE NET WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATION I COLLECT BEING
SENT OUR INTENTION AND GENDER
IDENTITY BECAUSE WE AGREE
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT JOINT
PRESS. I EIGHT HEAR YOUR
CONCERNS THAT WE NEED TO SEE
THAT CRITICAL DATA AND BACK TO
THE MISSION STUDY THAT YOU AND
WE LOOKED AT THAT AND I AM AND
WE KNOW. THIS THANK. YOU SHOW
HIM DISTRICT. AND WE AGREED WE
NEED TO THAT TELL YOU BEACH CAN
YOU. THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU NOT WE DO HAVE
PENDING JUST WHEN I COOPERATE
ON FINE QUESTION MY CHAIR I'M
PASSED DO WITH BY. ON MENTAL
HEALTH AND A- ARE DURING THIS.
AND DAM ACT ARE WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY. IN NINETEEN MAJOR
CHALLENGES AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
AND ADDICTION IN OUR STATE ARE
WE SEE IT ON OUR STREETS ARE
ALMOST POPULATION BUT IT WELL
BEYOND HOMELESSNESS AND LACK OF
ACCESS TO TREAT MEDICARE. AND
THE DATA THAT I'VE BEEN SEEING
ABOUT OUR COULD BE NINETEEN
AMOUNTS ALTHOUGH DICTION I
VERY VERY TROUBLING. ARE WE
KNOW PEOPLE ARE ISOLATED ARE
UNDER ENORMOUS STRESS AND
ANXIETY ARE LOSING JOBS I'M
HAPPY TO. GET YOUR WORK WATER
ALSO. HER EYES. ARE HEALTH
PROBLEMS JUST ENORMOUS ENORMOUS
HEALTH ECONOMIC SOCIAL STRESS
AND ANXIETY. THESE CALLS TO
SUICIDE HOTLINES. AND SO FORTH
IT'S FVE CITY PH AND I THINK
ALSO ARTS THE COUNTY OFFICERS
IF YOU WANT TO ADD YOUR COMMENT
ON. THE IMPACTS THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN CALIFORNIA ALL FROM
KOBE NINETEEN OR MENTAL HEALTH
AND ADDICTION I KNOW IT'S EARLY
DAYS BUT THERE I KNOW THERE IS
SOME EMERGING INFORMATION YOUR
COMMENT ON NOT I WOULD. THANK
YOU SENATE RATE. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT ON THAT. MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION QUESTION.
WE CAN ALSO RECEIVE- COMMENTS
FROM OUR COUNTIES IF THERE ARE
ANY THAT I KNOW LA COUNTY JUST
PERSONALLY DOES A LOT OF GREAT
WORK IN THAT SPACE- EITHER
MADERA COUNTY WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR FROM EACH OF YOUR
PERSPECTIVES AS WELL. TO RAISE
YOUR HANDS ALL AT ONCE DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ELSE YOU'D LIKE
TO. THINK. DO WE HAVE SOMEBODY
ON THE LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES DOCTOR
DAVIS THERE YOU GO. OKAY THANKS
TO RAISE MY HAND I WAS JUST
WAITING PATIENTLY UP SORRY
ABOUT THAT- NO NO PROBLEM AT
ALL YOU KNOW I THINK YOU KNOW
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE- THAT
YOU KNOW. THE NUMBER OF REPORTS
BASED ON THE FACT ABOUT IF YOU
HAVE GONE UP- WE OFF OF THE
FACT THAT. THAT WILL START TO
SEE WHAT WE HAVE PATIENT BACK
THROUGH THEIR PROVIDERS OR GO
BACK PREVENTIVE CARE WE MAY BE
MORE IN RELATIONSHIP. YOUR
BETTER UP. AT THIS POINT I
DON'T HAVE. DATA IN
RELATIONSHIPS THAT. I HAVE
MANY. PEOPLE HAVE YOU KNOW BEEN
AT HOME FOR THE MOST PART.
ABOUT WE EXPECT THAT THERE WILL
BE FROM UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT HAVE COME FROM THAT. WE
WILL BE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY AT
THAT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR DAVIS A APPRECIATE THAT
AND ANY OTHER ANSWERS. FROM THE
PANELISTS. MS BOSSY. THANK YOU
WE HAVE BEEN- PARTNERING
LOCALLY WITH OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT I TO REALLY-
INCREASE- SURVEILLANCE WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE KNOWN
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES FOR SURE.
ALL WE'RE ALSO PARTNERING WITH-
MINISTERIAL ASSOCIATION AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS I
TO MAKE RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND
TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND THE
SAFE WAYS IN WHICH THEY CAN. BE
ACCESSIBLE FOR- COUNSELING AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND HELP. IT
OUT WE DO EXPECT AS DOCTOR
DAVIS- SAID THAT- MIGHT MANYOF
THESE ISSUES ARE STILL HIDDEN
AT HOME. AND ESPECIALLY AS WE
OPEN SCHOOLS BACK UP AND THERE
IS MORE INNER INTERACTION WITH
MANDATED REPORTERS WERE
EXPECTING INCIDENTS OF- CHILD
ABUSE CASES DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OTHER SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES-
TO GO BACK UP TO LEVELS AS THEY
WERE AND PROBABLY HIGHER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT- I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND NEXT
WE WILL HAVE SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON. MY OWN. YOU'RE ON
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO GET BACK
TO THE- THE TESTING IN THE
TRACING ISSUE- AND THEN I HAVE
A QUESTION ON THE PRIVACY
ASPECTS- I'D LIKE A RIVER I'D
LIKE YOUR RESPONSES- FROM THE
PANELISTS ON THE PHONE AT THE
SWIMMING IN MY- ASSUMPTIONS ARE
ACCURATE- WE ARE NOW MOVING
INTO PHASE TWO THE GOVERNOR IS
INDICATED THAT HE FEELS THAT
WE'VE MET ENOUGH OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF HIS SIX
CRITERIA THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD. SO AS I LOOK AT THAT
MICHAEL AND I ASK MYSELF AND I
ALREADY LIKE YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS
I'M NOT OF THE WE HAVE HAD
ADEQUATE TESTING. OR TRAINING
FIX THAT NOW I KNOW I'VE
WORKING RIGHT IN DR DEAN THANK
YOU FOR GREAT EFFORTS IN ALONG
WITH YOUR SILENT ALMOST.
PARTNERS THE- WITH BLUE SHIELD.
SO WE HAVEN'T HAD ENOUGH IN WHO
WE BEEN TESTING WE PRIORITIZE
TWO ONE WAR A HIGH RISK PEOPLE
WE'VE EXPANDED THAT NOW TO
INCLUDE A SYMPTOMATIC FRONTLINE
WORKERS- THERE AND ALSO PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO GET TESTED TO
THE EXTENT THEY CAN GET A
DOCTOR'S PERMISSION TO DO SO
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT ABOUT 80%
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE INFECTED
BY OR AND CAN TAKE THIS WILL.
THIS VIRUS I'M SHOW NO SYMPTOMS
SO THEY ARE ASYMPTOMATIC- AS WE
TRY TO I ASSUME CONTAIN THIS.
OF VIRUS AND I ASSUME THAT'S
THE REASON FOR TESTING IN
TRACING AND I'D- LOVE TO HEAR
WHETHER OR NOT I'VE GOT THAT
ASSUMPTION CORRECT. BUT HOW IS
IT THAT WITH THE NUMBER OF
TESTS THAT WE ARE DOING OR THAT
WE THINK WE CAN DO AND THE
DELAY IN. GETTING THOSE
RESULTS. WE FEEL AS THOUGH WE
ARE MOVING TOWARD CONTAINMENT
WHEN WE ALREADY IN TESTING I'M
80% OF THE POPULATION. I THAT
IS LIKELY NOT TO EVEN SHOW
SYMPTOMS. SO HOW DO YOU WANT TO
THAT CONCERN I THAT WE- UNLESS
YOU CAN TELL US RIGHT THE ONLY
AND I HAVEN'T ANYBODY TALKING
ABOUT THAT OR- WHETHER THESE
NUMBERS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
POTENTIALLY WHAT WAS IT SIXTY
THOUSAND THAT YOU'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO- HOW IS THAT GOING
TO. OUR LESS TO THE POINT OF
CONTAINMENT MOVE US TO THE
POINT WHERE PEOPLE- CAN FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE CAN FEEL SAFE
FOR A LOOSENING UP THE RULES
GOING OUT IN PUBLIC MORE.
RATHER THAN THE STATE HOME
REQUIREMENT THAT WE HAVE NOW
AND THAT IS ABOUT TO END. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S YEP
DR DEAN. QUESTION ALL ALL START
IN AND TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
MARKOVIC IF HE WANTS TO ADD ON
TO WHAT I HAVE TO SAY- WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S STILL NOT ENOUGH
TESTING YOU KNOW WE HAVE HIT
THAT THIRTY THOUSAND TEST TODAY
BUT THAT'S NOT ENOUGH. I'M WE
HAVE MORE WORK TO DO WE KNOW WE
NEED TO BE UP INTO THE SIXTY TO
EIGHTY THOUSAND TEST DAY TO HIT
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE
TESTED ON WHEN WE EXPAND AND
THAT OUR STATE GUIDANCE LAST
WEEK IF YOU LOOK AT IT YOU'LL
SEE IT WHEN THE REASON WE SAY
IT'S FURTHER EXPANDED. IS IN
PRIORITY ONE IT'S A VERY LARGE
BUCKET IN INCLUDES YOU KNOW
SYMPTOMATIC PEOPLE IN IN A HOST
OF DIFFERENT ESSENTIAL
OCCUPATION- AND IF YOU DO THE
MATH ON THAT IT'S A REALLY
LARGE NUMBER OF. CALLS A YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. WE I AM IN
TESTING ON THAT FOR CON BEST TO
GATE. OTHER WORDS IN ORDER TO
THE BREAD AND BUTTER PUBLIC
HEALTH STRATEGY OF CONTAINMENT
IS TO CREATE A REALLY AREN'T
ACCURATE CONTACT INVESTIGATION
WHERE YOU CAN TRACK AND TRACE
AND IDENTIFY ANYONE WHO IS
EXPOSED AND TEST THEM AND
PARTICULARLY TO THE POINT THAT
YOU MAKE WITH THIS AFTER JANET
CAN- HAVE THOSE ARE INFECTIOUS
A SYMPTOMATIC TRACKING IN
TRACING TESTING THOSE THAT MEET
INFECTIOUS BASIN TO NOT A
REALLY IMPORTANT. AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE WORKING ON THE TURN
AROUND TIME TESTS WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE GOING TO BE
ADDITIONAL TESTING MODALITIES-
LET RAPID WHEN SAYING OF THE
VIRUS- WE ARE NOT TO DEPLOY NOW
TWICE. IN FORTY WE HIS THAT IS
THAT GOING TO ABILITY IT'S HELP
A SCALE ACOSTA I'M AND I THE
RIGHT TURNAROUND THAT WE SO
THERE'S MORE WERE TO BE DONE WE
KNOW MADE SOME PROGRESS BUT WE
WITH YOU THAT WE NEED TO BE
FASTER AND WE NEED TO BE
DEPLOYED. A QUICK FOR THOSE
CONTACT INVESTIGATION. MISTER
MARK ANY OUT ON THOSE. THANK
YOU YES I SAY YOU KNOW I WERE.
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
NEARLY FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AND TO HAVE THEM
ALL AT ONE WORST QUOTE IN A
VERY CLOSE PERIOD OF TIME WITH
A MEDIATOR NEAR IMMEDIATE
RESULTS AND UNDERSTAND EXACTLY.
WHERE THE VIRUS DID AT THAT
POINT THAT WOULD BE IDEAL IT'S
ALSO NOT FEASIBLE WITH THE
CURRENT TECHNOLOGY AND CAPACITY
AND SUPPLIES- AND SO I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE DONE. YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF FINDING A DRAMATIC
CARRIERS. WITH THE IN PLACE
ORDERS GOING ON FOR WEEKS BUT
THE SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND AMOUNT
WAS- AT A NUMBER OF COMPONENTS
ONE OF WHICH IS REGULARLY
CASTING PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE
EXPOSURE. LIKE FRONTLINE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS. AND OR
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
KEEPING CLOSE TABS ON THEM AND
THEN FINING PEOPLE WHO IF THEY
HAPPEN TAX SHELTER IN PLACE.
AND THERE'S TYPICALLY ABOUT A
FOURTEEN DAY INCUBATION PERIOD
FOR THE VIRUS BEFORE YOU START
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS. THEN IF
YOU ACTUALLY DONE THAT EVIDENCE
IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE SHELTER IN
PLACE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN MOVING
THEN WHAT YOU DO IS YOU LOOK
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE. INTO
MATIC LATER BECAUSE RESERVE
LAID THE VAST VAST MAJORITY OF
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING OUT OF SHELTERING PLACE.
BY THEIR ALREADY PROCESSED
THROUGH. EXPERIENCING A VIRUS
OR NEVER HAD IT AND SO- THAT
THE THINKING BEHIND WHY THAT
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT TESTING IN
THE APPROACH- THAT WOULD BE
TAKEN AGAIN IN THE IDEAL WORLD
WE COULD BE DOING THAT'S WAY
MORE BROADLY- AND WE CAN
CERTAINLY POTENTIALLY EXPAND
BEYOND FIFTY THOUSAND OR TRY
TO. IMPROVE THE TURN AROUND
TIME. I CAN'T GET EVERY NEW
MIGHT BE. BACK BUT YOU HAVE TO
TEST INTO POCKET IN A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. GREAT
THANK AND SENATOR JACKSON DID
YOU HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
YOU'RE ON MUTE. YES I WOULD I
WOULD LIKE TO- I'D LIKE TO ASK
A FOLLOW UP AND THEN A QUESTION
ON THE PRIVACY ISSUE. SO GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE STILL DON'T
HAVE THAT THE TURNOUT ISN'T
THAT FAST THAT WE STILL AREN'T
ABLE TO TEST. THE SIXTY OR
SEVENTY THOUSAND WOULD YOU
BELIEVE WOULD BE APPROPRIATE-
AND ONE OF THE OPTIONS THAT
QUESTIONS WHY THAT NUMBER WHAT
DOES THAT TELL YOU- GIVEN THAT
THE FACT THAT THE- THING ISN'T
ADEQUATE. YET DAD THE TURN TIME
IS SO LOW WHY WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT WE ARE. IN A POSITION TO
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PHASE IF
WE DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE.
ATTESTING TO MEET THOSE-
PRELIMINARY OR BASED A QUESTION
AS TO WHO. I IS INFECTED AND
WHO IS POTENTIALLY TRANSMIT THE
DISEASE. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON. ARE WE GONNA SEND THAT
BACK TO. DOCTOR DEAN OR WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION PLEASE. ALL RIGHT
THERE SHE'S. I'M HAPPY TO START
AND THEN IF MY COLLEGE STUDENT
DALY WANTS TO JUMP IN ABOUT
THAT TRACK AND TRACE EFFORTS-
PLEASE DO- SO LET ME START WITH
THE OFFICE YOU QUESTION OF HOW
DID WE ARRIVE AT THAT NUMBER WE
WRITE THAT NUMBER A FEW
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND EVERYONE'S
DOING MATH TRYING TO CALCULATE
WHAT THE NUMBER METRICUS. AND
WE IS THE STATE HAVE NOT GIVEN
OUT A RECOMMENDATION TO
COUNTIES OF WHAT THEIR- ON.
METRIC IS ON A WHOLE BUT THAT.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS THE
NUMBER OF COHORTS OF PEOPLE
THAT WE NEED TO BE TESTED SO
MISTER MARK OF IT SHOULD WORK
FOR YOU. ON YOU KNOW ESSENTIAL
WORKERS FRONTLINE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS ON SAFETY OFFICERS AT
CENTER AND SO FEW OUT OF THOSE
GROUPS AND THEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FREQUENCY. WITH WHICH THEY
WOULD NEED TO BE TESTED AND
THEN YOU DIVIDE OVER TIME. YOU
COME TO AROUND THE SIXTY TO
EIGHTY THOUSAND DIAGNOSTIC ON
PCR TEST DAY. THERE ARE SOME
INTERESTING IS THAT HAVE BEEN
PUBLISHED. ON THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION WAS DONE BY
WERE THAT DID YOU ASK FOR.
THOUSAND PER DAY JUST ONE THERE
ARE STILL OTHERS. SO THAT'S HOW
ARRIVED AT THE NUMBER. I WILL
ALSO SHARE THAT. TESTING IS
JUST ONE PART OF THE STRATEGY
THAT CONTINUING TO PHYSICAL
DISTANCE AND IMPLEMENT SOCIAL
DISTANCING- WHERE POSSIBLE AND
FOLLOWING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS
REGARDING. MASS GATHERINGS OR
RESTAURANTS YOU KNOW FOLLOWING
THE SEQUENTIAL RESPONSIBLE AND-
I. LIFTING FIVE SOME OF THOSE.
MEASURE IS A RISK THE WAY TO
APPROACH THIS BECAUSE TESTING
IS IMPORTANT BUT IT'S NOT THE
ONLY THING. YOU NEED TO
PRACTICE THE GOOD HYGIENE IN
THE PHYSICAL DISTANCING- IT IS
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO YOU
AND WE KNOW THE AS INCREASE
SEROLOGY TESTING IS BEING DONE
AND FORMS WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION MAY HAVE ALREADY
BEEN A IN FACT IT. ON THAT
HELPS TO FORM WHAT WE DO BUT
AND SO WE HAVE BETTER SEROLOGY
TESTING THAT ARE RELIABLE AND A
DIAGNOSTIC LEVEL AND ON A-
BASIS IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED
CONTINUE TO BE VERY SLOW AND
VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT LIFTING
ANY OF THOSE- ANY THE STATURE
AND THE MEASURES THAT ARE PUT
IN PLACE FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING. AND
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE TO. BY THE
AT EIGHT THAT WE FEEL THERE'S
ADEQUATE DIAGNOSTIC PCR TESTING
TO SUPPORT ON THE COUNTIES
TRACK AND TRACE EFFORTS. THANK
YOU DOCTOR DEAN AND JUST DO A
QUICK TIME CHECK WITH ABOUT
FIVE MORE SENATORS AFTER
SENATOR JACKSON'S SO JUST
WANTED TO- INSURE EVERYBODY
KNEW SO SENATOR JACKSON AND YET
ONE MORE QUESTION I DO AND THIS
IS THIS IS A QUESTION ON
PRIVACY THAT WAS RAISED-
PREVIOUSLY BY SENATOR BATES- AS
WE- HAVE ADVANCED AND WE HAVE
TECHNOLOGY IS HOPEFULLY IS A-
PARTNER. IN THIS. THERE IS
CERNAN I HAVE ADDRESSED SEND TO
THE GOVERNOR SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFYING A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS ASSOCIATED WITH USING
TECHNOLOGY TO DO THE TACING
WHICH MAY BE VERY HELPFUL AND
MAY BE CRITICAL. I HAVE YET TO
HEAR THOUGH ANYTHING OTHER THAN
VERY GENERALIZED STATEMENTS. OF
ARE HOW WE ONLY ARE USING THE
INFORMATION TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THE COPING PROBLEM. BUT THE
ISSUE IS THAT THE- COMPANIES
THAT ARE PROVIDING THE
TECHNOLOGY- NEED TO BE ARMED
AS- REQUIRED. TO ASSURE US AND
TO ENTER INTO WHATEVER
CONTRACTUAL RELATIONS IF WE
DECIDE TO HAVE WITHIN. THE DATA.
IS NOT USED BY THEM OR MADE
AVAILABLE TO ANY OTHER THIRD
PARTIES. IF WE WANT PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN FEEL CONFIDENT
AND ASSURED THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT GOING
ANYWHERE IS GOING TO EACH- IT
WAS TO CREATE A PROFILE. I USED
TO AGGREGATE SOMEONE'S A
PERSONAL IN FOR WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET TO THAT SUCCESS LEVEL SO
I'M WONDERING WHAT YOU ARE
DOING. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
GOOGLES THE OTHER COMPANIES
THAT HAVE STEPPED FORWARD AND
HOPEFULLY WILL BE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL ARE NOT GOING TO THEN.
USE THAT INFORMATION IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM- BEYOND THE
LIMITED PURPOSE OF HELPING US
TRYING TO IDENTIFY THOSE MAY BE
CLOSE TO COPE WITH SO WE CAN
AYE BLADES WARRANTY MORE. IT IS
YOU CAN. THANK YOU SENATOR JACK
AND I KNOW- MISS FINALE HAD THE
LAST QUESTION THAT BOTH SENATOR
JACKSON AND- SENATOR. BATES HAD
MENTIONED SO DO YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND TRY HIM BACK IN HERE
MISTER NELLY. TOUR SO I WANT TO
ASSURE YOU THAT THE CONTRACTS
THAT WE'RE ENTERING INTO YOU
FOR THE DATA MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
AND THE SOFTWARE PIECE ARE.
FULLY PROTECTED WITH PRIVACY
AND SECURITY PROVISIONS AND SO
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO USE THAT
INFORMATION FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE SAYS AND- THEN
INFORMATION MORE COLLECTING IS
SIMPLY THE CONTACT TRACING
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT. GOOGLE
AND APPLE APPS THAT ARE
COLLECTING INFORMATION PEOPLE'S
PHONES IT'S NOT THAT KIND OF
ACT THAT WE ARE WE ARE
INVESTING AND- OKAY THANK YOU
DID YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP STRUCK
A SENATOR JACKSON. I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR US TO AT SOME POINT
BE ABLE TO. SEE THOSE CONTRACTS
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT APPLE PHONES RETIREMENT
INFORMATION. REGARDLESS OF
WHERE IT COMES FROM AND WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS. THAT HIT
BUT IS NOT APPLICABLES IN MOST
INSTANCES BECAUSE HIP ACOSTA
MEDICAL. I WAS- COMMUNICATIONS
THESE ARE COMPANIES THAT DON'T
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO HIM I KNOW
THAT WAS AN ANSWER I HAD
RECEIVED A COUPLE WEEKS AGO. IN
A COMPENSATION SOME HELP PEOPLE
SO I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
GOING FORWARD- THAT THERE BE A
CLEARER UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
COMPANIES WITH OUR- AGENCIES
WITH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH PEOPLE.
THAT THIS INFORMATION THIS IS
NOT. A TO BE MADE AVAILABLE ANY
WAY SHAPE OR- BOB ANY. I'D COME.
NEED TO. COME OTHERS OFFER.
BEYOND WHAT WE'RE SEEKING IN
TO. OF THOSE WHO MIGHT THAT BE-
INFLICTED WITH A VIRUS OR
TRANSMITTING IT. WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE AND ARE HAPPY TO SHARE-
THE CONTRACTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
I APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON AND I CERTAINLY
SURE THAT SAME- SENTIMENT AS
WELL APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER KELLY- WE'RE GONNA GO
NEXT TO SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU. THANK. SORRY ABOUT THAT
AND YOU'RE A NEEDED. THE THERE
WE GO I KEEP IT IN YOU AND I
KNEW IT AND THEN IT GETS MADE
IT'S ALL GOOD IT'S ALL GOOD
MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO FIRST SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK FOR
BRINGING US TOGETHER I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO'S WORKED INCREDIBLY
HARD TO BE ABLE TO KICK OFF
THIS CRITICAL HEARING WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO PRO TEM. IN
HER AMAZING TEAM IS TRULY
GRATEFUL TO COME TOGETHER WITH
YOU IN GREAT COMPUTER
LEADERSHIP BOTTOM CHAIR- I
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO SAY HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE I DOCTOR DEAN
HER WORK IT IS BEING STRESSFUL
TO SAY THE LEAST OVER THE PAST
TWO MONTHS INTO THE ENTIRE TEAM
AT THE COVER ART AND PUBLIC
HEALTH WHEN I SAY HOW TRULY
APPRECIATE I KNOW WE ALL ARE UP
FOR THEIR CAN WORK IN THESE
REALLY CHALLENGING TIMES AND I
THINK THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE.
YES XIN. IT'S GOING TO CAN. TO
BE CHALLENGE ACROSS THE NATION
IN. RIGHT HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE I AM. I TRULY APPRECIATE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S TAKING
TESTING. INTO OUR OWN HANDS. AS
WE KNOW. IT'S GONNA BE MORE
CHALLENGING ON THE FEDERAL SIDE.
AND I'D LIKE TO BE A FOCUS MY
COMMENTS AND I PROMISE I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF. MADAM CHAIR ON
TESTING IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS A CONVERSATION I HAD
WITH A DOCTOR DEAN I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE SPEAKING AGAIN
TOMORROW ON THIS ISSUE BUT
LOOK. TESTING IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO NUMBER ONE.
DETERMINING WHERE THE VIRUS IS
NOW. I DETERMINING- WHAT WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING LIKE AS FAR AS
RE OPENING. I EIGHT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO APPROACH THIS VIRUS.
IN THE MONTHS. AND YEARS TO
COME UNTIL WE HAD THAT VACCINE.
I AND HOW DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DETERMINED. WHERE TO
PLACE TESTING SITES NOT TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE THREE MAIN-
TERMINATIONS DRIVE TIME. NUMBER
TWO POVERTY LEVELS NUMBER THREE
ABILITY TEST FULLY SUPPORT BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT RULE
CALIFORNIA. YOU LOOK AT THAT
MAP WE NEED THE LUNCH WEBSITE
WHERE TESTING SITES. OUR STATE
SPONSORED TESTING SITES ARE
LOCATED. AT THEIR NON WILL
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO GIVE ME
AN EXAMPLE. I'M YOU CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT THE NORTH COAST NORTH
COAST RUNS FROM THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE SHOULD THE ORGAN. 40% OF
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL. I'M TO
BE ABLE TO GET FROM THE TESTING
SITE IN CINEMA COUNTY. TO THE
CLOSEST TESTING SITE NORTH IT'S
A FOUR HOUR DRIVE ON ONE ONE
FOUR HOURS. FOUR HOURS. BY
PASSES MENDOCINO COUNTY
COMPLETE I'M YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
SOME OF THE HIGHEST POVERTY
RATES IN THE STATE IT'S IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA SO I NEED
ANOTHER EXAMPLE YOU DRIVE FROM
CLEAR LIKE TO SANTA ROSA. IT'S
THE CLOSEST TESTING SITE FOR
LAKE COUNTY THERE ARE NO STATE
SPONSORED TESTING SITES LIKE
AND IT'S AN HOUR AND A HALF.
ISN'T CITY. RIGHT IN DELAWARE
COUNTY THE NORTHERN MOST COUNTY
THE STATE IT'S A TWO HOUR DRIVE.
I'M WEAVERVILLE THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. IT'S AN TRINITY COUNTY
IT'S TWO AND A HALF HOURS OR IF
YOU GO OVER THE HILL THE OTHER
WAY. WE'RE READY. I SAY ALL
THIS IS WE THEN TELL RURAL
CALIFORNIA. THAT RATHER THAN
LOOKING FOR AN OPT IN SEARCH
SITE. I WE'VE HAD OUR BUDGET.
AND. WE DIDN'T HAVE TO WORK ON
A WORK AROUND. SO THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS RIGHT NOW CRISIS
STATE THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
A STATE SPONSORED SITE THERE
ARE RULE COUNTIES THAT CAN
BARELY KEEP UP WITH THE
RESPONSE FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
FEWER THAN SIX TOTAL PEOPLE IN
APARTMENT. YET IF YOU CONTINUE
TO OPEN UP AND TELL THEM. WE
HAVE TO BE BASED ON SCIENCE AND
HAVE THE SIGNS THE FINGER TIPS.
BUT THERE ARE GONNA BE
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES IN
MEETING THESE COUNTIES ARE
WHERE EVERYONE IS GOING TO WANT
TO TRAVEL THIS SUMMER. BECAUSE
AIR TRAVEL IS GOING TO BE OUT
BACK LESTER. AND WHAT WE KNOW
IS IT THEY'RE GONNA SIR GOING
TO RULE SPOTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SO IF WE ARE REALLY
FOCUSING ON A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL WE HAVE TO BE PROVIDE
TESTING FOR ALL MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- IT'S
RUNNING ABOUT TWENTY TWO
MILLION A MONTH. ONCE WE GET
FULLY OPERATIONAL WHAT'S THE
APPROXIMATE EIGHTY SITES SO
WHAT I WOULD HOPE THAT ASKED
THE CHAIR FOR THIS IS HOW WE'RE
GOING TO FOLLOW UP. FROM THIS.
THIS IS AN OPEN QUESTION IN.
THE WORK WITH A CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY AS
WELL AS THAT VERY CAPABLE STAFF.
OUR GONNA BE ABLE TO EXT INTO.
I AM WE AT STOP THE BUS OR OF A
TWO DOES. AND ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO BRING SOME EQUITY TO THE
SYSTEM. I HAVE GREAT CONCERN.
REPRESENTING FULL DISCLOSURE
MORE RURAL DISTRICT THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS THAT THE
GREATER PART OF THE STATE OR
THE DICE AND I. AGAIN NOT AT
ALL TRYING TO THROW STONES. AT
CALVARY APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
THEY ARE WORKING. AT THEIR WORK
IN EIGHT STATE SPONSORED-
MECHANISM WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WON'T. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON RURAL IT'S
A HUGE GAP IN OUR SYSTEM BY THE
WAY IT EXPOSES THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA. IF WE'RE NOT
TREATING NAME THE SAME AS URBAN
METROPOLITAN AREAS. I AND I
WOULD LOOK TO DR DEAN IT'S ALL
RIGHT TO THE CHAIR FOR ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT. WOULD HAVE A
BRIEF COMMENT BACK. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU AND- I WOULD JUST ADD
JUST ONE OTHER THING I MEAN
WE'D BE COMING FROM AN URBAN
COMMUNITY- WE HAVE OF COURSE
OUR OWN ISSUES BUT WE HEAR
OFTENTIMES ABOUT THE ROLE
PERSPECTIVE AND WE'VE HEARD
REPORTS THAT- IT TO SENATOR
MAGUIRE'S POINT. YOU KNOW THERE
HAS TO BE- FROST SEWAGE
ESSENTIALLY TESTED IN ORDER TO
FIGURE OUT COMMUNITY
TRANSMETAL. EVERYTHING FROM-
PUTTING VARIOUS MATERIALS
TOGETHER TO MAKE A SWAP BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TESTING AND-
IT JUST TO ADD ON TO THAT-
WHICH I THINK IS TO HIS POINT
YOU KNOW VERY VERY IMPORTANT IT
REALLY SPEAKS TO THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA IF WE CANNOT GET
THIS RIGHT IN A REAL
COMMUNITIES. SO DR DEAN I'LL
PASS IT ON TO YOU THINK YOU.
SURE THANK YOU CENTER FOR THE
QUESTION. AND THEY GIVE HER
KNOWLEDGE IN THE PROGRESS WE'VE
MADE IN CALIFORNIA WITH TESTING
BUT WE AGREE WITH YOU THAT IT'S
NOT ENOUGH AND WE AGREE WITH
YOU. THAT WE NEED TO BE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR THOSE
RURAL COUNTIES. OVER THE PAST
FEW DAYS I'VE BEEN ON THE PHONE
WITH MANY OF THEM. AND IN
TALKING WITH THEM. YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT THAT WHEN THEY
SHARE THE STAFF THAT THEY HAVE
YOU KNOW THEY MAY ONLY HAVE TO
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES OR A PART
TIME PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE. AND
SO THEY NEED SUPPORT. TO STAND
UP THE SPECIMEN COLLECTION
SITES AND I'LL SHARE WITH YOU
THAT. THE D. WHEN WE SAY WE
HAVE ENOUGH INSTALLED CAPACITY
TO TEST. ON THAT IS MEAN
ANYTHING IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
SWABS IF WE CAN'T COLLECT THEM.
AND THEN EVEN IF WE HAVE THE
SWAB TO COLLECT THE SPECIMENS
WE NEED TO HAVE THE STAFF IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT ARE
ABLE TO HAVE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY ON COME TO THAT SITE.
OR MOBILE VANS THAT CAN GO OUT
TO COLLECT THE SPECIMENS. ARE
CLINICS ARE SAFETY NET CLINICS
NEED TO HAVE AN OF SPECIMENS A
SPECIMEN COLLECTION CAN'T. SO I
AGREE WITH YOU- IT'S A NEED ARE
WE DON'T HAVE THE WHOLE PROBLEM
SIX YET BUT WE'RE WORKING
REALLY HARD. WITH THE RURAL
COUNTIES- TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
WITH THE OFTEN SEARCH SITES
WHAT WE DID IS LOOK
STRATEGICALLY AT THE STATE INTO
OKAY. WE HAVE EIGHTY SITES THAT
WE CAN STRATEGICALLY PLACE. WE
KNOW THAT THOSE EIGHTY SITES
COVER OVER 98% OF THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA WAS IN
A SIXTY MINUTE DRIVE. BUT
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT I KNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE'S ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
CALIFORNIANS. ON THAT ARE NOT
WITH. THAT DRIVE WHEN SITE. WE
ALSO THAT HOW. CAN'T FIVE OR-
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO YOU THE
INTERNET. AND SO CAN HARDLY
COUNTIES COME UP WITH
ADDITIONAL TOOLS ADDITIONAL ACT
AND- I'M HOW. FOR IT. THINGS
PRESS. AND TO BE DONE AND WE'D
BE HAPPY FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
AFTER THIS. LET ME ASK MY YOUR
MISTER MOORE. IF YOU WANT TO
SET. ANYTHING TO THE ACTS AND
WE CAN'T RESIST IS ON THE PHONE
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR THAT NO
JUST WANTED TO ECHO THE WE
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE GOAL
WE ARE GOING TO FALL FOR IT AND
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE.
IN SOME CASES MORE CREATIVE IN
HOW WE SAW FOR IT BECAUSE AS
WE'VE LOOKED AT. SOLVING THAT
IN SOME OF THE VERY RURAL AREAS
COLLECTION SITE. IT IS NOT A
GREAT SOLUTION. BECAUSE OF FOR
A WHOLE HOST OF REASONS THAT WE
COULD TALK ABOUT. OFFLINE
FACILITIES ALTERNATIVE SOLUTION
I THINK WE'LL GET BETTER EACH
YEAR FASTER MORE EQUITABLE
ACCESS AND SO. WE CLEARLY NEED
TO FALL FOR YOU GREAT THE GOAL
WE WILL FALL FOR IT WITH YOUR
HELP. I'M IT MIGHT NOT BE TRUE
COLLECTION SITES- FOR
SOMEBODY'S MORAL AREAS BUT WE
WILL HELP SOLVE. SO THROUGH THE
CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE- BOTH
THE COMMENTS. I'M ALL FOR
SOLVING FORT BUT I DON'T WANT
TO DIS WORDS I WOULD THINK THAT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH WHAT THAT PLAN IS
GOING TO BE FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA. IF WE ARE LOOKING
AT PUTTING IF WE HAVE THE
DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO INVEST
WITH. A VENDOR LIKE OPTIM SIR
CAN BE ABLE TO GO INTO A COUNTY
LIKE TRINITY FOR EXAMPLE OR
COUNTY LIKE MADERA WHO HAD
LIMITED STAFF. AND THEN WHAT
WE'RE GONNA TELLEM'S YOU HAVE
PROP UP YOUR OWN TESTING SITE
OR LIKE WE DID MENDOCINO COUNTY
WHERE WE HAD AN OUTBREAK OKAY
JOB BREAK ON THE COLD LOW
RESERVATION WITHIN ST LITERALLY
VERY PUBLIC. EMPLOYEE TWO AND
A HALF HOURS OVER THE HILL TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE EIGHT
HUNDRED TESTS FOR THOSE
RESIDENTS THE COUPLE OF
COMMITTING A RESERVATION. IT
DOESN'T WORK. SO AGAIN IT'S NOT
AT ALL AND TO BE CRUNCHY BUT
SAYING WE GOT US ALL FOR IT
DOESN'T SOLVE ANYTHING. WE NEED
A CLEAR. AND THEN WE NEED TO BE
A TO PUT DOLLARS BEHIND THAT
PLAN TO EXECUTE A SUCCESSFUL.
RIGHT YOU'RE HERE IN A BIT OF
MY FRUSTRATION BECAUSE AGAIN. I
WANTED SPEAK VERY HIGHLY ABOUT
DOCTOR DE DOCTOR JANE HAS MADE
HERSELF AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE
SHE IS. CALLING IN WORKING WITH
RURAL COUNTIES BUT WHAT I AM
WORRIED ABOUT. AND THIS IS WHAT
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WITH
RURAL ALWAYS BELIEVE IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE ACTION. IS THERE
LEFT BEHIND. I DON'T WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN ESPECIALLY SINCE THIS
IS AT THE STAKES ARE SO HIGH SO
IF OUR- SO CALLED SOLVING FORT
STRATEGY IS SIMPLY SAID IT'S AN
IMPASSE. AND HAVING THEM GO OUT
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT
DOESN'T WORK BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE EMPLOYEES. SO WHAT I WOULD
HOPE IS SOLVING FOR IT MEANS
THEY GET EQUITABLE TREATMENT.
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE AND AGAIN. I
AM VERY GRATEFUL DOCTOR DAN I'M
TECH AND GRATEFUL FOR SECTOR
GOLLY. YOU HEARING SOME
FRUSTRATION THAT. WE ROLL OUT
IN THERE THERE ARE. YOU CAN
REALLY DRIVE FOR HOURS AB ONE
ON ONE AND THERE'S NO TESTING.
AND I'LL ONLY GET THERE AND I'M
VERY GRATEFUL DR DEAN OBVIOUSLY
FEEL FREE TO CHIME IN IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING ELSE TO SAY ON
THAT. RIGHT THANK THANK YOU SEE
THAT ARE MCGUIRE AND I KNOW ON
THIS BOOK THIS COMMITTEE WILL
CONTINUE DISCUSSING- THE ISSUE
OF WHETHER IT'S BASED ON REGION
AND OF COURSE- WE'RE STARTING
NOW WITH TESTING BUT THE- THE-
EXPECTATION WOULD BE THAT WE-
OF COURSE. RECEIVE SOME
ANSWERS- TO ENSURE WERE MOVING
TOWARD THE STRATEGY IN PLAN
THAT FITS- EVERYONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AT DIFFERENTLY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
SENATOR MCGUIRE- NEXT TO ME TO
MOVE TO SENATOR. YEAH THANKS
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE TASK FORCE
FOR YOUR HARD WORK AND ALSO OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH. OFFICERS AS
WELL- I KNOW YOU WORKING HARD
TO. PROTECT PEOPLE IN YOUR
COUNTIES IN ACROSS CALIFORNIA
IF YOU ARE SEVERAL QUESTIONS
ARE STARTING OFF WITH TESTING-
SO PCR TESTING IS THE CURRENT
GOLD STANDARD WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES THE
NATURE OF THE VIRUSES THAT
ACTUALLY. THIS THE VIRUS NEWS
FROM THE NASOPHARYNX DOWN TO
THE LUNGS- DEPENDING ON WHEN
YOU DO IS THE SAMPLE COLLECTION
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT ACTUALLY
TAKE UP THE VIRUS. GIVEN THE
VIRAL LOAD. SO I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THIS EMPHASIS ONPCR
TESTING- BUT AS WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD ARE YOU LOOKING AYE
COMBINATION STRATEGY NO THERE'S
LIMITATIONS ON THE CURRENT
STRATEGY TASK. BUT THE MORE
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY WHO ACTUALLY
IS BOTH CURRENTLY INFECTED. AS
WELL AS WHO MIGHT HAVE THE
DISEASE AND I KNOW THEY'RE
STILL QUESTION MARK. WHAT DOES
YOUR ALREADY TEST REALLY MEAN
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT LEVEL AND A
BODY ACTUALLY RESULTS IN AN
ACTUAL ARE. ET SO THAT IS A
STILL OPEN QUESTION IN SCIENCE-
SO WE DON'T KNOW THAT BUT SAME
TIME YEAH WE DO PCR TESTING.
AND THEN- WE KNOW THAT THE
VIRAL LOAD CHANGES OVER TIME
AND SO WE MAY NOT IN FACT I
THINK THERE'S SOME INDICATIONS
THAT THE- SENSITIVITIES ONLY
70% FOR NASAL FRAGILE SLAPS FOR
PCR. AND SO IS THERE A STRATEGY
THINK ABOUT COMBINATION TESTING
ASTROLOGY AND YOU SEE ARE TO
TRY TO GET A BETTER HANDLE ON.
IT ACTUALLY IS POSITIVE KNOWING
THAT'S RELATIVE COURSE TAKES
ABOUT EIGHT DAYS FOR FROM TIME
EXPOSURE TO SEE SOME ANTIBODY
PRODUCTION OR SOMETHING EVEN
PICKED UP SO I REALIZE THESE
ARE SOMEWHAT TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS BUT- ULTIMATELY
POLICY WHY SCORE WE LANDING IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO BE SURE WE
CAN DOWN A FLIGHT. IS TRULY
POSITIVE AND HAVE A BETTER
ASSET RESULTS. YES DOCTOR DEAN.
YES THANK YOU DOCTOR PLAN FOR
THAT QUESTION- WE HAVE NOT-
ISSUED A GUIDANCE OR A POLICY
FOR SPECIFIC GROUPS THAT SHOULD
BE GETTING A SPECIFIC TYPE OF
SEROLOGY TASK BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL. LOOKING IN WANTING TO
SEE- VALIDATION OF SOME OF
THOSE TESTS- THE GOOD NEWS IS
WE DID- PROACTIVELY IS AS AS
THE STATE PURCHASE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION TESTS OF THE NEW
ABBOTT SEROLOGY TEST SO THOSE
ARE COMING INTO CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW. IT STARTED TO SHIP
IN THE STATE LAST WEEK AND
THERE'S A RUN ON THE ARCHITECT
MACHINE WHICH IS THE MACHINE
THAT MANY HOSPITALS I THINK
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY AYE
MACHINES ARE IN CALIFORNIA. ON
THEY BELIEVE THE TURN AROUND
TIME ON THAT TEST IS AROUND
THREE TO FOUR HOURS- BUT WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT MOVE FOR CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN SEROLOGY TEST. WELL
WE'RE STILL CAUTIOUS- ABOUT
RECOMMENDING THAT AND BEING
USED IN ANY SPECIFIC GROUP. WE
DO KNOW THAT MANY ON MANY OF
OUR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ARE LOOKING AT USING THEM AND-
CONJUNCTION WITH PCR TESTING.
YOU'LL SEE OUR NEW UPDATED
GUIDANCE ON A KNOWLEDGE IS THAT
IN SAYING ON PCR TESTING WITH
OR WITHOUT SEROLOGY. I'M AWARE
THAT A NUMBER OF GROUPS ARE
LAUNCHING STUDIES A COUPLINGS
AS YOU SAID COUPLING UP THE PCR
TESTING WITH SEROLOGY. AND
HOPEFULLY WILL HELP EDUCATE US
ON HOW AND WHERE. CAN BEST BE
USED. I'M TO THE POINT ABOUT
THAT SENSITIVITY IS BEST. SEE
OUR- THE WHAT'S BEEN INTEREST.
THE TESTS WERE SOME OF THEM ARE.
IMPEDE SEASONING SOME OF THEM
ARE THE UP CAN'T. THEY CAN
SPEAK MORE TECHNICAL BUT WHAT
THEY FOUND IN SOME OF THEIR IN
HOUSE VALIDATION IS THAT THE
TRADITIONAL PC ARE. ON MAY HAVE
A SENSITIVITY AND SPECIFICITY
AS HIGH AS NINETY SEVEN AND
NINETY NINE PERCENT. I WHICH IS
VERY GOOD. AND ESPECIALLY AS WE
LOOK AT NEW TESTING MODALITIES-
FOR EXAMPLE SOME OF THE NEW
TESTING MODALITIES ARE
SWAPPING. I'M INTO YOUR NARES
OR THE FRONT OF THE NOSE WHICH
IS A SELF WHAT. WE'RE WATCHING
NOT THE DATA THAT'S COMING OUT
ON THAT CAREFULLY. TO SEE WHAT
WORKABLE- OPERATOR ERROR OR
SELF SWABBING PLAYS WHEN YOU
RUN AND THEN ON THE TRADITIONAL
PC OUR MACHINE KNOWING THAT
THAT SENSITIVITY AND
SPECIFICITY IS PRETTY GOOD. SO
I AGREE WITH YOU CONCERN ABOUT
ME SEVEN EASIER POSITIVE MAYBE
WE GOT THEM A FEW DAYS LATER OR
TO YOUR POINT THAT THE VIRAL
LOAD CAN VERY AND THEN NEEDS A
FRIEND JAIL OR A FRIEND YOU'RE
ALL FAIRINGS- WE- WERE LOOKING
AT THAT. THERE'S IN SOME WAYS
IT'S NOT. CAN I KNOW ABLE RISK
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THOSE KIND OF
SWABS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO MISS
CERTAIN. OF PEOPLE THAT ARE.
AND JUST YOU'RE NOT DETECTING
THE VIRUS SO. I'M INTERESTED IN
SEEING MORE DATA ON SEROLOGY
TESTING IS IT IMPROVES BUT LIKE
I SAID WE PURCHASED ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION TESTS ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT RAMPING UP
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I'M SORRY
WHAT WAS THE SECOND QUESTION.
OKAY THANK YOU- SO NO PRE SHEET
THAT ANSWER I MEAN I THINK YOU
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE SINCE
THE SPECIFICITY I THINK SOME OF
THAT AGAIN IT'S NOT THE TESTING
TECHNIQUE IT'S THE ABILITY TO
DETECT AND- SO WHAT BE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT SOME
OF THE DATA THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT I KNOW ANOTHER CHANNEL
TALKS. SO KISSING ON THAT. IN
RELATION TERMS OF THE ACTUAL.
GETTING THE TESTING SO FOR
EXAMPLE- WE TALKED ABOUT
DIFFERENT. THINGS TESTING SITES
BUT NO LET'S NOT FORGET WE HAVE
OUR CLINICAL SITES WE HAVE OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS ARE
DOCTORS OFFICES MANY ASSUME AT.
LEAST A SOMEWHAT SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE OF THE STAY AT HOME
ORDER SENT ME AB HAVE
EXPERIENCE DOING TESTING. DO
YOU HAVE BUT THEY ALSO NEED TO
BE SURE WE HAVE TO DESTROY THE
LIMITATIONS OF ANY US ROB EARLY
ABOUT PHARMACIES. BUT IF THE
PEAK OF CONDUCTING THE TEST
DON'T HAVE TO FEED. BUT ARE NOT
PEOPLE WHO ARE. INSPECTIONS SO
YOU HAVE TO WHERE PEOPLE. WHEN
YOU DO THAT. I MEAN JUST TAKE A
SLOTTED SOMEONE'S. OR MOUTH
YEAH COFFERS. ON YOU AS SO YOU
GOT A WAY TO KEEP. SO FIRST
DOING X. AND SO WHAT ARE WHAT
IS THE SITUATION IN TERMS OF
SINO INTERSECTS WITH TESTING.
TERMS OF THE MAIL BUT A T. T.
E. N. THESE DIFFERENT SITES
ESPECIALLY HERE ABOUT THE ROLE
COMMUNITIES OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS. AND SO FORTH BE
SURE THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
DDT SO THAT YOU CAN DO THE
TESTS THAT WE NEED TO DO SOME
PEOPLE. TRAVEL FOR OUR CITY GO
TO MAYBE A LOCAL CLINIC GET IT
DONE. THE OTHER ISSUE I'VE
ACTUALLY HEARD IN RELATION TO
THAT. IS THAT FOR EXAMPLE SOME
CLINICS BECAUSE I KNOW SOME
RURAL COUNTIES. THEY DON'T HAVE
YOU KNOW. AND THE STAFF IS
SMALL SO THEY OFTEN REFERRED
ANYWHERE FURTHER CLINICAL-
ACTIVITY TO A LOCAL COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER TABLE PARTNERSHIP
THERE- BUT- BUT ALSO WHAT
HAPPENS OTHER DOCTORS HIS
OFFICE MAYBE CLOSE MAYBE
REFERRING THEM TO A COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER SOME TO ME HEALTH
CENTER. INFERRED FROM SOME
COMMUTING HEALTH CENTERS IS
THAT WHAT HAPPENS IS THERE GET
REFERRALS TO DO THE TASK
THEY'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT. BUT
WELL THE TESTS THEMSELVES GET
PAGED BUT ONLY ON THE LAND GET
STATE THEY DON'T. GET PAID THEY
HAVE TO. SPEND MONEY ON PT HE-
HE AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
AND ORDER TO PROVIDE THE TESTED
EXPENSE. SO ARE WE LOOKING AT
HOW WE SUPPORT OUR CLINIC IN
VARIOUS CLINICAL SITES ARE
ACTUALLY PERFORMING. THESE
TASKS SO THAT THEY CAN AT LEAST
GET THEIR EXPENSES COPPER SO WE
GET MORE TESTING SITES
AVAILABLE. THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT- THAT THE TESTING TASK
FORCES LOOK AT. MISTER MISTER
MARK OF IT SAYS SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE CLINICS- YES
SO ONE OF THE- BENEFITS OF
ENGAGING OFTEN SERVE IN THE
PARTNERSHIP IS THEY ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ON PP FOR THE SITE- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE STATE HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN PROCURING
ADDITIONAL AND NINETY FIVE
MASKS. BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THAT WITH SPENT. REQUIRES
ADEQUATE PP AND WE FACTOR THAT
AND WE'RELOOKING AT THE NUMBER
OF TASKS THAT WE BEAT THAT WE
NEEDED TO DO TODAY. THE BURN
RATE OF THE PP. HAVING SAID
THAT WERE ALSO TAKING A REALLY
CLOSE LOOK AT SOME OF THE NEW-
TESTING MODALITIES THAT ARE
COMING OUT THAT ARE SELF
COLLECTION. SOME ARE MAIL
ORDER- SUMMER- SELF COLLECTION
VI<c.cyan> SOLID MEDICINE WITH THE</c>
PROVIDER WHERE THEY HE SHOULD
ACTUALLY COLLECTS THE SWAB.
DROPS IN AN ENVELOPE AND SEND
IT BACK AND WE THINK THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
INCREDIBLY USEFUL- FOR THE
EXACT REASON OF PRESERVING PP.
ON I WANT TO TURN OVER TO MR
MARKETS TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CLINICS. THANK YOU
AND THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY WORKING
ON A PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW IT IT
OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO GO THROUGH.
MORE VETTING AND APPROVAL- BUT-
HOW IT IS THAT WE COULD.
APPROPRIATELY FINANCIALLY-
SUPPORT THE CLINICS. IN THE
TESTING EFFORT. AND HAVE THEM
OBVIOUSLY HELP AND SUPPORT IN
THE TESTING EFFORT SO I'M BAD
IS NOT COMPLETED YET- AND WE
STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT- WERE HIGHLY
COGNIZANT OF IT AND WE ARE
WORKING ON IT AND HOPING. HAVE
AN ANSWER HERE IN A MATTER OF
DAYS. THANK YOU AND JUST TO DO
A TIME CHECK AGAIN WE HAVE
THREE MORE MEMBERS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK SO IF WE CAN JUST
BE A LITTLE BIT MOE SUSPECTS
DISTINCT IF I CAN ASK
RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND SENATOR PAN OKAY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- SO YEAH I'D
APPRECIATE- THE ANSWERS FROM
THE TESTING TASK FORCE AGAIN I
WOULD URGE THAT WE THINK ABOUT
I KNOW YOU TO TALK MY OPTIMUM
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A WIDER
NETWORKS AND ACTUALLY PROVIDERS
THAT PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
SO PARTICULAR RURAL COMMUNITIES
TO TRY TO REACH OUT BE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE SUPPLIS
THEY NEED- I APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU LOOK AT GOAL OF SIXTY
THOUSAND. TO EIGHTY THOUSAND MY
GUESS IS THAT AS WE START TO
OPEN UP YOU GONNA HAVE MORE
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE GONNA NEED
ROUTINE TESTING DOES NOT MORE
EXPOSURE SO I THINK HOPEFULLY
WE WILL KEEP PUSHING TOWARD A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. THAT'S FOR
DAY- EVEN CONTAINMENT WE REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF CASES. MY FINAL
QUESTION IS ACTUALLY RELATED TO
CONTACT TRACING- SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW AND
PRESENTATION. YEAH DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE YES
STATE WORKERS ENTRANCE FROM
OVER A COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE PEOPLE THAT
ARE GONNA TRANSFER OVER. THE
DISTENDED MAKES NOT GOING AWAY
ANYTIME SOON AND AS MUCH AS-
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOOD EVENTUALLY
IDEA MAXINE THAT'S GOING ON
TAKE IT LEAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
NOT LONGER TO GET THERE ARE
SOME TREATMENTS- SO WE'RE GONNA
BE DOING CONTACT RACING FOR A
LONG TIME. AND I WANT TO KEEP
IN MIND THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
TRANSLATE OVER. THE WORD JUST
SITTING AROUND THEY WERE DOING
VERY IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
JOBS SO I GUESS WHAT I WANT TO
ASK IS THAT WHAT'S THE ON YEAH
WE NEED THEM NOW SO I GOT IT
WAS SHIFTING OVER TO DO CONTACT
TRACING. WHAT'S OUR LONG TERM
PLAN TO CREATE A SUFFICIENT
CONTACT RAISING STAFF ALLOWS
THE PEOPLE GOT TRANSFERRED OVER
EITHER GO BACK TO BEING A
REGULAR JOBS THAT WERE REALLY
IMPORTANT. OR ELSE OUT OF
SOMEONE ELSE JUSTICE THOSE JOBS
AS WELL BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE
CAN'T JUST CURRENTLY HAVEN'T
ARE TACKLE DEALT INFRASTRUCTURE
JUST FOCUSED. ON THE NINETEEN
REALIZE IT'S THE MEDIA SHE WE
HAVE NOW BUT NEXT YEAR. SO WHO
HAVE DOES HE OTHER INSTEAD. MR
LOTS OF OTHER THINGS GOING ON.
SO CAN OR. COUNTY PUBLIC
PUBLIC OFFICE. I CAN SPEAK TO
THAT. AND ALSO THE FACT THAT
IT'S SET. UP STATUS. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN. AND LET'S SEE WHO
WE HAVE HERE. THAT WAS DIRECTED
TO OKAY DOCTOR DAVIS WILL GO
AHEAD AND MEET YOU. OKAY RURAL
AREA YES THANK YOU. YEP AND
BETTER PADDED REALLY APPRECIATE
BACK QUESTION AND YOU'RE RIGHT
WE SHIP PEOPLE FROM OTHER
PLACES THAT THEY TAKE AWAY FROM
OTHER THINGS THAT A DEFENSE- ON
IT WELL. THINGS WERE LOOKING AT
OUR WINDS ARE THERE OTHERS WHO
ARE ALREADY OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY AS I MENTIONED
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS WHO.
ARE PROVIDING EDUCATION IN THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL AND IF THE
OFFER A FUNCTION THAT THEY ALSO
HELP THE SERVER OR ACT. IN
ADDITION TO TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND ANY TECHNOLOGY OR
OTHER THINGS THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL THE SPEED UP SOME OF
THE COMMUNICATION AND FOLLOW UP
PROCESS IS THAT ARE NEEDED.
WHETHER IT'S IDENTIFYING ARE
INTERVIEWING IN IDENTIFYING THE
CASE IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR CONTACT INFORMATION. FOR
KATE CONTACT. OR IF IT IS ABOUT
FOLLOWING UP WITH EACH PERSON
WHO MAY BE UNDER WARRANTY IN
EFFECT ABOUT THEM OR NOT. BUT
WE ARE LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL
POLLUTION THAN POSSIBLE OPTIONS
THE CONTINUE. MOVING FORWARD IN
THAT FASHION ARE WE TO COMMIT
TO DOING THAT FOLLOW UP ABOUT
IT ABSOLUTELY NEEDED. I DO WANT
TO STRESS THOUGH THAT. EVEN IN
THAT WAY REALLY HAVE TO BE IT
HERE TOO IT'S GOING TO BE THE
PHYSICAL DISPENSED BANK. AN
INDIVIDUAL- MEASURES THAT
PEOPLE PAY WHETHER AT THE
SOURCE CONTROL USING A FACEMASK
OR ENSURING THAT YOUR WASHING
YOUR HANDS. APPROPRIATELY TO
PREVENT. THE SPREAD EITHER FROM
YOU OR TO SOMEONE ELSE- THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE STRONGER- STOP
MORE STRONGLY NEEDED AS WE MOVE
FORWARD EVER. WHEN WE GET IN
OUR WITH BUT WHEN A- BY. TYPE.
NEGATIVE UNDERSTAND THAT AT THE
POINT TIME AND ALL OF THOSE.
THAT'S A PRETTY YOUR EACH ABOUT
THAT AND IF AND THOSE AROUND
THE OUR LOVE ONE. ARE GOING TO
BE MY MORE NAY ACTING. OR AND
GIVE US AN ALLEY TALK ABOUT
FROM THE STATE LEVEL AND WHAT
WE WHAT KIND OF FUNDING THE
STATE MIGHT BE SEEKING FOR
CONTACT TRACING SUPPORT. RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ENTERED INTO A
COUPLE OF CONTRACTS AND RICHARD
THEM I'M FOR THE CONTACT
TRACING DATA MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
AND PEOPLE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AS
WELL AS THE TREATING. WE ARE
PLANNING TO RE DIRECT STATE
EMPLOYEES NOT ONLY FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH. DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AT LEAST FOR THE TIME
BEING AND WE ARE- HOPING TO
HAVE SIX MONTH DEPLOYMENTS
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
INVESTMENT IN TRAINING FOR
PEOPLE DOES NOT ALLOW US TO
HAVE PEOPLE TAKE SHIPS OF TWO
WEEKS OR SOMETHING WHERE WE
COULD ROTATE IN AND OUT. AND WE
ARE WORKING ON WHAT THAT WILL
LOOK I CAN AND IF WE DON'T. THE
ABILITY TO REDIRECT AN OFFICE
STAFF AND WE WILL HAVE A
FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR YOU. OKAY
SO I APPRECIATE THAT I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THE STATE STAFF
DID YOUR RE DIRECT YEAH I'M
ASSUMING THAT JOBS ARE
CURRENTLY DOING. DIRECTED ARE
STILL. TO AND WHILE THEY MAY BE
PUT ON HOLD TEMPORARILY WILL
NEED TO BE RESUMED AT SOME
POINT. WE HAVE A WORKFORCE.
PROPOSAL SINCE I DON'T EXPECT
THIS CAN DAMAGE TO GO AWAY BY
NEXT YEAR. TO BE SURE WE TRAIN
UP ENOUGH ABSOLUTE THIS WEEK
BACK TO KEEP READING HOLES IN
OTHER. CAPITALIST FINALLY. AND
I JUST WANT TO. DANCE BUT THAT
CENTER. RIGHT YES. ACTRESS FOR
DATA IT'S ABOUT SETTING RULES
FOR PROTECT COMPANIES ANYBODY
ELSE GET DATA ABOUT CROWD OF
THAT THEY NEED TO FOLLOW BE
SURE IF THEY'RE NOT COVERED BY
HIP OUR STATE PRIVACY LAWS WE
MAY NEED TO THINK ABOUT IT
THEY'RE GOING AROUND
ADVERTISING SOMETHING SAYING
THAT THERE'S GOING TO HELP YOU
CONTACT TRACING A NEED TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH PRIVACY
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE THAT. NOT
ONLY HEALTH DATA PERSONAL DATA
IS NOT IN USE OR MISUSE OUT BY
BY THOSE COMPANIES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS AND
THEN- MOST CERTAINLY NOTED-
NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON TO SENATOR
PORCHES AND THEN WE HAVE
SENATOR UMBERG AND SENATOR
COMING. SENATOR GORGEOUS. I'M
NOT SURE ACTUALLY WITH- WITH
THROUGH MY- MY HAND RATES ALLOW
WAIT TO THE NEXT TO THE NEXT
GROUP AND OKAY WONDERFUL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT SENATOR
UMBERG. UP HERE ALSO FOLLOW
QUESTIONS CONCERNING CONTACT
TRACING. OF THOSE BY A
CURRENCY- BUT- WHAT SKILL SETS
ARE REQUIRED FOR SOME OF THE
ENTRY LEVEL CONTACT TRACER I
GET THE WHOLE LANGUAGE ABILITY.
THAT'S QUESTION NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO IS. AT WHAT IS SORT
OF A RANGE THAT ONE COULD
EXPECT ON IS A CONTACT
RESEARCH- TERMS OF
CONVERSATION. NUMBER THREE YES
JUST A BASIC QUESTION SO YOU
HAVE A- FOR EXAMPLE EIGHT A
CLERK AT A GROCERY STORE WHO
COMES DOWN WITH. THAT NIGHT HE
ALL. WHAT DO YOU OBVIOUS TRACE
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD BUT
WILL POST TO YOUR TRICKS YOU.
BE SORRY ACOSTA RICE SO ANYWAY
IF YOU COULD RESPOND TO THOSE I
WOULD BE GRATEFUL AND THE LAST
POINT IS THAT WITH RESPECT TO
PRIVACY OF A DIRECT EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION TO SB NINE EIGHTY
WHICH HE- JACK'S. YOUR SHORT
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG SO WITH THE
QUESTIONS REGARDING CONTACT
TRACERS THE END YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT CONSTITUTES AN ENTRY LEVEL
CONTACT TRACER COMPENSATION-
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION. I DON'T HAVE ANY
HANDS RAISED AT THIS MOMENT I'M
SORRY MISS BOSSY THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MEET ON ME
VIEW. THERE YOU GO. SO I COUPLE
TOOK I COVERED A COUPLE POINTS
IT IN MY PRESENTATION I'LL GO
BACK TO THOSE I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR AN ENTRY
LEVEL CONTRACT RESEARCH TO HAVE
SOME FUNDAMENTAL LAKE CULTURAL
AWARENESS AND SOFT SKILLS TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD TRUST WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY'RE
WORKING WITH THEY NEED TO HAVE
A COMMUNITY CONTACTS IN THAT
COUNTY- IN WHICH THEY WOULD BE
ASSIGNED. BUT THEY NEED TO HAVE
SOME GOOD COMMUNICATION SKILLS
AND THE ABILITY TO HELP BUILD
TRUST VERY QUICKLY WITH OTHERS-
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO COMPLETE THAT THE
TRAINING THAT'S PROVIDED BOTH
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND THEN
THE STATE TRAINING THAT'S
AVAILABLE I'M COMPENSATION IS
GOING TO GOING TO VERY QUITE A
BIT FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY-
BASED ON COST OF LIVING IN THAT
KIND OF THING. BUT WE COULD
PROBABLY PROVIDE A RANGE TO
YOU- COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
INVESTIGATOR- POSITION
DESCRIPTIONS A AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. BOB I HAVE GROCERY STORE
EXAMPLE. IF WE HAD A POSITIVE
OUT OF GROCERY STORE A THERE'S
AN IN DEPTH SURVEY THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH DOES COMPLETES WITH THAT
PERSON. AND WE IDENTIFY WHO ARE
CLOSE CONTACTS AND A CLOSE
CONTACT IS DEFINED AS A PERSON
WHO HAS BEEN WITHIN SIX FEET.
OF THE COVERT POSITIVE
INDIVIDUAL FOR A TEN MINUTES OR
LONGER. SO IF THEY WERE AT THE
CHECK OUT- AND- THEY WERE.
MOSTLY DOING- LIKE NOT
TRANSACTIONS IN WHICH THERE
UTILIZING CASH BUT PEOPLE ARE
PAYING WITH CARDS AND THEY'RE
NOT- PHYSICALLY TOUCHING THE
SAME ITEMS WE DON'T HAVE AS
MANY CONCERNS. ESPECIALLY IF
THAT- CASH CASHIER WAS WEARING
A MASK AS THEY SHOULD BE OR IF
THERE'S LIKE THE GLASS IN PLACE
SO THERE'S DIFFERENT FACTORS
THAT WE CAN CENTER. AT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEONE WHO CAN CONTACT AND WAS
A CLOSE CONTACT. AND IN MADERA
COUNTY AS WE'RE LOOKING AT-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OPENING UP
BUSINESSES. OUTWARD DEFINITELY-
ENCOURAGING BUSINESSES TO HAVE
SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY. WHO ARE PEOPLE WHO
COME INTO CONTACT WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND OTHERS OVER THE
COURSE OF A DAY AND HAVE IT AT
A TRACKING MECHANISM SOME KIND.
THAT'S ALL AND TERRY- BUT THAT
WOULD HELP US IN CONTACT
TRACING FOR EXAMPLE THAT YOU.
BUT I'M SURE IF I JUST FOLLOW.
YES PLEASE YOUR MUCH THE EXAM.
UP WE'RE GETTING I'M SURE ALL
OF US ARE GETTING UP LOTS OF
INCREASE UNEMPLOYMENT IS HUGE
STATE RIGHT NOW SO WHAT WHAT
I'M TRYING TO DO IS GET OUR
ARMS AROUND WHAT WE DIRECT SO
DOES THIS PERSON THEY NEED A
HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE THEY NEEDED
A PHD. IS A MINIMUM WAGE JOB IS
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR YOUR
JOB WE'RE WE'RE DOES IT ALL I
MEAN JUST ROUGHLY. I ALSO THINK
DOCTOR DAVIS HAS HIS HAND UP AS
WELL- DOCTOR DAVIS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
YOU KNOW I GREW UP WITH THAT
EARLIER AND WE WOULD HAVE TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THE OUR RANGE
OF. FOR VARIOUS MISSION I DO
THINK THAT IN GENERAL THERE-
THERE CAN BE A BROADER RANGE IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE.
A CLINICAL PERSON. THAT CAN DO
SOME OF THAT- THAT'S PART OF
THE CONTRACT BOB. SO WE CAN GO
BACK AND FIND THE DISMEMBERMENT
I'M SORRY BUT BARRY RANGES- IF
THE FACT THAT FIRED. I DO WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT ON THE EXAMPLE
THAT IF. WE ARE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN IN CLOSE CONTACT BY
DEFINITION THE TECHNICIAN AT
THE- FORTY HOURS BEFORE THEIR-
WITH THAT SAME. AND TIMES. THEN
WE HAVE LIKE WE'VE DONE IN THE
PAST I WOULD BUY CAN BE ABLE TO
VOTERS THANK YOU KNOW PUT UP A
PUBLIC NOTICE AND- DONE A
PUBLIC LEAVE. THE FAITH YOU ARE
AND THE LOCATION YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED IN YOUR THE TEPS
THAT YOU NEED A- IN ORDER TO.
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION AND
CONTINUE TO WATCH OUT FOR.
THERE ARE PROPERTIES THAT ARE
IN PLACE. BASED ON THE DETAILS
OF WHAT WE GET AND WE CAN
ACTUALLY REACH OUT THAT WE ARE.
ABLE TO REACH DIRECTLY BUT
ENOUGH THAT THE FEDERAL WE
CAN'T WE HAVE TO DO A PUBLIC
NOTICE IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
PUBLIC. AWARE OF. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BUT ALAS
I WONDER CONGRATULATE SENATOR
DAUGHTER. EXCELLENT AREN'T YOU.
THANK I THINK YOU MENTIONED
QUARANTINE BEARD SO BY. DULY
NOTED THANK YOU SENATOR.
EXCELLENT YOUR YES MOST
DEFINITELY THANK YOU SENATOR
UMBERG FOR YOUR QUESTIONS AND
THE WE HAVE NEXT WE HAVE
SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR- FIRST LET ME
THINK THE PARTICIPANTS THAT
HAVE BEEN HERE TODAY I- REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY IT'S
BEEN REALLY HELPFUL AND ALSO
YOUR COMMITMENT TO. HELPING THE
STATE OVERCOME THIS DEADLY
DISEASE- ONLY YOU KNOW WE
REALLY HAVEN'T FOCUSED ONTHIS
ISSUE BUT I WANT TO MENTION IT
BECAUSE- IN MY DISTRICT THIS IS
A BEEN A REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION WHICH IS THAT-
EVERYBODY THAT NEEDS TO GET
TESTED CAN GET TESTED- AND I
AND I MEAN THAT IN TERMS OF
WHETHER YOU HAVE INSURANCE AND
WHETHER YOU'RE IN DOCUMENTED-
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
UP. THE STATE WANTS TO MAKE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY SIGNIFICANT- AND
I ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT AN
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE REGARDING RURAL
COMMUNITIES- MY DISTRICT IS A
RURAL COMMUNITY AND SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WELL SOME
OF THE ISSUES THERE'S A LACK OF
INFORMATION ON THE TESTING-
MODALITIES AND HOW THEY WORK.
AND WHETHER RURAL CALIFORNIA IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO SEE THE
SOPHISTICATED TESTS COME
THROUGH. IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT- IS IT NOT ONLY THAT
THE TESTING SITES BE AVAILABLE
BUT ALSO THAT THE- QUICKER
TESTS- ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM AS
WELL AND THERE'S ALREADY A
SENSE ON THAT. AT THE-
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES HE IS
NOT- DOES NOT TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION SOME OF THE
ISSUES IN RURAL CALIFORNIA AND
THAT- THEY'RE NOT GETTING THEIR
FAIR SHARE SO THAT THIS SENSE
THAT IT'S NOT FAIR IS ALREADY
OUT THERE- BUT WHAT I WANT TO
DO IS I WANT TO TALK ABOUT-
DATA COLLECTION. AND DAM AND
JUST GET A SENSE OF WHETHER YOU
WERE COLLECTING THE RIGHT KIND
OF DATA TO GET BACK TO SOME OF
THEM THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE BY SENATOR JACKSON- YOU
KNOW THE DATA BECOMES REALLY
IMPORTANT AND FOR LOOKING AT.
WHO CAN OPEN AND HOW QUICKLY
AND IN WHERE WE'RE SEEING THE
DISEASE- MANIFEST ITSELF AND-
THAT THE WHOLE ISSUE WITH
MAKING SURE THAT WERE
IDENTIFYING THE LGBT COMMUNITY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. BUT ALSO
HOUSING CONDITIONS BECOME VERY
IMPORTANT IN MANY OF MY- IN IN
MANY OTHER PARTS OF MY DISTRICT
HOUSING OVERCROWDING IS
SIGNIFICANT AND YOU HAVE MANY
ON RELATED INDIVIDUALS THAT
RENT- THE UNITS. THE OCCUPATION
BECOMES REALLY IMPORTANT TO
PARTICULARLY AS WE LOOK AT- THE
M. EMPLOYMENT SITUATION WHICH
IS YEAH IN AGRICULTURE MANY
TIMES PEOPLE ARE WORKING ON
MACHINES AND THEY REQUIRE YOU
TO STAND SHOULDER TO SHOULDER.
AND SO- THERE'S THE POTENTIAL
FOR- THE THAT THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS IN THOSE KINDS OF
SITUATIONS- AND ALSO A QUESTION
AS TO. WHY WE ARE USING
SENTENCE TRACK INSTEAD OF
IDENTIFYING- IT IS CITIES
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR SENSES
TRUCKS ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA- INVOLVES COUNTY AND
INCORPORATED PROPERTY WITH- A
VERY DENSE CITY URBAN TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT AND THE DATA IS
LIKELY TO BE SKEWED WE'VE SEEN
THIS OVER THE YEARS WITH. ON
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA BETTY ITS
COLOR BY THIS MADE THAT THAT
REALLY DOESN'T TELL YOU WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE COMMUNITY AND
SO- THOSE WITH THOSE ISSUES
BECOME REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
AND THEN FINALLY AT THE AT AS A
KIND OF A POINT. IS THAT. I
HAVE A QUESTION IT'S A FIRST
TIME TODAY THAT WE'VE HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT. LEAVING
ISSUES UP TO THE COUNTIES. TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
TO- TO REGULATE FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD- SOME OF THE
CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH PEOPLE.
ESSENTIAL WORKERS SHOULD BE.
PROTECTED AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE SIX DISTRICTS AS
PART OF MY SIX COMPANIES AS
PART OF MY DISTRICT AND EACH
COUNTY DID SOMETHING A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT IN REGARDS TO
FARMWORKERS. AND WHETHER
EMPLOYERS SHOULD PROVIDE
PROTECTIVE. EQUIPMENT WHERE
THEIR- THERE WAS THERE WERE
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT HOW THEY
WERE TO GET TO WORK MANY OF
THEM COMMUTE TOGETHER AND NOT
AND WHETHER THE AND EDUCATION-
PROGRAM PRIOR TO STARTING
EMPLOYMENT BECOMES IMPORTANT
WHETHER IT'S A GOOD THING TO
HAVE A- TEMPERATURE- TAKEN
BEFORE THEY GO. BEGIN TO WORK
IT JUST DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN BENEFICIAL
TO HAVE STARTED SOME TIME AGO
AND TO HAVE THAT THE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES DOING DIFFERENT THINGS
HAS BEEN- DIFFICULT TO GET ARMS
AROUND AND TO. TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO- EDUCATE FARMWORKERS
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO KEEP
THEMSELVES SAFE THANK YOU
SENATOR CABALLERO AND I KNOW
YOU- CONCURRED WITH A LOT OF
THE COLLEAGUES ON LGBT Q.
ISSUES ROLE ISSUES OF COURSE-
AND- OF COURSE YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS RELATED TO DATA
COLLECTION CENSUS TRACT. SO
WE'LL START THERE FIRST- AND
THEN OF COURSE ESSENTIAL WORKER
GUIDANCE- ESPECIALLY AS IT
PERTAINS TO FARMWORKERS SO
WE'LL START WITH THE DATA
COLLECTION AND CENSUS TRACT. A
QUESTION FROM SENATOR COMING AT
ALL AND WE HAVE DOCTOR DEAN.
I'M ACTUALLY RAISE MY HAND TO
TURN IT OVER TO YOU MISTER MARK
OF ITS ON THE PHONE TO RESPOND
TO THAT DATA QUESTION GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT. MISTER
MARKOVIC YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SENATORIAL FOR THAT
QUESTION IT. THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE DOING YEOMAN'S WORK
RIGHT NOW TO GATHER THE DATA
THAT YOU HE- IN TERMS OF
TESTING AND OTHER CATEGORIES
AND- REAL TESTAMENT TO THEIR
EFFORTS THAT WE'RE GETTING WHAT
WE'RE GETTING AND- IN ORDER TO
BE DOING WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING- THE STATE IS GOING
TO NEED. A MUCH MORE INTEGRATED
DATA STRUCTURE THERE'S A LOT OF
DATA BEING COLLECTED AND FIVE
LOS BUT IT ACTUALLY NEEDS TO BE
CONNECTED. IT NEEDS TO BE HELD
IN A PRIVATE AND SECURE MANNER
AND IT NEEDS TO BE. APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT. ON THE STATE MAKE
SURE THOSE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING. AND I BELIEVE THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE
TO CONSIDER- YOU KNOW HOW TO
GET THAT CAPABILITY. IN PLACE-
IN A REASONABLY. FAST MANNER SO
THAT FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE IS
ANOTHER SURGE IN CASES. WERE
ABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS SUCH
AS- ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
TESTED IN THE HOSPITAL- WHICH
ETHNIC GROUPS FOR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION ARE THEY- WHAT-
WHAT IT WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENCES IN. YEAH GROCERY
AND OTHER- A POTENTIAL
DIFFERENCES THAT WE SHOULD KNOW
AND UNDERSTAND SO BEING ABLE TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS
REQUIRES. BILLION DATA FROM
MULTIPLE SOURCES IN INTEGRATING
IT ABOUT THE VERY IMPORTANT
CAPABILITY I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER. AS THE
MOST DEFINITELY THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER MARKETS AND THEN-
QUESTION RELATED TO ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE FOR FARMWORKERS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE THAT QUESTION. SEE
I'M GONNA JUST PICK ON SOMEONE
MEANT I KNOW THAT THERE HAS
BEEN GUIDANCE PUT OUT THERE BUT
IF WE CAN JUST- ELABORATE ON
THAT A BIT MORE- BECAUSE I KNOW
MANY OF OUR ESSENTIAL WORKERS
ARE STILL- VERY IN VARYING
DEGREES OF UNDERSTANDING. OF
WHAT- TO DO- AT THE WORKPLACE
SO I'M GONNA KICK IT OFF TO DR
DEAN AGAIN- TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU. SURE I'M
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
CAN TELL YOU THE WAY THAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT TESTING OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND ON THE
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS IT
THERE HAD THEIR SIMPLY HASN'T
BEEN ENOUGH TESTING CAPACITY ON
TO DO THE LEVEL THAT WE WOULD
LIKE. TO DO AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER YOU KNOW BECAUSE THIS
VIRUS IS SPREAD ISN'T A
SYMPTOMATIC THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE SYMPTOMS THE
POINT THAT YOU MADE ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN CONGREGATE
SETTINGS OR- APARTMENTS TO LIVE
IN VERY CLOSE PROXIMITY TO EACH
OTHER ON THAT THAT'S A RISK
FACTOR FOR SPREADING THE
DISEASE. SO AS WE THINK ABOUT
TESTING- ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WHETHER THEIR FOOD YOU KNOW
FOOD SUPPLY WORKERS OR ON
HEALTH CARE WORKERS OR PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS- THE NUMBER
THAT'S BEING USED AS EVERY
FOURTEEN DAYS- THAT'S NOT AN
OFFICIAL GUIDANCE PER SE BUT
THAT'S KIND OF A BENCHMARK
THAT'S BEING USED OF HOW OFTEN
SOMEONE THAT HAS- A HIGH RISK
FOR EXPOSURE. WHAT WOULD BE A
REASONABLE A PERIOD OF TIME TO
RETEST THEM- IF CASTING WAS
UBIQUITOUS AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY LIMITATIONS YOU KNOW SOME
HAVE ARGUED THAT THAT TESTING
SHOULD BE DONE EVERY SEVEN DAYS
OR EVERY DAY. UNDER THE CAR
LIMITATION WE DON'T HAVE THE
BILL TO DO THAT I'M IN AT IT IS
YOU KNOW WHAT ALL COMMUNITY.
I'M AND IT IS FARM THAT SOME
THAT WERE IN. WITH THE LOCAL
OFFICER ABOUT OF HOW CAN WE
TRAVEL ASPECTS MEN CLICK SITES
IN THOSE UNITY TO BE ABLE BY
THE LEVEL OF I SEE WE KNOW WILL
BE NECESSARY. ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE THAT LIVE I'M IN CLOSE
QUARTERS EACH OTHER IN A PART
BUILDINGS. ARE IN REGULAR ON.
WITH OTHER HOUSEHOLD. WE KNOW
THAT SIMPLE WE'RE WORKING WITH
OUR LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS TO
LOOK AT IN ADDITION TO JUST
OFTEN SERVE SIZE BUT WHAT KIND
OF- SUPPLIES WE NEED TO BE
GIVEN TO THE LOCAL YOU KNOW THE
SAFETY NET CLINICS FQHC CLINICS
IN THE PRIMARY CARE CLINICS. SO
WE DON'T LIKE I SAID WE DON'T
HAVE ALL OF THAT SOLD TODAY
WITH THE- SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE
BUT WE'RE WORKING ON AND WE
KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT AND WE
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
DEAN. SHEET THAT AND THANK YOU
SENATOR COMING AT ALL- I'M
GOING TO. THE NEXT GO TO
SENATOR JIM JONES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I THINK IT- MY
FIRST CONCERT I THINK IT'S JUST
A QUICK COMMENT MY SECOND- MAY
BE A QUESTION THAT MAYBE FOLLOW
UP FOR A COMMITTEE STAFF. I DO
WANT TO CONCUR WITH SENATOR
WINNERS- CONCERNS EARLIER.
ABOUT PRISONERS BEING RELEASED-
WITHOUT BEING TESTED I THINK
THAT THAT'S AN IMPORTANT- ITEM
THAT WE SHOULD WE TAKE A LOOK
AT THE SECOND THING IS ON THE
WORLD ISSUES. I'VE GOT QUITE A
FEW- RURAL AREAS IN MY DISTRICT
AS WELL- THAT. COULD BE
ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO THREE
HOURS AWAY FROM THE URBAN
CENTERS AND CERTAINLY- THE
LARGER HOSPITALS IT WOULD BE
DOING THE TESTING- I UNDERSTAND
THIS- SEEM A CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION OF SENT
A LETTER TO THE GOVERNOR ASKING
FOR AN EXECUTIVE ORDER- TO
ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO DO THE
TESTING. I THINK IT WOULD BE IN
THE FINAL PANEL SEVEN ANSWER
THAT THAT'S GREAT- IF NOT THEN
I THINK IT MIGHT BE AN
APPROPRIATE- FOLLOW UP FROM
THIS. COMMITTEE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF ASKING FOR
THE STATUS OF THAT AND- YOU
KNOW IF THEY ARE GOING TO
APPROVE THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHEN. AND IF THEY'RE NOT WHY
NOT. SO THANK YOU. YES THANK
YOU IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
CHIME IN PLEASE BUT WILL
CERTAINLY- NOTE THAT NOTE THAT
AND PROVIDE THAT AS HOMEWORK
FOR. BUT THIS COMMITTEE IN IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
PANELISTS THANK YOU. GREAT I
THINK WE'RE DONE THERE I
ACTUALLY JUST HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR THIS PANEL WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PANEL I
KNOW THEY'VE BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING AND WE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
THAT. MINE WILL BE DIRECTED TO-
DOCTOR DAVIS IN LA COUNTY MONEY
BUT MANY OF MY STATEWIDE
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED
THANK YOU- BUT DOCTOR DAVIS I
KNOW- IN LA COUNTY WE'VE HAD.
OF COURSE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
CASES AND YOU ALL ARE WORKING
SO VERY HARD EVERY SINGLE DAY
WE WERE RECEIVING YOUR- YOUR
UPDATES BY BOTH YOURSELF AND
DOCTOR FOR ERROR SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR HARD WORK
THERE- I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
RELATED TO- MOBILE TESTING SITE
SPECIFIC TO AREAS LIKE THE SKID
ROW AREA WHERE- A BULK OF OUR-
RESIDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- HAVE HAD. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TEST BUT IT
SEEMS THAT THEY'RE NOT TESTING
SO. I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT- WE
CAN DO IN THAT RESPECT TO-
CONTINUE MESSAGING TO- OUR
RESIDENTS AND THESE CONGREGATE
SORT OF ENVIRONMENTS TO GET
TESTED AND WHAT OTHER. KIND OF.
CHALLENGES BUT ALSO LEARNING-
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE GOING
FORWARD. I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING- IN
PARTNERSHIP WHERE A LOT OF THE
HEALTH SERVICE DIVISION THE
HOUSING FOR HELP. AS WELL AS
THE CITY- AND THEIR STAFF
AROUND YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO WITH
IT BUT AND ALMOST. AND WE HAVE
HEARD THE SAME THING IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE NOT REALLY WANTING. I
BELIEVE IT IT MAY GO BACK TO
OUR COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
EARLIER ABOUT IT BUT THEY
ABOUT- YOU KNOW WHETHER NOT YOU
FOR FREE TO GET IT AND WHAT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT- WE
WERE IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY-
AS THEY WERE IMPLEMENTING
PROJECT FROM YOU YOU OFFER.
LOCATIONS BURKE YOU BOTH THE
COME OFF OF THE STREET AND THE
HOUSE THEY WERE OFFERING THAT.
AS WELL BUT THAT PARTICULAR AND-
A PERSON WHO WOULD AFFECT THE
POP BUT THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN.
IN A LOCATION WHERE THEY COULD
HAVE BEEN ISOLATED. IN ORDER TO
PREVENT THEM SPREADING OTHERS.
I THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
REALLY LOOK CLOSELY AT WHAT
OTHER POTENTIAL ON AND IS THERE
MIGHT BE. IN THAT REGARD. WE
HAVE HAD A STRONG EFFORT TO TRY
TO. GET PEOPLE WHO ARE RENTING
ALMOST THAT INTO EITHER A
SHELTER LOCATION OR HOUSING
LOCATION. IN RDER TO PUT THEM
IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
FACILITIES FOR HAND WASHING
BETTER. EFFECT I THINK THAT ARE
NEEDED TO PREVENT THAT. I AM
PREVENT- GETTING THE FILM WHILE.
BUT I THINK. WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO. MAKE THAT ARE
COMFORTABLE DECISION BUT THOSE
ARE EXPENSE AND ALMOST THAT.
TIME IN ADDITION TO FROM IN A
BROADER COMMUNITY TO PAY OFF OF
THE HEARING. WELL I DO WANT TO-
BUT OF COURSE THE MOMENT JUST
GO BACK TO THE DATA QUESTION. I
THINK THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
MANDATED IN TERMS OF STATE
REPORT. THERE ARE SYSTEMS THAT.
HAVE A LOT OF THAT INFORMATION.
IN THERE HAVE TO BE A BETTER
MAPPING OF THE- I TYPICALLY
WERE BETTER ABLE TO GET.
ANOTHER RACE ETHNICITY DATA.
FROM THE HOSPITAL- BUT I CAN'T
SAY THAT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
REPORTED THROUGHOUT. IN
ADDITION THE LAB REPORTING IN
THE TERMS OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. THE CITY IS NOT
EVEN A REQUIREMENT. HAS BEEN
PAID TO FILL TO BE RECORDED- IN
TERMS OF STATE RIGHT. ALSO
THERE NEED TO BE FROM CHANGES
THERE- BUT I AGREE WITH MR
MARCUS BUT THERE ARE THINGS.
THAT ARE OUT THERE ARE THERE
ARE READY BUT THEY MAY NOT BE
MAPPED AS WELL. IN ORDER TO GET
BACK DATA REPORTED. I'M SO I
THINK THAT THERE ARE MECHANISMS
THERE. ARE YOU WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE SEXUAL ORIENTATION
ALTHOUGH. WE DID HAVE THAT ON
OUR OUR FARM. AND WE DO ASK
THAT QUESTION WHEN WE
INTERVIEW. CASE THE- IN TERMS
OF THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION-
AND SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT DATA. AS WE ENTER THE-
WELL. ABOUT MORE COMMON TERMS
OF WHAT WE DO WITH PEOPLE. ON
WITH- AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT THE CITY OF DONE AS
WELL AS OUR PARTNERS. WHO ARE
WORKING WITH THE BOOK AND. ON
THE- OFF. THANK YOU. DAVE I
REALLY. THAT ANSWER- TO BOTH
QUESTIONS AND I ALSO JUST WANT
TO SAY- I WILL ALSO PUT A NOTE-
OF. PRAISE FOR EACH OF YOU AND
WORKING WITH OUR LONG BEACH
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AS WELL IN
WHICH I REPRESENT- WHICH IS A
COMPLETELY SEPARATE SYSTEM BUT
WORKS VERY COLLABORATIVELY WITH
LA COUNTY- DEPARTMENT- AND JUST
ANOTHER SORT OF THOUGHT I KNOW-
SENATOR COMING AT ALL ALSO
MENTIONED THIS BUT- WE HAVE. IN
MANY CASES LARGE IMMIGRANT-
COMMUNITIES AND- I KNOW MOST OF
OUR- THE LANGUAGE IN MESSAGING
WE PUT OUT THERE IS IN VARIOUS
LANGUAGES. OF COURSE IN THE
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY THREE
WHICH I REPRESENT WE HAVE IN
SOME CASES- CAMBODIAN. COME MY
SPEAKING I RESIDENTS. AND ALSO
OF COURSE SPANISH- 90%
MONOLINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKERS
AND THE SOUTHEAST LA REGION SO-
ANY ADDITIONAL WORK WE CAN DO
TO. PARTNER WITH NON PROFITS TO
DISSEMINATE INFORMATION IN
THESE LANGUAGES. I THINK YOU
KNOW YOUR CAN CONTINUING TO DO
THAT BUT JUST YOU KNOW ANOTHER-
IDEA TO CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
THAT AND I THINK YOU AGAIN.
GREAT SO WE ARE DONE WITH- THE
FIRST PANEL IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PATIENCE ONCE AGAIN. WHAT WE
WILL DO THEN IS. SO SORRY I
WILL GO ON TO THE SECOND PANEL-
IN WHICH OUR FIRST PRESENTER.
IN THIS PANEL IS DOCTOR STEVE
GOING YES- HE IS THE
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR AND
CHAIR DEPARTMENT OF PATHOLOGY
AT UC SAN DIEGO HEALTH I
WELCOME YOU AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE DOCTOR GOING
YES. THANK YOU ARE CAN I PUT UP
A PRESENTATION YES PLEASE EIGHT
OUT LET'S SEE IF I CAN GET THIS
TO WORK SO I'M GOING TO. I'M
GOING TO GIVE THIS PRESENTATION
BUT AT THE SAME TIME. IT IS
THE- SENATORS DON'T MIND I'D
LIKE TO LAY SEND SOME ANSWERS
TO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS RAISED
BY. SENATORS DODD SENATOR WIRE
SENATE COP YELLOW SO I HAVE
ANOTHER HAD AYE WHERE IN
ADDITION TO MY ROLE I'M A BOARD
CERTIFIED PATHOLOGISTS. PERSON
AND A DISTANCE OF MY ROLE IS
CHIEF PATHOLOGY UCSD WHICH I
ACT IN YEARS. I ALSO AM THE
LEAD ALLAH JUST UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE THE
PRESIDENT. WARNING CODE THAT
NIGHT SHE I AM A CONSULTANTS TO
DR DEAN'S COMMITTEE OF THE TASK
FORCE I'M DEVELOPING TESTING AS
ANOTHER FACULTY MEMBER.
PARTICIPATE ALL TIME FROM
UNIVERSITY DAVIS. AND I ALSO
CHAIR A COMMITTEE- WHICH
INCLUDES THE LAB DIRECTORS AND
THE CHAIRS OF OLOGY FROM ALL
FIVE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE MEDICAL
CENTERS THAT UC DAVIS. UCSF A
UCLA IN LOS ANGELES USED TO
EUROPE OR ANY BCS THE AND THAT
COMMITTEES BEEN FUNCTIONAL
QUITE SOME TIME SO AS CHAIR OF
THAT COMMITTEE. IN SEPARATE I
WOULD LIKE A LOT OF US BECAME
WORRIED. THAT CALIFORNIA WAS
NOT PREPARED. TO PROVIDE THE
LEVEL OF TESTING THAT WE NEEDED.
THIS EPIDEMIC AND I. HE AND
WORRY TWENTY NINE IS A VERY
VERY DAY FOR US THAT'S WHEN THE-
RELEASED NEW GUY. ALLOWS I
COMPLY CLIA CERTIFIED LABS LIKE
THOSE CRESCENT UNIVERSITIES
LIKE UCSD. TO DEVELOP- DID
NINETEEN DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
MAINLY TALKING ABOUT THAT YOU
SEE ARE FAST WHICH IS THE
DIAGNOSTIC TESTS THE DOCTOR
CHARITY IN WAS DISGUSTING YEAH.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING SO HIGH COMPLEXITY
CLIA CERTIFIED LAB IS WE RUN BY
A BOARD CERTIFIED PATHOLOGIST
OR SOMEBODY WITH THE BALLOT
GETS TRAINING IT HAS A VERY
VERY COMPLICATED SERIES OF
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE. DIAGNOSTICS HOSPITAL
ESTATE THERE ALSO TEST OUT
DIFFERENT TYPE OF LAB FACILITY
WHICH IS CALLED- CLEO WAIT AND
THAT ALLOWS MORE SIMPLIFIED
TESTING SO THE- POINT IS BEEN
RAISED WITH REGARD TO WHY NOT
INCORPORATE PHARMACIES. INTO
THE TESTING. OUR TESTING
PORTFOLIO IN THE STATE I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT MOST PHARMACIES
THAT YOU ON SITE TESTING OR
CLEAR AWAY. AT MOST OF THE
TESTING THAT THE FDA ALLOWS
UNDER EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION AND FDA APPROVAL
NOW THAT DOES THE TESTING
MACHINES THE HIGH THROUGHPUT
THINGS THAT WE USE ARE ARE HIGH
COMPLEXITY SO I'LL TALK I CAN
AND I CAN ADDRESS THAT IN MORE
DETAIL BUT- THERE IS. A LITTLE
BIT OF A PROBLEM WITH REGARD
THE TECHNOLOGY NEEDED AND HOW
WE DO IT MY PERSONAL VISION AND
I COMPLETELY AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO EXPAND TO RURAL AREAS WE
NEED TO EXTEND TO PLACES. WHERE
FARMWORKERS MAY BE. LIVING JUST
STATE YOU. AND MY- PREFERENCE
BE TO HOW WE- FASTER. AND GET
TO UP YOU KNOW WELL PREPARED OR
TO SO THIS GIVES YOU AN IDEA
WITHIN NINE DAYS OF THE FDA
GUIDANCE ARMORY TWENTY NINE THE
LAST DAYS OF THE DAY OFF- BUT
YOU SEE ES DE ONE WHY WITH THIS
FIRST DIAGNOSTIC TEST. ALL FIVE
CAMPUSES THAT DIAGNOSTIC TESTS
WITHIN- WITHIN A WEEK OF THAT
DAY. AND THIS SHOWS YOU WHAT
OUR CURRENT CAPACITY IS THE PCR
TEST OUR THREE PUT HER DAY IF
YOU READ THIS OUT. IT'S YOU
KNOW. COMING UP ON TEN THOUSAND
TEST PER DAY WE WORK IS THE
SYSTEM WE CAN GREEN IS THE
SYSTEM DISCUSS. OUR PROBLEMS
AND ISSUES. AND I WILL ALSO
SUGGESTS THAT I HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT OPINION
BECAUSE I THINK. WE NEED TO
THINK IN TERMS OF CASTING
STRATEGY AND TECHNOLOGY. AND
THE PROBLEM IN MY MIND IS
EVOLVING FROM ONE IN WHICH GOAL
WE NEED MORE TESTS WE NEED MORE
TESTS TO. WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO USE
OUR CATS BECAUSE I WILL TELL
YOU THAT OF THIS MAJOR CAPACITY
YOU SEE IN THE UC SYSTEM. WE
DON'T USE A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
IT AS MUCH AS 50% OF THOSE
TESTS THAT WE COULD BE DOING
WERE NOT PERFORMING. AND ONE I
WAS ONCE ASKED WHY NOT STEVE IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PATIENTS DESPITE AN AGGRESSIVE.
OUTREACH PROGRAM WE ALL OFFER
SEROLOGY NOW. AND I KNOW- WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD SOME DEBATE ABOUT.
THE USEFULNESS OF SEROLOGY. ARE
WE GONNA TALK FOLLOWING ME AN
EXPERT USER OLOGY I WOULD JUST
SAY MY OPINION IS I AM AN
OPTIMIST. I'M A BELIEVER A WHAT
WE CALL THE MEMORY B.
LYMPHOCYTE I THINK THE PROBLEM
WITH THIS VIRUS. IS NOBODY'S
BEEN EXPOSED TO IT SO WE'RE ALL
WE SEE OPEN NINETEEN WE'RE LIKE
INSTANCE WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF
MOTHER'S MILK. AND SO IT'S A
COMPLETELY BRAND NEW CHALLENGE
TO OUR IMMUNE SYSTEM. ONCE
YOU'VE RECOVERED AND YOU WILL
HAVE POSITIVE SEROLOGY IT IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE WE DON'T KNOW
TO WHAT EXTENT. THAT MEANS YOUR
IMMUNE WILL YOU GET IT AGAIN
HOW LONG WITH THAT I HE LAST
BUT I DO THINK THAT SHOWING
THAT SOMEBODY AS A POSITIVE
STRATEGIES. DECISIONS ALONG
WITH THAT. THE UC. A BY THE WAY
I IT WAS SENATOR DODD SPOKE
ABOUT AN ANTIGEN TEST THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN AN ANTIBODY
TEST. ANTIGEN TESTS ARE
DETECTING PROTEINS ASSOCIATED
BUYER SO SUPPOSED TO BE ARE IN
A WHICH IS WHAT WE DO YOU SEE
OUR- IT IS ANOTHER WAY. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEBODY IS ACTIVELY INSPECTED
AT THE TIME. I WILL SAY THAT IN
MY LAB AT UCSD OUR TURNAROUND
ON PCR IS LESS THAN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS INCLUDING THE TIME
REQUIRED TO GET SAMPLES FROM
OUR COLLECTION CENTERS WHICH
INCLUDE DRIVE THROUGH CENTERS
NEED TO CREATED. INTO THE LAB
AND TO REPORT THE RESULTS SO I
THINK RAPID TURNAROUND TIME IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. I HAD ON
THE TABLE I DIDN'T TALK ABOUT
IT THE ABBOTT ID NOW SYSTEM.
SPOKE ABOUT THAT THAT'S
ACTUALLY GO BACK THE ABBOTT ID
SYSTEM YOU SEE WE'RE USING
THAT. THAT IS A ONE HOUR TURN
AROUND TIME THAT'S ALSO WHAT
YOU CALL CLEO WADE. SO THAT
COULD BE USED IN THE PHARMACY
OR LOW COMPLEXITY LABORATORY
IT'S A LOS THROUGH. ALREADY IT
IS FDA APPROVED FOR USE IN
DETERMINING MY LAB FOR ME TO DO
IT. WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
ABOUT A HUNDRED CASPER DAY
USING THIS SYSTEM. ABBOTT I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY COULD MAKE
ENOUGH MACHINES TO DO WHAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD LIKE TO DO AND
DOCTOR DEAN SPOKE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT YES. THE SENSITIVITY
OF THAT ASSET A IS A LITTLE BIT
LOWER THAN THE SENSITIVITY OF
OUR HIGH THROUGHPUT PLATFORMS
LIKE THE ROCHE AND THE ABIT A
QUICK MINUTE THAT WE USE
STANDARD LEE HERE USED TO GET
STATE. WITH REGARD TO
SENSITIVITY I'LL JUST SAY YES.
THE VIRUS DOES. TO YOUR LONG.
BUT USING THE ROCHE DID IT INTO
IN THE PEACE ARE. ASKED SAY
THAT WE YOU. WE GET THE CAT AS
AS LOW AS HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED.
OF THAT SIX. SO WHEN. YOU THE
PROBLEM WITH DETECTING AS I
ALWAYS SAY LOOK IF THE VIRUS IS
ON THE SPOT. WE CAN SEE IF WE
CAN DETECT IT. THAT DOESN'T
MEAN YOU PUT THE SWAB IN THE
RIGHT PLACE CLINICALLY STICK
OUT YOU ARE UP TO DOES IN HIS
BRAIN TISSUE THAT'S NOT OUR
FAULT EITHER. BUT IN FACT THE
ASSET HAS A GREAT ANALYTICAL
SENSITIVITY. AND DOCTOR DEAN
WAS CORRECTED IN DESCRIBING THE
ANTIBODY TEST. LITTLE BIT LESS
SENSITIVITY AND THERE'S SOME
ARE. HALF OLOGY MATHEMATICS
INVOLVED IN THAT SO WHAT WE
DOING IN OUR REGION THIS IS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE UNIVERSITY
HOSPITAL THE OTHER FOUR
CAMPUSES UNIVERSITY HOSPITAL. A
REAL SHOUT OUT. CHIU UCSF.
BECAUSE THANKS TO THE TRANS
UPPER BURKE INITIATIVE THEY GOT
A GRANT THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
PROVIDE TESTING ABSOLUTELY
FREE. TO EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS IT
I THINK THAT'S FANTASTIC IT IS
TO BE USED MORE OFTEN. WE'VE
TRIED REACHING OUT AND WE HAVE
REACHED OUT TO STILL NURSING
WRIST THIS A LOT EASIER TO USE
UCSD. WE HAVE A PROGRAM CHEST
FIRST RESPONDERS YOU'VE REACHED
OUT AND THAT WE ARE TESTING
PEOPLE ON HOMELESS FACILITIES.
UP WE'VE MAY OVERFLOW TESTING
AVAILABLE TO OUR MEN'S HEALTH
SERVICES THE REGIONAL
LABORATORIES WE SERVE SMALL
HOSPITALS. WE SUPPORT THE BA
WITH ALL OF THAT AGAIN WITH
THEIR CAPACITY AT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED ON AVERAGE. ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED. BUT HER DATE- I AM
PERSONALLY CONCERNED I'VE BEEN
QUOTED IN THE LOCAL NEWSPAPER
SAYING BUT I TOTALLY BELIEVE.
YOU CST SHOULD HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR EVERY HUMAN
BEING FROM THE MEXICAN BORDER
UP THROUGH RIVERSIDE. AND I
THINK EVERY HOSPITAL THE UC
SYSTEM IS THERE. TO TAKE ON
REGION'S AND WE CAN'T SUPPORT.
AND WE'RE AVAILABLE JUST WHAT
WE ARE STATE ASSETS. I WILL SAY
I'M VERY YOU KNOW I THINK IT
WAS CENTER MCGUIRE SPOKE ABOUT
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
REACH RURAL COMMUNITIES. AND I
AM. FAMILIAR WITH THE OPTIMIST
TESTING I MAYBE THE A TO THIS
AND WE'RE ON RIGHT NOW ALONG
WITH A LOT OF OTHER PLACES.
WE'RE WORKING ON WAYS THAT
PATIENTS CAN SELF REQUIRE
SPECIMENS PEOPLE ARE WORKING ON
SALIVA AND THEN THERE IS A- A
TEST THAT YOU CAN USE THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PUT ALL THE WAY
UP YOUR NOSE TO YOUR THROAT SO
WHAT HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
DOESN'T HAVE TO DO THAT EVEN IF
THAT SUPERVISED BY A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL LIKE WE'RE
CONSIDERING. THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL DOESN'T HAVE TO
CHANGE PROTECTIVE CLOTHING IN
BETWEEN EVERY CASTLES THAT IS A
WAY TO GET SAMPLES FROM MORE
DISTANT SITES. TO STRONG
TESTING CENTERS WHETHER IT'S
THE UC SYSTEM HOSPITAL OR QUEST
OR SOME OTHER LARGE FACILITY
WITH GREAT RAPID TURNAROUND
TESTING AND WE HAVE ALL KINDS
OF WAYS PRE ON A LITTLE COOL
THANK YOU DOCTOR ON IS THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH- WE WILL. WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M SURE
WHAT WE CAN GET BACK TO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AFTER THE
PANEL- AND ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT
WE WILL TRANSITION OVER TO
DOCTOR ALLEN WOO OUR NEXT
PANELIST CHIEF OF CLINICAL
CHEMISTRY AND TOXICOLOGY AT SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL AND
PROFESSOR OF LABORATORY
MEDICINE AT UC SAN FRANCISCO
WELCOME DOCTOR WILL AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS WELL.
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR AND
SENATORS THE OPPORTUNITIES
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S. HEARING
MY NAME IS ALAN WILL AND I'M A
LABORATORY MEDICINE. FASTER AT
UCSF WHICH IS ONE OF THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT'S TRYING TO
LEAD THE WAY FOR. EDUCATION
HEALTHCARE AND MEDICAL
RESEARCH. WE ACTUALLY HAVE
ABOUT THE MOST EXPERIENCE WITH
ANTIBODY TESTING IN THE STATE
SO WE HAVE- DONE THOUSANDS OF
RESULTS. AND THAT WE HAVE ADDED
THEM WITH THE VARIOUS CLINICAL
HISTORIES OF ALL ON OUR CALL
THE PATIENTS THAT HAVE. COME
THROUGH SAN FRANCISCO GENERAL
FROM DAY ONE AND I'M HERE TO
SORT ASSURE YOU JUST BRIEFLY
ARE EXPERIENCED AN ECHO SOME OF
DR DEAN OF COMMENTS THAT. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE NOT REALLY READY TO
DISTRIBUTE ANTIBODY TESTING. TO
EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
SURE WHAT IT MEANS I CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT EVERYBODY POSITIVITY
INDICATES A PRIOR INFECTION WE
REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES.
WITH CROSS REACTIVITY TO OTHER
ARE VIRUSES. BUT THE PROBLEM IS
YOU HAVE- NO GUARANTEE. OF
IMMUNITY AND SO AS A
POPULATION. HOW YOU CAN USE
THAT INFORMATION ARE YOU
BECAUSE YOU THINK THAT YOUR
POSITIVE OF HAVING AN INFECTION
THAT YOU CAN LACKS. ON YOUR
SOCIAL DISTANCE SAYING THAT YOU
CAN RETURN TO WORK WITH FULL
CONFIDENCE THAT YOU WILL NOT BE
SPREADING THE VIRUS TO ANYBODY
ELSE. THESE ARE THE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THAT WE NEED TO ASK
RIGHT NOW BEFORE GOING TO RELAX
THE SHELTER IN PLACE OR WE'RE
GOING TO RETURN. EVERYBODY BACK
TO. TO WORK AND YOU KNOW WE DO
NEED TO GET BACK TO WORK
ECONOMY IS IN RECESSION. HI
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
FOR MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE UNEMPLOYMENT VERY HIGH.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAUTIOUS AND SO WHAT I WANTED
TO. SHOW YOU ARE COUPLE OF
SLIDES THAT TELLS HISTORY OF
WE'VE DONE. SO TO GIVE YOU A
IDEA WHAT SOME OF THESE RESULTS
MEAN. SO HERE. THREE DIFFERENT
TIME PERIODS I'M SORRY TO. TWO
DIFFERENT TESTS FOR- KOBE THEIR
BODIES THE MOST TYPICAL
PRESENTATION IS THAT YOU GET
ANTIBODIES WITHIN THE FIRST
SEVEN TO TEN DAYS. I GM COMES
FIRST AID IDG COMES LATER BOB I
WOULD SAY THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
PATIENTS LOOK LIKE THIS. BUT
THEN THERE'S A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DELAYED
RESPONSE YOU CAN SEE HERE THAT.
THIS PERSON DIDN'T DEVELOP
ANTIBODIES FOR THREE WEEKS
EVERYBODY SAYS WELL CORENTIN
FOR TWO WEEKS AND YOU'RE FINE.
NOT SO SURE ABOUT THAT IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE. HERE'S AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD A DECLINE IN
THE ANTIBODY RESPONSE AFTER TWO
AND A HALF WEEKS OUT. IS THIS
PERSON A MOON DURING THE FIRST
TWO WEEKS AND IS NOW BECOMING A
NON IMMUNE WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
AND THEN THE MOST INSIDIOUS OF
ALL THE DATA IS 4% OF PATIENTS
HAVE NO ANTIBODIES AFTER THIRTY
DAYS SOME OF THEM ARE IMMUNE
SUPPRESSED SOME OF THEM ARE NOT
CAPABLE OF RAISING ANTIBODIES.
SO THESE ARE DATA FROM A
QUANTITATIVE CENTRAL LAB
PLATFORM. THAT ALLOWS US TO
LOOK AT THE FIDELITY OF THIS
TEST. IF WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH
RAPID POINTED CARE DEVICES SUCH
AS SEEN HERE ON THE RIGHT. I
THINK THAT THAT'S A MISTAKE. WE
OWE THAT RELY. THESE LAST AT
LEAST AS CURRENTLY CAN. IS NOT
THE NOW FIVE. IF TO THE THIRD
FLOOR. WHERE THEY COULD BE.
MADE NOT ONLINE. HOW DO YOU
PASSED IN IF YOU SAY WELL GET
YOUR POP. YOUR GO OUT IN THE-
HAVE. A GOOD TIME. IN YOUR
PICTURES. AND START THE EFFECTS
ALL OF AND I THINK THAT IS.
WHAT THE MOST DANGER. SO I
WOULD NEED TO SHOW YOU THE
BECAUSE I WANT YOU TO HAVE AN
IMAGE OF WHAT'S GOING ON. SO
THE SOCK BALL THE VIRUS AND THE-
OF THE BOTTOM STRUCTURE IS A
OUR LONG CELLS. OF THE VIRUS IS
TO RECESS. IT'S HERE. AND THEN
TAKES OVER G. OF PROTEIN MAKING
CAPABILITIES OF OUR CELL SO
INSTEAD OF PRODUCING CELLS ARE
PROTEINS THAT WE NEED. IT
STARTS PRODUCING VIRUS AND A
DEN PROPAGATES ANYTHING THIS
ISSUE GOES ON AND ON.
ANTIBODIES ARE KEY TO- BLOCKING
THE ENTRY OF THE VIRUS TO THE
CELLS THESE ARE WHAT WE CALL
NEUTRALIZING ANTIBODIES THESE
ARE THE ONES THAT WE ARE ALSO
HOPING TO GET. WHEN WE GET A
VACCINE. THERE IS ALSO
DISCUSSED OF. GIVING MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES THAT WILL BLOCK THIS
PROCESS SO ANTIBODY PRODUCTION
IS KEY BUT THE QUESTION IS WHAT
IS OUR ANTIBODIES BEING
DIRECTED TO THAT THERE ARE MORE
THAN JUST A SO CALLED SPIKE
PROTEIN. IN THE VIRUS THERE ARE
OTHER PROTEINS THAT ARE PART OF
THE STRUCTURE OF THE VIRUS
ITSELF. THAT DON'T REALLY
INDICATE THAT THERE IS A MUNITY
DOESN'T BLOCK THIS ENTRY
PROCESS THEN IT'S NOT IMMUNE
IT'S ALL BYSTANDER IT TELLS YOU
THAT THE VIRUS PROTEIN WAS
THERE. FOR TICKETS A STRUCTURAL
PROTEIN QUITE FRANKLY IT
DOESN'T HELP US IS WE DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS A MUNITY SO
THERE IS A GOLD STANDARD TEST.
THE GOLD STANDARD TEST IS
CALLED A PLAQUE NEUTRALIZATION
ASPECT. WHERE WORKS IS THAT YOU
TAKE CELLS ARE PETRI DISH THAT
YOU CAN RAISE YOU TREATED WITH
ANTIBODIES FROM A PATIENT SO
THEY HAVE NEUTRALIZING
ANTIBODIES AS SHOWN IN THE RED
DIAMOND HERE. THEY WILL BLOCK.
HE ALSO I FIRE TO IN. THAT SO.
THAT IS THE BUT WE WANT TO SEE.
IF WE ERA BY. THAT ARE WHAT I
SAY BYSTANDERS THAT DO NOT IN
NEUTRALIZE THE ABILITY OF THE
VIRUS TO GAIN ENTRY TO
OURSELVES THEN THIS IS A- NON
NEUTRALIZING ANTIBODY. IT'S A
MY LAST SLIDE IS THIS ONE THIS
IS A STUDY CONDUCTED IN CHINA
ARE USING ONE OF THE SPIKE
PROTEINS AS THE BINDING FOR THE
ANTIBODIES SO THE X. AXIS HERE
ON THE BOTTOM IS THE RESULT OF
A- TYPICAL WHAT WE CALL ALISA
ANTIBODY TEST. THE Y. AXIS THE
UP AND DOWN ACCESS IS THE
RESULT OF THE- ACTUALIZING
ANTIBODY TEST THAT WHICH THAT I
SHOWED YOU IN THE PREVIOUS
SLIDE. AND THE THREE ZONES THAT
I'VE HIGHLIGHTED IN RED ARE KEY
HERE. HIS OWN IN THE BOTTOM
LEFT INDICATES THAT THERE ARE
SOME PATIENTS WHO HAVE NO
ANTIBODY RESPONSE AND WHO DON'T
PRODUCE NEUTRALIZING
ANTIBODIES. NOT IMMUNE WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW IF THEY'RE INFECTED
OR PERCENT OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
SO EXHIBIT THIS. THAT'S NOT SO
MUCH OF A PROBLEM. LOOK AT THE
LOOK AT THE TOP LEFT THE TOP
LEFT HERE TO PATIENTS OR MAYBE
MORE THEY HAVE NO ANTIBODIES
BUT THEY HAVE OTHER ANTIBODIES
ARE NOT BE DETECTED BY THE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE A LICENSE.
AND THESE ARE IN FACT. IMMUNE
SO YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO COULD
BE IMMUNE EVEN THOUGH THEY
DON'T HAVE ANTIBODIES YOU JUST
HAVE TO PRODUCE THE RIGHT
ADVICE OKAY SO THAT TOO. IS NOT
SO MUCH OF THE PROBLEM THAT I
SEE. THE PROBLEM I SEE IS THE
BOTTOM RIGHT SET ON IN THE- AND
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CAUGHT
CONCENTRATION WOULD BE FOR THE
NEUTRALIZING ANTIBODY IN THIS
CHART THEY COULD INVADE EVEN A
LITTLE BIT HIGHER THAN THAT
CIRCLE. WHAT THESE PATIENTS
SYNDICATE AND DOCTORS I CAN ASK
YOU TO JUST FINISH YOUR YOUR
SITE HERE BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THIS IS MY LAST STATEMENT
OKAY GREAT CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
I HAVE TO GET IT IN. THESE FIVE
PATIENTS HAVE ANTIBODIES. THAT
ARE NOT NEUTRALIZING SO IF YOU
TELL THEM THAT THEY'RE IMMUNE
IS SEND THEM BACK INTO THE
WORKFORCE IT'S- A SECOND WAVE
OF INFECTIONS SO WE REALLY NEED
TO BE CAUTIOUS MY COLLEAGUES
ARE DEVELOPING NEXT GENERATION-
ANTIBODY TESTS THAT I HOPE WILL
RESOLVE ALL OF THIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT. VERY
INSIGHTFUL WE APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH- AND NEXT WE WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR THIRD PANELIST-
WHICH IS PATRICK PULLMAN VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL MANAGER
WESTERN REGION OF QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS. A WELCOME MISTER
PLOWMAN. Q. MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATORS-
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY FOR-
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
PATRICK WOMEN ON THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR QUEST DIAGNOSTICS
ON THE WEST COAST- WHICH IS
INCLUDES CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY
AND- IS THE CALIFORNIA IS THE
pHEADQUARTERS. SO I WANT TO GIVE
A QUICK OVERVIEW OF QUESTS
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS. OUR VISION
THE QUEST IS TO EMPOWER BETTER
HEALTH WITH DIAGNOSTIC INSIGHTS
THAT SO- MISSION STATEMENT OF
WE ARE A LEADING PROVIDER OF
DIAGNOSTIC SERVICES AND WE HAVE
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. WE HAVE AS OF THIS
WEEK A PERFORMED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ONE AND A HALF MILLION.
ILA TESTS NATION WIDE SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF ALL. YOU SEE
OUR TEST ON MARCH NINTH. AND
THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT 20% OLD.
COVET MOLECULAR TESTING FOR
NATIONALLY HERE CALIFORNIA.
DATA THROUGH BEGINNING OF THIS
WEEK WE'VE CONDUCTED
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND MOLECULAR
TESTS FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
SENSE. SOME OF BETWEEN IN THE
LOW TWENTIES LET'S SAY OVERALL
THE TESTING DONE AND THEY'RE
NOT IN THE IN CALIFORNIA. SO I
WAS YOU KNOW WE'VE A BIG
COMPANY WITH TWENTY FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND COLLEAGUES ON TO THANK
THEM FOR ALL LOOK BAD DOING
COME ACROSS THIS- PANDEMIC ON
THE WORKING THE FRONT LINES. BY
PROFESSIONALS FOR BOTANISTS AND
OBVIOUSLY THE TRANSPORTATION
AND LOGISTICS PROFESSIONALS
THAT WE HAVE. TO WEAR WITH VERY
PROUD OF OUR PRESENCE IN
COMMITMENT THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA- AND OUR RESPONSE IS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF OFF LONG
TIME COMMITMENT- AND INVESTMENT
IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE SEVEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WHO CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME WE HAVE TO
REGIONAL LABS ONE. BASED IN
WEST HILLS ONE IN SACRAMENTO WE
HAVE TO BE SO TERAFLOPS WHICH
OF SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO VALENCIA
WE HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PATIENT SERVICE CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE HAVE A
DOZEN RAPID RESPONSE SLASH
PROVIDING STAT TESTING. ON OVER
SIX HUNDRED CARS VANS USED TO
KOREA SAMPLES FROM LOCATIONS
ROUTE TO OB. ALL MAY LAPSED SO
WE HAVE A BIG INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA- THAT WE THAT. WE
HAVE AND WE MADE. SO WE- MARCH
NINE. BUT WE ACTUALLY WOULD
DEVELOPING LIKE MANY OTHER.
ACADEMIC AND PRIVATE LEBAR
TREES A BASS SAY. AND THIS IS
THE NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS
FOR LABS AS WE ATTEMPT TO HAVE
ACCESS DEVELOPED IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE CLINICAL
NEED AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT
pDEVELOPED BY A GROUP HERE IN
THESE NICHOLS INSTITUTE IN SAN
JUAN CAPISTRANO. THIRTY DAYS OF
WE HAVE A NATIONAL NETWORK WE
HAVE OVER WHAT WE HAVE TWELVE
LEBAR TREES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
COLLECTIVELY WHICH WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PULL THE FORM FIFTY
THOUSAND TESTS BUT DAY FIFTY
THOUSAND TEST TODAY WE AVERAGE
TURNAROUND TIME. IS LIKE MOST
OF THEM TO GO HE'S WAS SAYING.
ONE TO TWO DAYS ON AVERAGE AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A VERY VERY
MINIMAL BACKLOG. AND THIS IS
BEING THE CASE RUNNING A
MINIMAL BACK TO OKAY FOR THE
PAST THREE WEEKS SO WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING TO EXPAND
CAPACITY BEYOND THE FIFTY
THOUSAND. BUT IT IS A CHALLENGE
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE EACH OF
THESE CODE BASS INSTRUMENTS. IS
LIMITED TO. BRINGS ABOUT TWO
AND A HALF THREE THOUSAND TESTS
A DAY SO IT'S A DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE TO SCALE. I JUST WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT BRIEFLY TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF OUR SPECIFIC
ACTIONS HEARING CALIFORNIA
WE'VE TAKEN- TO SUPPORT THE
EFFORT THESE INCLUDE. TESTING
OF DON'T CALVET PATIENTS FROM
LOCAL LAW CENTURIES HOSPITALS
TO FACILITATE TRANSFER. TO THE
UNITED STATES NAVY SHIP MERCY-
WE WERE INVOLVED WITH. SETTING
UP TESTING FOR THE SEARCH
HOSPITALS IN LOS ANGELES
SPECIFICALLY LONG BEACH
COMMUNITY INCIDENTS SINCE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE MASS
OFFICE ON THE HOME A SURGE-
TEQUILA YES Q. EIGHT CITIES.
AND WE PROVIDE THE TESTING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
INMATES WITH TESTING FOR THE LA
COUNTY TWIN TOWERS JAIL- AND AS
WE CUT TODAY THIS AUTUMN SERVE
THE EIGHTY TEST SITES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL. LOCATING IN THESE TESTING
THAT'S THE QUEST AUGUST SIXTIES
THE ENGINE BEHIND THOSE EFFORTS
WE PROVIDE THE LOGISTICS AND
THE TESTING. NOT JUST FOR
BOTTOM SERVES BUT ALSO FOR
VERILY AND WE SUPPORTED VERILY
FROM THE VERY START. WE'RE ALSO
INVOLVED IN- ANTIBODY TESTING-
WE HAVE TO DATE PERFORMED THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SEROLOGY TESTS. ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND OF THOSE
AREN'T FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
CURRENT THROUGHPUT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ANTIBODY TESTS
DAY YOU KNOW. BABS THE COUNTRY
AND WE'RE GONNA BE EXPANDING
THAT SHORTLY- BY THE END OF MAY
TO A QUARTER OF MILLION TESTS
PER DAY ACROSS ON NETWORK. SO
WE'RE RAMPING UP. THE TESTS
HERE I JUST WANTED TO GIVE A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF WHAT
CAPABILITIES WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING AND- HOW WE BEING
SERVING. BUT I DO THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE IS TOP JUST TO TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW. DIAGNOSE X.
WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE FOR HOW
CRITICAL MOST OFF AND YOU KNOW.
AS MUCH. REFER STUDY ABOUT THE
PERCENT OF CLINICAL SUSPICION
BEING BY AND SO TO PROVIDE BY
THE- TESTING YEAH THE DOG. COST
ONLY A FOR PRO 3% OF THE HEALTH
CARE SPENDING SO DIAGNOSTICS
ARE INCREDIBLE VALUE
PROPOSITION- BUT REIMBURSEMENT
RATES CONTINUE TO BE CHALLENGED
AND THE I JUST WANT TO FINISH
ON THIS POINT THE PROTECTING
ACCESS TO MEDICARE ACT THAT WE
HAVE. IS PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING TO OUR INDUSTRY AND
OTHERS BECAUSE THIS HAS
RESULTED IN A 10% RATE CUT- FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS AND IT'S
THE TECH. CRITICAL BECAUSE CMS%
PAYMENT RATES ARE FREQUENTLY
USED BY ALL THE PAYMENTS AS A
IMPORTANT REFERENCE POINT- SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE- YOU KNOW
WILL FAIR REIMBURSEMENT
POLICIES FOR THE WORK. AND THE
VALUE OF THIS TESTING THAT WE
DON BUT IN SUMMARY WE WERE VERY
PROUD TO PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
I'M WHETHER SUPPORTING THE
DRIVE THRU FLEXION SITE YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT. OF THE HIGH RISK
POPULATIONS NURSING HOMES AND
OTHERS RURAL POPULATIONS AT TWO
EIGHT SEIZE CORRECTION
FACILITIES THANK WORKING THERE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN MAKE SURE WE
CAN. SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
ANOTHER'S ACROSS ON A TRIP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PULLMAN
APPRECIATE THAT- COMMERCIAL
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND NOW I ARE ON
TO OUR FINAL FOR HER WITHIN
THIS PANEL TODAY IS KAREN
SAVAGE SAYING ONE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA PAN
NICK HEALTH WORK- TO DISCUSS
TEST ACCESS ISSUES AND WE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AS WELL. WELCOME AND HAVE A
JUSTONE. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU ARE. TO BE
HERE TODAY BEN REALLY AND HAVE
TO LISTEN TO ALL THE ALL THE
OTHER ANALYSTS. THAT WORK IT
HAPPENING CAN ABOUT FOR WORDS I
AND GOT YOUR BUT- CANNOT OF
THAT FOR STATEWIDE MULTI
CULTURE HELD AT. THE ORGAN. WE
WORK WITH COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
TO ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY AND
ADDRESS. IT HEALTH DISPARITIES.
I'M AND I DO WHAT I SAY I THINK
WE CAN NUMBER OF ISSUES WITH
REGARD TO HEALTHEQUITY I'M IN
THAT I THANK THE AND HAVE BEEN
AFTER YOU TO FOCUS ON HAVE.
HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT ALSO
REALLY WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED. I'M PARTICULAR AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER ISSUES.
AND WE KNOW WHAT HARD TO OUR-
TODAY THAT THEIR AND THEIR
DIRECT KNOWLEDGE MEANT THANK
YOU THE COLOR PARTICULARLY
BLACK AND LATINO COMMUNITIES
ARE BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE
CUP NINETEEN ENDEMIC. COVER
NINETEEN IS BUILDING UP BEHIND
DECADE BUT BASS THAT AND
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES HAT WE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO HAVE A
HIGHER BURDEN OF CHRONIC
DISEASE. LET'S ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE AND ULTIMATELY
SHORTER LIKE IT'S EXPECTED
THESE. UNLESS WE ACT QUICKLY
AND EFFECTIVELY TO TARGET EVERY
PART OF. OUR PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
YOU WE WILL LIKE MAKE THEM WORK.
EQUITY IN ONE OF THE MEN ISSUES
WE MUST. AND IS THE LAND
THROUGH WHICH WE FIRST TO THAT
RIGHT. I AM IT'S BEEN STATED
ALREADY BY JUST AS A REMINDER
BLACK WHICH- AND FOR THE
CALENDAR TO. ARE OVER. YOU IN
IN OUR AT I'M HOPING. BUT DID.
ONLY PART OF STORY. I'M FOR.
HELP IS NOT. WERE AND DATA I'M
BUT NINETY HAD THAT MINISTER BY
RATE AND THAT. WHICH WE THAT A
WHOLE AND I ENERGY. OF WHO
ACCESS AND WHO IN HOW PEOPLE
ARE IMPACTED. IF YOU TAKE THAT
ARE REPORTING DATA AND HAS BEEN
MINISTER BY RACE AND ETHNICITY
HAVE FOUND THAT BLACK LET YOU
KNOW THAT ARE BACK THE UNDER
REPRESENTED. IN WHO IS BEING
TESTED I'M WHICH MEANS THAT
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN TERMS OF
CASES THAT THAT. UNLIKELY
COMING UNDER ACCOUNT AND THE
IMPACT THAT THE PANDEMIC IS
HAVING. ON THOSE YET EVEN. WE
DON'T ONLY NEED. AND AT ALL IN
THE- AND BUT WE REALLY CUTTING.
OF IN THE- THAT ARE MONTH IN.
IT SENATOR WIENER THAT THE- I
FROM THE MID DISTRICT IN CAMP
AND- GO. WHICH CAN THAT THE
VIRUS IS MORE WHY. AND
COMMUNITY FOR RATHER HAVE LEFT
ACT. TO ACCURATE AND TIMELY.
HEALTH INFORMATION. FLEXIBILITY
TO SHELTER AND- OR THANK I LATE
YOU'RE BEING INCOME. WORK
LIVING CREDIT HAVING CAN AND
YOU NOT HAVE AN- ACT IT.
ADEQUATE TO PROTECTION JUDGES.
WAIT AND WE THE TEAM FROM OUR
THAT SHE THAT HAVE FOR QUITE
LIKELY TO COME BACK I'VE BEEN
IN LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS. HI
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS. WE REALLY
NOW WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS AND WE DO APPRECIATE.
I'M KIND OF THE RECENT EFFORTS
BY THE STATE WITH EIGHTY. THE
DESKTOP HAVE BEEN FIGHT BUT WE
KNOW THAT MUCH MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE. NOT ONLY DO WE NEED
CASTING LOCATIONS BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO REMOVE. IT CASTING SO
DOES THAT REQUIREMENT THAT WE
HAVE PART TIME POPULATION BUT
YOU'D BE REFERRED BY A DOCTOR.
I'M CAN BE A HUGE BARRIER
BREAKING THE COLOR WHO ARE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE A ACCESS TO A
USUAL OR THAT HEALTHCARE TO. BE
ABLE TO GET THAT TRAINING AND
GET THAT REFERRAL. AND WE ALSO
YOU KNOW FEET. THAT OUR DRIVER.
YOU DON'T HAVE A CAR. I'M SORRY
BUT BE MORE WHY BUT CAN RIGHT
BEING OPENED INTERPRETERS ARE.
CAN GETTING ISSUE THAT WE HEAR
ABOUT AT THAT. RIGHT I AND
LIMITED I HOURS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THEY TESTING. YEAH TO. WHEN
THEY'RE I'M WHEN I GET OFF.
WHEN THEY DONE WHEN I GOING
HOME THE DAY. ONE EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY THAT DIRECT. IT
LOOKING. AT THAT WAS COMMUNITY
GAS THANK BETTER WHY TRUST. I'M
FOR EXAMPLE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
THAT RIGHT UNITY HEALTH CENTER
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. IN A WALK
IN RIGHT THAT REALLY FOCUSES ON
SERVICES TO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND BE
ABLE TO. I'M REALLY PROVIDED.
THAT POPULATION. IN ADDITION
FOR BOTH CASTING AND CONTACT
TRADING. OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
OUTRAGE. MUST BE MUCH MORE
ROBOT. I CALIFORNIA REALLY.
THAT TO MAKE THAT HAVE THINGS
THAT FOR YOU CHARGE AND REGARD
IMMIGRATION THAT. I'M BUT
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT AND
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT
PEOPLE DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
COST. PEOPLE ARE WORRIED THAT
GETTING HAS IT WILL IMPACT
THEIR OPERATIONS THAT IT. AND
PEOPLE ARE SCARED EVERY EVEN A
POSITIVE TEST RESULT WILL
JEOPARDIZE THEIR JOB. SO WE
RECOMMEND USING CRAFTED
COMMUNITY MESSENGERS PROVIDE
ACCURATE AND TIMELY. AND
CULTURALLY RELEVANT INFORMATION
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATION
FROM LA COUNTY ABOUT THE-
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS I
THINK THAT'S- A STRATEGY THAT
WE DEFINITELY EMBRACE AND-
THINK. YEAH I'M AND THEN
FINALLY I GET FUNNY THING WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT TESTING AND
CONTACT TRACING- WE REALLY
WORRY THAT THOSE EFFORTS WILL
ONLY BE. EFFECTIVE AT THE
ABILITY THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
HELP ISOLATE IF THEY HAVE HOW
DID IT WORK THEY HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH. BUT IT POSITIVE
WHICH MEANS THAT IN ADDITION TO
LOOKING AT HOW WE'RE GOING TO.
HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT I THINK WE
REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON
STRENGTHENING OUR STATE IN THAT
I'M WHAT WE HAVE TODAY IS NOT
GOING TO WORK FOR THE MAJORITY
OFCALIFORNIANS WHO DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO WORK FROM HOME.
AND WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO WORK
NETWORK WHO MAY NOT EVEN HAVE A
PHYSICAL LOCATION TO ISOLATE.
AND WE REALLY NEED TED KOPPEL
DOWN ON BUILDING THOSE SOCIAL
SERVICES. THAT ARE GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT I MEAN TO BE ABLE TO
CONTROL. THE CAN BACK. IN A
MOMENT WHICH WE MIGHT HAVE A ON
IT. ABOUT RAPE AND EQUITY. YOU
CAN. ACTION TO ACT OUT. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OP. HAS AT
I'M AND TO FOR THEIR GATE. MANY
AT ANY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
VERY INSIGHTFUL- GREAT SO. THIS
CONCLUDES THE TWO PANELS AND WE
AGAIN APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE HERE. AND WHAT I'LL
JUST REITERATE IS THE PUBLIC'S
OPPORTUNITY TO DIAL IN BEFORE
WE GET TO MEMBER QUESTIONS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- TO ALL THE
PRESENTERS BEFORE WE MOVE ON A
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
AS MENTIONED I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN
NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. 1-844-291-6364 AGAIN
THAT IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
pUSE THIS ACCESS CODE. NINE
THREE SIX EIGHT FIVE ZERO EIGHT
AGAIN THAT IS ACCESS CODE NINE
THREE SIX EIGHT. FIVE ZERO
EIGHT ALRIGHT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO MEMBER QUESTIONS IN THE
FIRST AS SENATOR I HAVE UP IS
SENATOR NUMBERS. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. IT IS MY HAND IS UP I'M
GONNA TAKE MY HAND NOW OKAY NO
PROBLEM SO JUST REMIND SENATORS
TO RAISE THEIR HANDS AND IF YOU
DID NOT WANT TO BE CALLED ON
YOU CAN JUST AND DO YOUR TO THE
HAND THERE- I HAVE SENATOR
BOARD JUST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS MAY BE A QUESTION FOR
BROWN DOCTOR WILL WORK TO
DOCTOR ON IN I. S. LOT OF
INFORMATION GET CIRCULATED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA IN THROUGH THE
MEDIA OUTLETS SO THERE IS US
AND COMPETING INFORMATION- ON
WHETHER ARE CODED NINETEEN.
DEATH RATES ARE OBJECTIVELY
DETERMINED. PARTICULAR I USE AN
EXAMPLE IMAGINE IN A
SYMPTOMATIC HAITIANS. CHOOSE
FROM A HEART ATTACK IS THAT
PERSON LISTED AS BEING A CO
GOOD RELATED YES. AND IF YES
PLEASE EXPLAIN IF NO PLEASE
EXPLAIN IN OUR OTHER COUNTRIES
USING THE SAME TYPE OF METRIC
TERMINATIONS. ARE THAT WERE
YOU'RE SAYING SO WAS
CONSISTENCY IN THE RATES THAT
WE HEAR ABOUT ONLINE FROM OTHER
STATES AND OTHER COUNTRIES
WHETHER YOU CHINA RUSSIA
SEVERAL. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
JUST WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THAT QUESTION. BEING ABLE TO
DISPEL CAKE DOCTOR WILL THANK
YOU. YEAH SO- THE WAY WE KEEP
TRACK OF THAT IS THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE SOME POSITIVITY AND
VIRUS IN ORDER TO CALL UP ALL
THE DEATH AND OUT OTHERWISE IF
IT'S A COINCIDENCE HEART ATTACK
AND UNCLE BUT NEGATIVE THREE
DON'T CONICAL WITH. A DEATH SO-
I DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER PEOPLE
DO BUT THAT WOULD BE THE ONLY
THING THAT MAKES SENSE CAN JUST
GO ON SYMPTOMS. HAVE OBJECT OF
LABORATORY DATA. PERMISSION FOR
A FOLLOW UP. QUESTION CHAIR
WOMAN YES PLEASE. THE WHITE
HOUSE HAD YOU HAD A PRESS
CONFERENCE AND THE REASON I'M
HONING IN ON THIS IS. THERE WAS
THERE WERE STATEMENTS MADE AT
THAT. AN INDIVIDUAL. WHO AT THE
TIME HE PERISHED. ARM SUFFERED
FROM AILMENT COMPLETELY
UNRELATED US EXAMPLE OF A HEART
ATTACK. PAN BECAUSE AT THE TIME
OF DEATH. HE HAD TESTED
POSITIVE. THEY RULED THAT A CO
GOOD YEAH. SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS OUR- IS
EVERYONE WHO HAS CO GOOD. AUG
OF TEST POSITIVE FOR COBRA ARE
WHETHER NOT THEY PASSED AWAY
FOR SOME COMPLETELY UNRELATED
COSTS ARE THEY PUT ON THE
ROSTER OF CODED RELATED DEATHS.
THERE WILL. YEAH SO I BELIEVE
THE ANSWER IS YES I CERTAINLY
THERE COULD BE A COINCIDENCE
THAT SOMEBODY HAS A HEART
ATTACK AND ALSO IS CALLED A
POSITIVE BUT YOU CAN ALSO ASK
DID THE COLD THE DISEASE CAUSED
THE HEART ATTACK WE KNOW THAT
KOBE IS A HIGHLY CARDIO TOXIC
SO IT'LL EIGHT IT IF A PERSON
WHO HAD CALLED THEN SURVIVES
AND THEN HAD A HEART ATTACK
YEAH THEN I COULD SEE THAT
THERE COULD BE SOME AMBIGUITY
BUT CERTAINLY COLD BIT
INFECTIVITY PLAYED A ROLE MORE
THAN LIKELY UNLESS THEY'RE
COMPLETELY ASYMPTOMATIC IN
WHICH CASE. WE MIGHT NOT EVEN
HAVE KNOWN THAT THEY WERE COLD
ACOSTA. ARE YOU WILL YES OTHER
STATES AND OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
MAKING THE SAME METRIC
DETERMINATIONS THAT WE ARE IN
THAT PARTICULAR INSTANCE. AND I
BELIEVE DR GHANI IS ALSO HAS
HIS HANDS UP I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I'M CALLING ON HIM IF
THERE IS ANY FOLLOW UP TO THAT.
QUESTION AS WELL. THIS IS TO
GUARANTEE IS I I'M NOT SURE
THERE'S A- GREAT DEAL. ROSS THE
COUNTRY WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CO MORBIDITIES
IF THEY HAVE HEART DISEASE
START IT HAD EMPHYSEMA START
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO END UP. YOU ARE AT
VENTILATION WITH THEIR RISKS OF.
TRYING TO READ OF IT NINETEEN
IS IT GREATLY INCREASE. WE
THOSE HIGH RISK GROUPS I DO
AGREE WITH DOCTOR WILL IN MOST
CASES YOU. IF SOMEBODY IS IT
MADE IT BECAUSE THE INITIAL
SYMPTOMS BOB THAT NINETY AYE
CHANGES IN THEIR LONG LONG
SHOWN. YEAH FINAL CAUSE OF
DEATH IS PROBABLY RELATED VIRUS
AND OTHER CO MORBIDITIES IS
TYPICALLY CONSIDERED IN
NINETEEN. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU
CENTER FOR JUST DID OU HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- NEXT WE
HAVE SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ACTUALLY- LET ME
JUST QUICKLY ACTUALLY TOUCH ON%
CENTER BOARD JUST THIS
QUESTION- SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
HAVE CULTIVATED. AND YOU DIE OF
LOVE FROM A MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCIDENT THAT'S NOT CANDIDACY
COBIT DUST. SO NOT EVERY DEATH
OF ANYONE WHO DESPITE THE FOR
KOBE ARMY TICKETS COUNTY AS
ECHO WITHOUT TO ASK ME SOME
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE TWO AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE ACT SAYS
MORE TALLY- WHICH IS THE DEATH
RATE BEYOND WHAT WE EXPECT FOR
THIS TIME OF YEAR IS MUCH
HIGHER ACTUALLY THE NUMBER OF
POLICIES WE HAVE. FOR THE
NINETEENTH WE TRY UNDER COUNTY
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING OF IT
BUT THE QUESTION I HAVE RELATED
TO. FIRST OF ALL FOR HUMAN FROM
WEST I. YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT USE. HAD NO. LOT SO
THAT'S EIGHT. ARE YOU USING
YOUR AND CAPACITY THE SO I MEAN
YOU'RE NOT. AT THE EDGE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW BACKLOG BUT CAN USE TO
IT DO YOU HAVE ACCESS TO OR NOT
USING IT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE ARE
ABLE TO GET SAN TO YOU. AND IS-
AND WHAT'S THE FASTEST YOU CAN
TURN AROUND THE TEST RESULTS
GIVEN THE FACT YOU DON'T HAVE A
BACKLOG YOU MENTIONED ONE TO
TWO DAYS- IS THE WHAT'S WHAT'S
KEEPING YOU FROM DOING IT EVEN
FASTER THAN THAT. SO DO YOU
SPEAK TO THIS PARTICULAR ASK
QUESTIONS. YES SIR- WE WILL
IT'S BEEN ABOUT THREE WEEKS
WHERE WE HAVE HAD SPARE
CAPACITY AT QUEST SO LIKE
DOCTOR GERDES IS REFERRING TO
HIS LABS. WE COULD BE DOING
AND- SIGNIFICANTLY MORE TESTING
OVER THE PAST THREE WEEKS SO
THAT'S WHY WE DON'T HAVE A
BACKLOG TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
TIMING. IT IS A QUESTION OF
WHERE THIS WAY WHEN YOU START
THE STOPWATCH- IF YOU START THE
STOPWATCH THE- YOU KNOW IT
EIGHT AM LET'S SAY FOR EXAMPLE
AND WE GET IT INTO THE LAB- BY.
MID DAY WE CAN GET YOU THAT
RESULT THAT EVENING- BUT A LOT
ABOUT SAMPLES IT'S ABOUT
GETTING THE SAMPLES FROM RURAL
CALIFORNIA- INTO THE INTO THE
LAB. OKAY AND SO WHEN YOU SAY
EXCESS CAPACITY IN TERMS OF SO
HOW WHAT PERCENTAGE ARE YOU WE
HEARD FROM USE THAT ARE YOU SEE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEIR MAY BE
DOING AL HACER LO MORE HALF.
WHERE WHERE ARE YOU IN TERMS
YOUR ACTUAL CAPACITY IN TERMS
OF ACTUAL SAMPLES YOU'RE
GETTING ARE YOU. LIKE 20%
ACCESS SPECIFIED PERCENT EXCESS
CAPACITY YEAH THE REST ESTIMATE
YET SO IT CHANGES CONSTANTLY AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE- BUT LOST. THE
LAST TWO WEEKS WE'VE BEEN
RUNNING. PROBABLY 25% BELOW OUR
CAPACITY. OKAY SO. THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY
YOU CAN DO A LOT MORE WE JUST
NEED TO GET. PEOPLE THAT THAT
SOUNDS LIKE RIGHT THE ISSUE.
AND THEN ACTOR TO YES FOR YOU
SEE AS YOU ALSO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND YOU SAID YOU REACHED
OUT TO PEOPLE WHAT SEEMS TO BE
THE GREATEST BARRIER TO BE ABLE
TO DO MORE TESTING SINCE YOU
HAVE THIS CAPACITY YOUR
LATITUDE SO. I GUESS IT IS A
QUESTION FOR BOTH QUESTION FOR
UC DAVIS IS IT THE DOCTOR
REIMBURSEMENT ISSUES FOR
EXAMPLE YOU CAN ONLY DO TEST
FROM CERTAIN PLACES BECAUSE YOU
WON'T GET PAID FOR THEM. ARE
THERE IS THAT- THAT PEOPLE JUST
ARSENIO LAST- WHAT WHAT WHAT
SEEMS TO BE. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE NEED TO DO MORE
TESTING. YOU HAVE ACCESS. SO
WHAT CAN I. YEAH THERE IS A
GREAT QUESTION. YEAH YOU KNOW
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST NOT. ISSUE
OKAY- FOR US- YOU KNOW. WE'VE
STREAMLINED AND I THINK THE CMS
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. IN MY MIND.
FOR THE- PC OUR **** VERY GOOD.
AND ALLOWS US TO BALANCE THE
NATURALLY DO SOME WORK WHERE
ARE THEIR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WERE REIMBURSED IS
GONNA BE A PROBLEM. WE WOULD
YOU KNOW I THINK YOU'D BE
RELEVANT YOUR QUESTION WE
SCREENED FOURTEEN HUNDRED
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AT UCSD AND
FOUND ONE POSITIVE. WE WENT OUT
TO A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
WHERE WE ACTIVELY SOLICITED
HELP. AND WE FOUND ABOUT A 40%
POSITIVITY RATE IN THE IN THE
PEOPLE WERE LIVING THERE. AND
SIX EMPLOYEES WHO WERE TESTED
POSITIVE IT AND NO SIGNS OF THE
ILLNESS SO WE GOT TO GET THE
HOT SPOT IS THE UNIVERSITY I
DON'T HAVE THE STAFF. INVOLVED
IN OUT REACH IN MARKET EIGHT
WITH DOING THE BEST WE CAN. BUT
IT'S LIKE THE OLD MOVIE BUILD
IT AND THEY WILL CALM I THINK A
LOT OF US HAD THAT IDEA THAT
THERE'S SUCH A NEED FOR TASTIC.
ALL WE NEEDED TO DO WAS PRESENT
OURSELVES AND SAY WE HERE WE
HAVE THIS CAPACITY YOU PEOPLE
WOULD REACH OUT. CONTRARY HAVE
TO AGGRESSIVELY AND IT TAKES
STAFF AND ARE WE PEOPLE AND WE
DO IN THE BEST WE CAN WITH.
WHAT WE HAVE AND UNIVERSITIES
TO DO THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT. WE
DON'T HAVE THE SAME CAPACITY
LIKE A COMPANY LIKE QUEST YOU
THAT KIND OF THING. BUT IT IS A
CHALLENGE AND THAT'S WHAT WE
LOOK TO THE STATE. THE TASK
FORCE AND OTHERS. TO DEVELOP
PROJECTS WHERE WE CAN
PARTICIPATE AND USE OUR ASSETS.
BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION. I
DON'T KNOW IN STATE TASK FORCE
SORT OF PUBLIC HEALTH PEOPLE
ARE THERE I MEAN WE'RE THE
COLLABORATION THERE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE THIS TESTING CAPACITY.
OKAY WE HAVE A DOCTOR I'M SORRY
MS SAUCY AND THEN- WE'LL GO TO
DOCTOR WHO THE GREAT A COUPLE
HANDS UP THERE. IF THERE'S TWO
SIDES OF TESTING MEMBERS OF THE
SAMPLE COLLECTION RIGHT AND
THERE'S THE PROCESSING OF THE
SAMPLE AND SO THE CAPACITY AND
PROCESSING EXAMPLE THE LABS HAS
GROWN AND IT IS VERY MUCH
AVAILABLE RIGHT- SWAPS HAVE
BEEN- DIFFICULT TO COME BY AS
WELL AS FIRE MEDIA AND THEN
IT'S AN ISSUE OF STAFFING WHICH
GOES BACK TO MY ORIGINAL POINT
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
ADEQUATE PUBLIC HEALTH STAFFING
IN PLACE READY FOR THESE KINDS
OF EVENTS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THESE IMPORTANT FUNCTIONS ON
THE GROUND AND THERE SOME
COLLABORATIONS THAT WE DO. BUT
FOR THE MOST PART WHEN IT COMES
THESE TECHNICAL KINDS OF THINGS
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH STOCK. I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR BUDGET REQUEST. THANK YOU
AND I THINK A WILL GO TO DOCTOR
WHO AND THEN DOCTOR DEAN. THERE
WAS JUST A- MEMBER THAT WAS
JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOME SAID YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO HAVE SURGE
PROTECTION WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO. PAGE A BIG BOULDER SELF.
ARE GONNA BE INFECTED AND THAT
WAS OUR HOSPITALS PRIORITY IS
TO BE SURE THAT WE CAN IT CAN
HANDLE ARE THE CRITICAL CARE
NEEDS OF NOT ONLY OUR PATIENTS
NOT ONLY. IN PATIENTS AND-
OUTPATIENTS WITH SYMPTOMS AND
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. NOW THAT
IT LOOKS LIKE- WE ARE ABLE TO
HANDLE IT I THINK WE SHOULD
EXPAND ON OUR SERVICES. BUT
STILL NUMBER ONE IN MY PRIORITY
IS MY PATIENCE AND WE'RE NOT
EVEN TESTING EVERYBODY WHO
COMES IN THE DOOR YET. THAT'S
OUR NEXT MISSION I AM NOT
LOOKING TO- TO HELP- EVERYBODY
ELSE'S ISSUE WHEN I CAN'T EVEN
FIND AT. IT'S ALWAYS A BY THE
WAY YOU SAID YOU CAN'T TEST
OCCUPATION SO WE HAVE ALL THIS
CAPACITY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
YOUR YOU SEE SO WHAT'S GOING ON.
SENATOR OUT IF WE WOULD LIKE TO
JUST FINISH UP THAT QUESTION WE
HAVE ABOUT- FOR OTHER SENATORS
AND WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE WAITING AS WELL SO- DOCTOR
WILL IF YOU LIKE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU. YEAH I MEAN
IT IT'S ALL ABOUT- ARE SLOBS
AND SUPPLIES AND THAT. WE CAN
ONLY DO WITH WHAT WE HAVE IN IT
WAS LITERALLY ONLY JUST THIS
WEEK THAT WE GOT A SUPPLY OF
BOB- ADDED ID NOW KIDS AND IN
THE END IN THE PASSAGE SO
PUTTING TOGETHER. OUR KIDS
WE'VE HAD FOUR OR FIVE
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS THEY HAD A
LOT CURRENT PRIME BUT THAT IS
RESOLVING AND SO WE ARE ABLE TO
WELL. YOU TAKE CARE OF OUR
PATIENTS ABSOLUTELY LET
LITERALLY AS OF THIS WEEK.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR WILL- I THINK SENATOR
PENN DOES THAT CONCLUDE. YOUR
QUESTIONS. AT E. S. I SEE
CHARITY DANGER I KNOW SHE WANTS
TO MAKE A FINAL COMMENT.
ABSOLUTELY DR DEAN. ON FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ENORMOUS EXPERTISE THAT DOCTOR
GUNN USE HAS. HELPED ADVISE THE
TESTING TASK FORCE TO LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT TESTING MODALITIES
AND STRATEGIES ON. EVERYTHING
THAT WAS JUST SHARED BY THE UC
SYSTEM AND BY QUEST IS REALLY%
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
CAPACITY AND WE KNOW THAT AND
WHAT WHAT WE ARE STRIVING TO DO
IS TO LINK UP THE SPECIMEN
COLLECTION SITES WITH THOSE
LABS THAT HAVE CAPACITY IN AS
WE SPEAK WITH THE RURAL
COUNTIES WE'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT RURAL COUNTIES TODAY. WE
ARE WANTING TO LINK THEM UP
WITH THOSE HAVE LABS THE UC
LABS I'M TALKING ABOUT IF THEY
HAVE A- CONTRACTOR IF THEY'RE
CLINICS HAVE CONTRACTS WITH
PRIVATE LABS HIS THERE'S ADDED
CAPACITY THERE SO THERE THERE
ARE OPTIONS ON THE TABLE RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE NOT BEING FULLY
USE. ON I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT PART OF THE ISSUE HAS BEEN
LACK OF SWAPS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE AS A STATE-
ARE. WE BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE BEEN A FEW WEEKS HERE BY
NEXT WEEK WILL HAVE- ENOUGH
SWAP TO TURN AROUND AND SEND
OUT TO THE COUNTY SO THAT'S
BEEN A MAJOR BOTTLENECK. BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY ARE LIKE WHAT WE
CALL A MAP MAKER MODEL WORK NOW
KING THE SPECIMENS BEING
COLLECT ACTUALLY IN ALL OF. HOW
CAN. YOU THERE ARE PRIVATE OR
WHEN THE SEA LAB I KNOW DR
GHANI AND I. DID ON EACH END
THAT ONE TO SENDS BEST. SO THAT
THEY CAN SEE ABSOLUTELY
CAPACITY. IT SHOULD. STOP GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A DOG DEAN
EN WE WILL. GO ON TO OUR NEXT
SENATOR FOR IN QUESTION SENATOR
JACKSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SO IF I IF I UNDERSTAND THIS
CORRECTLY WE NOW HAVE A GREATER
CAPACITY TO ANALYZE THESE OF A
TEST SO AS A RESULT THE BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LABS. GOING
ONLINE IF YOU WILL THE PROBLEM
IS BEEN SWAPS AND THEN THE RE
AGENTS AND WHAT I HEAR YOU
SAYING IS THAT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS THAT ISSUE SHOULD
BE RESOLVED SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO
UNITE TO BE ABLE TO. TO MEET
THE EXPECTATIONS ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF. OF THE LABS TO
DO THE TESTING WITH THESE FREE
AGENTS AND SWAPS NOW BEING
AVAILABLE I'M WONDERING NOW
WHAT HAPPENS IF WE DO GET A
SEARCH AND- I'M A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT THAT GOING FORWARD ARE WE
PLANNING TO KEEP THESE PEOPLE
I'M BOTH THE. THE FOLKS WHO ARE
GOING TO BE TAKE THE TO THIS
AND DO THAT WERE. ALONG WITH
THE LAB SO ARE THEY GOING TO BE
ON LINE CONSISTENTLY SO THAT IF
WE SEE A SURGE COMING IN
WHETHER IT'S THE SUMMER.
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN. GOING THIS
PHASE TWO OR THREE YEARS WHO
KNOWS WHAT- AND THEN IN THE
FALL WHEN WE START SEEING MORE
THE FLUID SPECTRUM. ARE WE
GOING TO BE PREPARED ARE WE
GOING TO GO TO THE SAME PROBLEM
AGAIN OF THE LACK OF SWAMPED I
MEAN HE'S JUST BEEN Q. TIPS.
THE NOTION OF. WE DON'T HAVE
THEM HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
IS JUST. MIND BOGGLING. ON THE
IT HAS BEEN A SORT OF A HURDLE
FOR US IN TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM. BUT ARE WE
ANTICIPATING WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE. ARE OUR
LABS AVAILABLE IN THE MATERIAL
AVAILABLE ARE WE WATER PAYING
THESE PRIVATE WHAT. ARE THEY-
THEY GETTING BURST THROUGH MEDI
CAL US SO THAT WE CAN
ANTICIPATE THEY'LL STILL BE
WITH. I IF THE SIR. GREED COMES
OR IS GOING TO BE MONEY OF THE
OUT OF GENERAL FUND. HOW IS
THIS ALL GOING TO WORK AS AS WE
GO FOR IT IN AND HAVE AN
EXPECTED SURGE SOME POINT IN
TIME. OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON'S. HER RIGHT ARM. COULD
WE ARE HERE TO TAKE THIS
QUESTION THERE WERE- I'LL THERE
WAS A LOT TO UNPACK THEIR
RELATIVE TO- FUTURE MANAGEMENT
AND WE'LL START WITH DOCTOR WHO
WILL. REGISTER JUST QUICK
COMMENT THESE ARE JUST A FEW
TIPS THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR
BATHROOM THESE ARE SPECIALLY
DESIGNED- TIPS THAT ARE ARE
.ORG NEWS OR THE BUT THIS
PARTICULAR PURPOSE TO TRACK
VIRUSES ARE NOT KILL THEM ALL
FOR WE HAVE A CHANCE TO TEST
THEM IN FACT THE ABIT ID NOW
HAS OLD SPECIAL Q. TIPS THAT
CAN BE USED WITH ANY OTHER
DEVICE CAN USE ONCE YOU. COULD
USE FOR ANOTHER SO IT'S NOT
QUITE AS SIMPLE AS THAT IT IS
STILL MAINTAINS TO BE A
SURPRISE. BUT TWO YEARS
QUESTION YEAH I'M- OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE TO PREPARE FOR THAT AND I
THINK THAT WE DO HAVE TO SET
ASIDE. RESOURCES AND SUPPLIES
SHOULD A SECOND WAVE COME EVEN
IF IT'S AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC SO. A DESIRE TO
KNOW IF THERE ARE IMPACTED.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WILL IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
ELABORATE. OKAY I THINK DOCTOR
DAVIS. SIR WE CANNOT HEAR YOU
WILL GO AHEAD AND ON MUTE YOU
IN JUST A MOMENT. THERE YOU ARE.
YEAH RIGHT NOW YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU THANK YOU. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT I DO UNDERSTAND AT
LEAST AT THE MOMENT- THAT THE
MAJORITY OF PLANS ARE COVERING
THAT- SO THERE IS THERE IS
REIMBURSEMENT FAIRLY FOR THE
MEDIC HOW PLANT. I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT BUT THE ISSUE THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM PROVIDERS
ESPECIALLY. AND LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE SERVING A
POPULATION OF THAT WE ARE
SEEING THE WORST HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAN ARE ALSO MISSING
THE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. IT'S NOT AS IF THE
SAMPLE EVEN IF THEY WERE GONNA
COLLECTED IN OUR OFFICE. AND
JUST BE DONE WITH WITH NOTHING.
ARE THERE IS GUIDANCE
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE CDC IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THAT- BUT THEY
DO OFFER HERE AT THE SAME.
ISSUE BOB NOT BEING AVAILABLE
AND THE OTHER IS ABOUT THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
THAT'S YOU TO. COLLECT IN THE
APPLE DOT. THANK YOU DOCTOR
DAVIS. AND SENATOR JACKSON. I
THINK WELL I DO HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN THAN THAN THAT
IT HAS TO DEAL WITH THE- I'M
WONDERING IF ANYONE HAS AN
OPINION ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S
EMERGING NOW IS DOING. WASTE
WATER- AND- TRACING AND WHETHER
THAT WOULD BE AN EFFECTIVE. WAY
TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT CASTING. A CRISIS TO DEAL
WITH THIS WELL I WONDER IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
JUST. THE BUNK WHETHER IT HAS
SOME VALIDITY WHAT THE EXPERTS
SEEM TO THINK AS FAR AS- USING.
ME ALSO SO WASTE WATER IS A
TOOL FOR- TRYING TO FIGHT THE
VIRUS IN INSIDE CONTINUED
INFECTING OF COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S. OKAY
LET'S SEE WHO WE HAVE HERE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY HANDS UP BUT IF
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO
TAKE THAT ON AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND TERMS OF WASTE WATER
MANAGEMENT. ALL RIGHTS WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE. PERHAPS WILL PUT A
PIN IN THAT AND THEN COME BACK
TO THAT IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
THOUGHTS AT THE END BUT WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD. TO SENATOR
MCGUIRE. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING CHAIR ALL HOLD MY
QUESTION I KNOW THAT WE'RE
GETTING LATE. WE HAVE A COUPLE
COMMENTS ALL HOLD MY QUESTION
INGESTING THE DECKS YOU THAT'S
ALRIGHT READING. VERY MUCH AND
WE HAVE THREE MORE SENATORS
SENATOR DODD. YEAH NO QUESTION
FOR ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR DOT I
APPRECIATE THAT WE DO HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE WAITING
SENATOR WIENER. NO I'LL PASS
OKAY AND FINALLY OUR MADAM CO
CHAIRS UNDER BATES. YES HERE
YOU HAVE ME MY ON YES YOU ARE.
QUESTION KNOWING THAT WE ARE
PUSHING THAT TIME BUT IT'S FOR
DOCTOR WOO AND THE DISCUSSION
OF ANTIBODIES OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY LEADS TO THE QUESTION
OF THE NATION ARE WE ANYWHERE
NEAR THAT CAN YOU COMMENT.
BRIEFLY ON. CAN WE BE RUNNING A
LEADING FROM ALL THE OTHER
BODIES I DO SOMETHING THAT
LOOKS LIKE A VACCINATION IN THE
FUTURE. DOCTOR WILL AS I CAN'T
I CAN'T COMMENT ON WHERE VERY
ON A VACCINE THAT SO NOT
SOMETHING THAT I PARTICULAR
WORKING ON WE ARE WORKING ON
THAT IT YOU SEE US OUT. WHAT
THE NEXT STEP IS TO IDENTIFY A
NEXT GENERATION- ANTIBODY TESTS
THAT CAN BE WIDELY DISTRIBUTED.
OUT SO WE SORT OF GOT INTO THIS
BECAUSE- THE FDA. DID NOT VET
THESE TESTS IN THE IN HOPES OF
GETTING IT OUT THERE AND I SOON
SUPPORTED THAT. EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION A LOT OF STEVEN
HAVE THESE TESTS TODAY BECAUSE
NORMALLY WOULD TAKE ONE TO TWO
YEARS. THEY GET ANY THESE OUT
HERE AND SO THEY SORT. OF HIS
PURPOSE BUT IT'S DEFINITELY
TIME NOW TO. LOOK AT A SECOND
GENERATION THIS IS MY OPINION.
THANK YOU BE ABLE TO SHARE THAT
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT CONTINUE
DOUBTS THAT OF ME THANKS AGAIN.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
BATES AND DOCTOR WILL ALRIGHT-
THIS CONCLUDES OUR QUESTIONS
FROM SENATORS AT THIS TIME SO
WE WILL- MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I JUST WANT TO.
REITERATE ALL MAINTAINED A
QUORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR COME
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES AND WE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING PATIENT.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE ON WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT SO. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE THE TOTAL. PEOPLE
WAITING TO BUY TESTIMONY PLEASE.
YES IN THE QUEUE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWENTY ONE WAY ANY. OKAY
THANK YOU TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE-
OPEN THE LINES AND ANNOUNCE
EACH COLOR INDIVIDUALLY SO WE
CAN BEGIN HEARING FROM THE
PUBLIC. I WAS REALLY FIRST
WE'LL GO TO A LINE OF ALISON
THROUGHOUT THE TO GO HEAD. ME
YES WE CAN ALISON HELLO. I AM I
AM HEARING A LOT OF WHAT YOU
GUYS PAYING AND BECAUSE THERE
IS A RISK OF DATA BREACH WILL
TESTING IN CONTACT TAKING BE
MANDATORY OR WILL BE OPTIONAL
WELL WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO OPT
IN OUT AT OPT OUT OF THIS- I'M
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
FAMILY IF YOU GUYS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THE LOW INCOME
DEMOGRAPHIC ESPECIALLY HEARING
FROM YOU GUYS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN FOUND TO BE TWICE AS
LIKELY TO. HAVE POSITIVE I AM A
LITTLE BIT WORRIED ABOUT HOW
THIS IS GOING TO- IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR THE
FAMILY I KNOW YOU GUYS TALK
ABOUT COMPENSATION BUT THE
WILLINGNESS TO COMPLY AND-
HEATING. IF THIS IS GOING TO BE
MANDATORY. OR OR NOT AND IF
THEY'RE GONNA BEAT PANIC
SCHMIDT AT THIRD CAN BE HE'S
FINE THINGS LIKE THAT AND HOW
THAT'S GOING TO FURTHER A PRESS
SOME OF THE- LOW INCOME.
DEMOGRAPHIC IN MINORITY GROUPS
AS WELL I AM A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT I WANTED
TO. YOU GUYS HAVE ANY PLANS ON
HOW TO ADDRESS THOSE AREAS.
THANK YOU ALISON AND WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT COMMENTED AGAIN
JUST TO CLARIFY THESE ARE
COMMENTS OF COURSE IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS OF THE PANELISTS I'M
SURE CAN- PROVIDE AS THOSE
ANSWERS- THERE AFTER BUT THIS
IS JUST A COMMENT PERIOD SO
THANK YOU FOR THOSE AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THE NEXT TO THE LINE OF
ANDREA REAGAN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU COMMITTEE
FOR ALL OF THE INFORMATION YOU
PROVIDED US ACCESS TO TODAY. I
DID WANT TO COMMENT I WORK IN
THE INDUSTRY OF DATA SECURITY-
I'M AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL AND-
CPNI. IS CRITICAL DATA PERSONAL
DATA IS A VERY VALUABLE
COMMODITY I WOULD REALLY AFTER
THAT- THE PUBLIC IS GIVEN. THE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IS BEING
ACTUALLY OBTAINED FOR EXAMPLE
IS THE DATA COLLECTION ONGOING
WITH THE MAC COLLECTION OR IS
IT AN AD HOC SECURE DATA
TRANSPORT ON REQUEST. FROM
SPECIFIC CASES SO THAT'S A-
HUGE CONCERN AND WE KNOW THAT
BREACHES HAPPEN AND WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE THAT
INFORMATION. BECOME MORE CLEAR.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THOSE COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. OUR NEXT WE'LLGO TO
LINE OF A FRIEND THAT- ORDER
THEY'LL SKI THIS GUY HAD HELLO.
HELLO HI MY COMMENT IS THIS ITS
MULTI FLOWS TOLD. I HAVE
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS AS MY
HUSBAND WAS BROUGHT TO A
HOSPITAL. WITH A GREAT TITUS WE
NEED TO BLADDER DISEASE. HE
CONTRACTED HE HAD NO SYMPTOMS
WHATSOEVER HE CONTRACTED THIS
WITHIN THE HOSPITAL. WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO GET. CLOSURE BECAUSE WE
CANNOT GET. AUTOPSIES BUT- SO I
WANT TO KNOW HOW THEY ARE GOING
TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION AND
THAT IF YOU ARE HAVING YOU ROLL
UP TESTING THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DOING YOUR TESTING COULD BE RE
INFECTING THE PEOPLE IN THE
NEXT CAR IN THE NEXT WALKING IN
THAT NUMBER TO. NUMBER THREE IF
PEOPLE ARE BECOMING LIKE MYSELF
BECAUSE I WAS EXPOSED TO HIM
THEY KNEW THEY TESTED HIM AND
NEVER TOLD ME HE TESTED
POSITIVE THAT MORNING I SAW HIM
IN THE AFTERNOON IT LASTED FOR
THREE MORE DAYS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS CATHERINE WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND DULY NOTED
WILL GO HEAD ON TO THE NEXT
COMMON EVERY- PERSON WHO'S
CALLING IN GETS ABOUT ONE
MINUTE SO THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WILL MOVE TO CAROLYN DANIELS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS KAREN DANIEL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS THREE HOUR
INFORMATION- I COME FROM MENTAL
HEALTH AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ISSUES THAT WORKED IN OVER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND 8100% OF THE CALLS
RIGHT NOW COMING IN FOR
CALIFORNIA GET A PLACE AN
ENGINE LIGHT. IS DEALING WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
I'M AFRAID THAT OUR RESOURCES
ARE ALREADY BARELY DEPLETED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
CONFLICTING INTERESTS OF
CASTING A CONTACT TRACING WHEN
WE HAD THE STATE ARE ALREADY
BORROWING FROM THE FEDERAL FOR
STATE UNEMPLOYMENT I THINK THE
COST OUT WE HI THIS THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT BEACH AND QUITE
FRANKLY EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. AND
I ASK THAT YOU LEAVE SOURCE
THOSE IN MENTAL HEALTH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THANK YOU THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
A NEXT WE GO ON OF JENNIFER
BEETLE THIS GUY HAD. HI ONE OF
THE CENTERS TALKED ABOUT HIS
INTERVIEW ON RIGHT NOW THAT THE
REALLY BIG CONCERN OF MINE I
HAVE TO FOSTER DAUGHTERS FROM
TWO DIFFERENT FAMILY THAT THEY
WERE HOME RIGHT NOW THEY WOULD
BE CONTINUE TO BE ABUSED. YOU
I'M SO THOSE PEOPLE ARE BEING
LEFT IN NO PROBLEM THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE AND THE ONLY
CONCERN IS ABOUT HAS BEEN IN
CONTACT TRACY. DO YOU- MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ARE NOT BEING
ADDRESSED BY THE FAMILY ON
EITHER HUGE CONCERN ALSO WHAT
ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED
TESTING- AND WHAT HAPPENED A
PEOPLE REFUSE TO BE TESTED
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A CONTENDER
BE ABOUT GOING BACK TO WORK OR
FOR KIDS TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
OR EVEN WITH THE HEALTH CARE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE SUBSEQUENT
MEETINGS WITH VARIOUS- OTHER
ITEMS RELATED TO COVERT SO WE
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
THOUGH THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. NEXT WE GO DO CRISTINA
HILDEBRAND PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
TO GET A HOLD RENT FROM OF A
TRADE THAT MAKE YOU THINK THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
I'M I HAVE THREE GREAT BUT
QUICKLY NUMBER ONE I REALLY
WOULD APPRECIATE IT THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR
WOULD DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
CONTACT TREATING INDIGENT. THEY
SEEM TO BE YOU THANK YOU THE
THING NAMELY WHETHER IT THAT.
WHAT YOU'RE TO WHAT YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY WITH THE IN
CUTS THAN OR OVER THE PHONE
UNDERSTANDING WHO'S BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH WHAT. BUT THE
DIGITAL APPLE GOOGLE WHATEVER
IT IS THAT COMES ABOUT I THINK
IT GETS VERY CONFUSING FOR
PEOPLE. AND THE SECOND POINT
THAT I WANTED TO MAKE IT
THERE'S NO TALK OF FOLKS PUBLIC
HAVE BEEN FOR NEGATIVE THEN THE
TESTING I THINK UP SOMETHING
I'M NOT A FISSION AND NOT
SOMETHING THAT INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND. THE
LEVEL OF BOTH POSITIVE AND
NEGATIVE ONE GENTLEMAN SHOWED
YOU KNOW SOMEBODY WHO HAD LOW
AND- PROTECTED POSITIVE COULD
THAT. HAVE BEEN TESTED HATE
BEING UP ALL OF THE- WE DON'T
KNOW OR MAYBE HE DOES BUT BUT
IT WASN'T VERY CLEAR TO AND
THEN THE- OF PEOPLE THAT DID.
IT WE ARE. AT GO BECAUSE BE IT
AT HOME FOR THE REST OF THE
TIME AND WE'RE LOOKING TO GO
BACK WHAT. WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
ALL THE WAY TO CREATE NATURAL
IMMUNITY CREATE ALLOW THE
PEOPLE BETTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS WE.
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALL PLEASE. X. WE GO TO A OF
AMY BONE THESE GUYS. YES HI.
PLEASED TO SHARE THAT TWENTY
NINE IN THEIR FOUR ONE HEALTH
DATA BREACHES AND ACCORDING TO
THE HEAD BUT JOURNAL BE REACHES
INCLUDED HEALTH DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING THE LA COUNTY. ONE IN
FOUR OF THOSE BREACHES COME
FROM EMPLOYEES AND WITH YOU
GUYS TALKING ABOUT HIRING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO ACT
YOU THE MATH DIGITAL
SURVEILLANCE THING OF
CALIFORNIA- AND WITHOUT AN END
IN FIGHT I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. AND THEN ALL AS
LONG ALSO WHO WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOT IF BUT WHEN
THEY GREET YOUR HEALTH
INFORMATION YOU WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FALL
CONFIDENT THAT FORCED PEOPLE
UNDER QUARANTINE OR ISOLATE THE
WRONG PERSON- AND FURTHERMORE
THANK COVERED NINETEEN IS IN
THE STARS FAMILY. HOW WILL
DIGITAL SURVEILLANCE AND
DISTINGUISH IT FROM THE MANY
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES THAT ARE
OUT THERE OR EVEN SIMPLE
SEASONAL ALLERGIES I DID YOU
TELL ME PEOPLE HURTING ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WITH YOU KNOW
OVER THREE MILLION PEOPLE OUT
OF WORK AND I DID. I DON'T SEE
HOW THAT THAT THE THING OF ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
THE NEXT GO TO. CULLITON THIS
HEAD. HI THANK YOU FOR. XFINITY
TO COMMENT I AM QUITE CONCERNED
WITH SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY WE
HONOR ALL POSITIVE ARE HAPPY MY
FAMILY IS NOT INTERESTED IN
BEING PASSED. FOUR FOUR FAX
RELATED AND CONTACT EIGHTEEN IS
QUITE CONCERNING WE ALL KNOW
THAT THEIR DATA BREACHES WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN IF OUR INFORMATION
GET OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR MY CONCERN THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME THANK YOU AS WELL.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THE NEXT
TO GO TO THE LINE OF ERICA
WALKER. ERICA YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME- YEAH I JUST LIKE TO ECHO
SOME OF THE OTHER CONCERNS THAT
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T FIFTEEN
NOTHING LIKE BETH- YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT. OTHER THINGS AND
OTHER. OTHER WITH THAT PEOPLE
FACE EVERY DAY AND WE HAVE TO
DO WITH BIRDS WILL BENEFIT AND
YOU KNOW THE BEST ISLAND. ALL
THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
THAT ARE YOU KNOW THE HIGH
DEATH RATE AS WELL AND- ARE WE
GONNA GET BLOCKED EVERYBODY UP-
AND WE GET SOME KIND OF. ALL
THAT NATION IT IS IT'S ABOUT
THE FAVORABLE PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY ARE HURTING ALL
OVER THE STATE. THEY'RE LOSING
JOBS SO I JUST WANTED TO I
THINK YOU GUYS PLEASE TAKE A
LOOK AT ALL THE DATA- AND YOU
KNOW NOT JUST BECOME. SO MUCH
FEAR. GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THE NEXT
SINGLE LINE OF CAROLINE RUBIO
IS GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAROLYN IDEA THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I'M I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT I DO NOT CONSENTTO
THE TRADE IN ANY WAY THIS IS AN
INVASION OF MY AND MY FAMILY
PRIVACY PROTECTED UNDER THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. MY BODY BELONGS NOT THE
GOVERNMENT I AM CONCERNED THAT
TRACKING IN FACING INFORMATION
GAINED IN THE PROGRAM COULD BE
USED TO ATTEMPT FORCED ME ON MY
FAMILY MEMBERS TO BE TESTED AND
OR FORCIBLY REMOVED FROM OUR
HOME. AND THAT AND THAT IS AN
EXTREME INVASION OF PIVACY AS
WELL AS DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST
LOW INCOME FAMILIES I'M ALSO
CONCERNED WHETHER THAT
INFORMATION COULD BE USED IN
ORDER TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO RETURN
TO WORK OR SCHOOL AND WHETHER
THIS WILL BE OPTIONAL OR
MANDATORY IN ORDER TO RETURN
THE WORKERS WELL. I'M I'M ALSO
HIGHLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF INFORMATION
BRIDGES WHICH ARE QUITE FUN I
DO NOT CONSENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS AS WELL.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. A NEW
SINGLE LINE OF YOU THAT TO BLUE
EYES BLACK THIS GUY HAD. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I'LL ALSO
VERY CONCERNED I DO NOT WANT TO
BE. DID IT- I DON'T WANT TO BE
TRACKED OWN VACCINATED. AND
ALSO ADDED TO THE TOTAL THE
DATE THE VALENCE OF EVERYONE IN
SOCIETY UNDER THE GUISE OF
CONTACT TREATING WHICH IS
VIOLATING THE FOURTH AMENDMENT
PROTECTION ARE PRIVATE HEALTH
INFORMATION IS NOT IN THE LOFT
OF PORTLAND PROTECT. PROTECTION
NOR SHOULD IT BE EXCEPT FOR THE
SAKE OF THE MAILING OF. I EVEN
THE ACL LU THE GOV NEEDS TO GET
A WARRANT IF IT WANTS ACCESS TO
OUR PRIVATE HEALTH INFORMATION.
AND I'M ALSO CONCERNED AND
BRIDGES I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO BEACH- EMPLOYED CAN
TAKE OUR MEDICAL INFORMATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. A
YES NEXT TO GO TO THE LINE OF
FIRST THE. THE TURKISH TO
CAMPBELL PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH
YEAH THANK YOU I'M AND GOVERNOR
OF FRAMEWORK FOR RE OPENING
THAT HE RELEASED A FEW WEEKS
AGO- SOMETHING THAT STUCK OUT
TO ME WAS THAT IT A COMPLETE RE
OPENING WOULD REQUIRE TESTING
TRACKING AND ISOLATING. LOOKING
BACK TO THE VERBIAGE OF AB TWO
BIG HILL. THAT BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER
ISSUE ORDERS TO EITHER
GOVERNMENT WELL AND GET YOU
WITHIN A LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
JURISDICTION TO TAKE ANY ACTION
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER DEEMED
NECESSARY TO CONTROL. THE
SPREAD OF COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
I HEARD A ABOUT I. TRY AND
TESTING TODAY AND I HAVE
CONCERNS THAT. THIS LANGUAGE AB
TWO SIX TWO WELL I GIVE A LOT
OF BREAD INTO WHAT ACTION IS
AND CAN BE CONSIDERED NECESSARY
WE ALL HEARD THE VENTURA COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT TALKING
ABOUT. BASICALLY PUTTING
REMOVED FORCING REMOVAL OF
PEOPLE FROM HOME IF THEY ONLY
HAVE ONE BATHROOM AND THEY ARE
IMPACTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. A NEXT TO YOUR LINE OF
NATALIE MORGAN TEENY LUCIA GO
AHEAD. HEY MY NAME IS NATALIE
MORGAN PLAINLY SCALE I AM FROM
THE GROWTH OF CALIFORNIA AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
HATCHED ON MY CAN TURN MY
CONCERNS ARE OBVIOUSLY BREACHES
THEY HAVE AN LL OF THE TIME
WITH HEALTH INFORMATION. THE
CARD INFORMATION AND SO I DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH EVEN MORE
DATA BEING COLLECTED ON MAY
FELT AMAZED WHEN MEMBERS. AND
I'M COMPARING TO THE TOWING
MANDATORY WHAT WILL THE
CONSEQUENCES BE IF WE DECIDE
NOT TO DO IT EVEN IF IT IS
MANDATORY AND SO I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE. THOSE QUESTIONS THAT
DRIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT COMMON PLEASE. THE NEXT
BILL AND MICHELLE GIVEN THE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHELLE GIVEN BUT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE AT THAT AGE
THAT CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WERE
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK
RESPOND COOLEY NINETEEN. AT THE
TOP OF THE FASHION NAY AND WE
AGREE THAT THERE IS A NEED TO
ENSURE THAT TESTING IS
AVAILABLE IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND I RURAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
EITHER WORK AT THE STATE ON OF
POLLUTION. AND CONTACT RATING
WE KNOW OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING HARD TO
THIRDS BACK AND HAPPY AND WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
EFFORT. WE ALSO AGREE WITH
SENATOR CAN'T COMMENT THAT THE
STAFF BEING PULLED FROM OTHER
AREAS WILL EVENTUALLY. NEEDED
WITHIN OUR WORK. WE NEED
ADEQUATE RETURN. HOW AND DANA.
STAFF CONTACT YOUR COULD NOT
YOU NEED TO CALL THE NAY. IT'S
NOT A- TERM. OR WANT TO PARTNER
MADE THE CUT. THAT KATHY TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF. THANK
AND- TO BE. MUCH OF ME BUILDING
SPECULAR. AND ATHLETE WHICH DID
NOT LATER THE AND. CONTACT YOUR
DOCTOR. INCLUDE MANY TO A FAST
IN THE ABILITY. I THE- TECH
INDIVIDUAL WITH SOCIAL SERVICES
AND SUPPORT AND MEDICAL NEEDS I
ANYTHING THAT THERE BE
ADDRESSED AND SOMETIMES THAT IN.
CONNECTING THEM OUR- HEALTH
CARE OR A CLINICAL STAFF. RANMA
BY HALF DID YOU CONTACTED AT
THE- THAT WE- JUST. IS BUT
INSTEAD WE BILL. AND BOLSTER
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. BUT NEXT
ALAINA VICTOR CHRISTY. HAD YEAH
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF VICTOR CRISTINA BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE HIGH
QUALITY CARE TO SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE AUTHORED A
UNIQUELY POSITIONED IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST RADICAL THE
NINETEEN BECAUSE THEY ARE
REALLY IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE OUR TRUSTED SOURCES OF
CARE FOR ANYONE THAT WALKS
THROUGH THEIR DOORS. WE ARE TO
SEE TESTING AND CONTACT TRACY
EARLY FOCUS FOR THIS COMMITTEE
A LIKE YOU WE BELIEVE TESTING
IS Q. DARK SPOTS RECOVERY MANY
HELP THAT ARE ALREADY BEGUN
TESTING NEED HELP THERE'S
WATCHING GAVE MORE READILY BUT
REMAIN MUCH CONFUSION OVER HOW
TO ENGAGE TO DATE THERE IS NOT
CLEAR AND CONSISTENT AT THE
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION
BETWEEN HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
EFFECTIVE CAN. COUNTY BY THERE
ARE SOME BEST PRACTICES
ACCORDING OF DR THE MAN. THEY
THE COURT MAY THINK APPROACH IS
NEEDED BUT COUNTY THEN THE CITY.
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. IN INCOME
HEALTHCARE AS THE ACTUAL. WE
NEED MORE LETTER IT WOULDN'T
HAVE TO COMMITTEE THE OUTLINED
NUMBER THE DESTINY. GREATER DO
IN THE FOR TO WITH YOU AND THAT.
AT THE CORE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VICTOR NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT WE GO TO
KRISTIN BELASCO THESE GUYS. I
MIGHT RETURN IS IN OUR FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT WITH SOMEBODY
ELSE YOU READY HI BUT- HOW HE
DOES THE PANEL THE WARRANT FOR
THE CONTACT. AND WILL YOU BE.
THIS OF BLOOD BY RICK FACT BY
ALL. I HAVE TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. YEAH OUR
NEXT WILL I KNOW SHAKIRA MCCALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT CONTACT RETAIN
AND VENTURA COUNTY MADE A
STATEMENT HEALTH DEPARTMENT
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE
SOMEONE AND THEY DIDN'T HATE
WITH VOLUNTARY FROM THEIR HOME
IF THEY WERE TECHNICAL BUT
NINETEEN AND THERE WERE MORE
THAN ONE PERSON LIVING IN THE
HOUSE. AND THEY ONLY HAVE ONE
BATHROOM I WOULD LIKE TO GET
CLARIFICATION ABOUT VOLUNTARY
ARE NOT FALLING KERRY BUT ALSO
LIKE TO KNOW WHERE THOSE PEOPLE
WOULD BE PLACED BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN THAT'S IT ATTACKS LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND THEY WILL BE
TARGETED AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE
A CHOICE. EDUCATION TO KNOW
THEIR- SO I THINK IT VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THEY KNOW THE
OPTION. SO THEY WON'T BE DARK.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THOSE COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. EXCELLENT NERISSA GLAD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I YOU KNOW
WE TAKE A LOT RISKS EVERY DAY
THAT WE'RE LIVING AND IN
LISTENING TO THIS PANEL AND GET
THAT FOUNDED THAT HERE IN
AMERICA WILL EVENT OR EVEN
ENTERTAINING THIS TYPE OF
CONTACT TREATING OPERATION
WHICH IS MORE REPRESENTATIVE OF
COMMUNIST CHINA- YOU KNOW THE
PANEL FOCUSED ON PAT BUT NEVER
MENTIONED ALSO ALL OF THE MANY
OTHER FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO. OVERALL HEALTH WHERE ARE
NATION IT'S HURTING
ECONOMICALLY AND PEOPLE ARE OUT
OF WORK THEY'RE DEPRESSED
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILY WHAT ABOUT THE
COST THAT IS FROM THE SHUT DOWN
AND NOW. YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
BEING OUT MONEY WE DON'T HAVE
TO GO TOWARD AN OPERATION SUCH
AS THIS INSTEAD OF BEING IT
PUTTING IT BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO TO A
LINE OF JENNIFER MILLER THESE
GUYS. IN FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
ABOUT WHY YOU ALL ARE OPEN
CALIFORNIA KEEPING OUR HIGH
RISK IN ELDERLY POPULATIONS
DETECTED WHILE ALLOWING
FACTORED IN UNITY AND- IF YOU
FEEL. I'M ALSO ABOUT HOW CAN
JUST BUYING CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT THAT AND BY ALLOWING FOR
A LOCK DOWN IF IT IS THEN BUT I
AND QUESTION I THANK TREAT AND
POSSIBLE BACK NATION. THANK THE
THING YOU VERY MUCH FOR NEXT
PLEASE. A NEXT WE GO TO LINE OF
INDIA D. MERRY UP THESE GUYS AT.
THANKS A LOT WELL YOU GUYS
REALLY ARE OPEN AT THE GOOD GET
ALONG FINE- REGARDING. YOUR
TWENTY EIGHT FEET WE ALL KNOW
THAT THROUGHOUT HISTORY NEVER
ABOUT STATE YOU THOUGHT CONTROL
ALL OF THIS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT COMPLETELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL MANY OTHERS
SEE WHERE THIS IS GOING AGAINST
OUR FREEDOM. WE HAVE NEVER
STOPPED ARE CORNY EVER
THROUGHOUT ALL THE MORE COMPLEX
THE WHITE. IF YOU WERE LEADING
MANDATORY HELLO THE BACK WALL
THAT CAN I GET YOUR TOTALLY.
SALIVATING OVER THIS. BEYOND OR
WELL. WE NEED ALL. ADAM
BUSINESS FIRST PRIVATE. YOU
LET'S GET TO KEEP OUR RIGHT THE
CONSTITUTION WE ARE STILL
TOWARDS BELT PLEASE IN A REAL.
THE USA THIS IS RIDICULOUS AND
I'D LIKE TO GO TO THE- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND AGAIN- THIS IS ON
TESTING AND CONTACT TRACING ARE
RELATED TO COVERT NINETEEN BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT PLEASE
NEXT WITH A LINE OF DENNIS
CUEVAS ROMERO IS GOOD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR DEMOCRATS
ROMERO WITH THE IS TELL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA- SHAPE THE HEARING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BECAUSE THE
SYSTEMIC RACISM COVERED
NINETEEN HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT OF BLACK PEOPLE AND THAT
TREND CONTINUES IN CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH CLEAR DISPARITIES
FOR ABOUT THE NEXT INDIVIDUALS.
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
SIMILAR DISPARITY PATTERNS
AMONG PACIFIC ISLANDERS AS WELL
CENTRAL UNDER TRACK IN THE
NATIVE INDIVIDUAL WITHOUT
COMPREHENSIVE DATA COLLECTION
AND TRACKING THAT HONORS
PRIVACY RIGHTS FOR INDIVIDUAL
OF THE STATE WILL CONTINUE TO
MISS THE MARK AND EXACERBATE
HEALTH DISPARITIES AMONG PEOPLE
OF COLOR. AS IT RELATES TO
CASTING AND THE STATE ON HEALTH
COMMUNITY CITIES AND COUNTIES
MOST RECOGNIZED THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF THE
NINETEEN ON THAT HOUSE PEOPLE
AND THE NEED TO WIDE SPREAD
PAST FEELING SHELTERS AND CAT.
WITHOUT BE THERE WILL BE
CONTINUED TO BE DANGEROUS
OUTBREAK. TESTING SHOULD BE
MOBILE AND GO TO WORK ON HEALTH
PEOPLE LIVE BECAUSE MANY OF THE
PEOPLE HAVE HELP AND
TRANSPORTATION CHALLENGES CAN
APPRECIATE EVERYONE- FOR
TODAY'S HERE HANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NEXT WE'LL LINE OF BECCA KRAMER
MAO YOU GOT. HERE AT THIS IS
BACK AT CAMERON ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
ADDITION TO THE CONCERNS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE BANISTERS REYES
WE'RE OFF THE CONCERNED ABOUT
MERRILEES REQUIREMENT THAT
ANYONE ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS
TESTING AND- HAVE A GOOGLE
ACCOUNT AND AGREED TO ALLOW
THEIR LEAD TO SHARE THEIR DATA.
WITH THEIR SISTER COMPANY
GOOGLE AS WELL AS THIRD PARTIES
LIKE SALES FORCE ACCESS TO
CRITICAL TESTING SHOULD NOT
DEPEND ON WHAT CREATING AN
ACCOUNT AND SHARING INFORMATION
WITH WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY AN
ADVERTISING COMPANY. THE
EXPANSION OF THE STATE YOU
BARELY TO INCREASE TESTING AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AMPLIFIES
CONCERNS AND WORRIES AS
DISPARATE IMPACT WE ARE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW MEDICAL
INFORMATION SUCH AS ONE CODE
THAT NINETEEN STATUS. WOULD BE
IMPLICATED BY CONTACT TRACING
WHETHER DONE BY APPS OR NEW
CONTACT TAKING PERSONNEL NOT
ADEQUATELY TRAINED IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PRIVACY MATTERS AS
WELL AS CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
PROTECTIONS WOULD BE IN PLACE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE A LOGICAL
TAX STRUGGLE TO BE USED ONLY
FOR VALID PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES. INCLUDING GUARANTEES
THAT THE DNA SAMPLE DATA
LOGICAL TESTING CANNOT BE USED
FOR ANY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS TO INCREASE THAT.
NINETEEN THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. X. BE JUST C<c.cyan> CLAN A</c>
HAND PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YOU
FOR TAKING MY CALL MY NAME IS
JESSICA CLAMMY HAND AYE WORKING
OUT WHERE. ARE TO GROW
CALIFORNIA I WORK WITH A VERY
LOW SOCIOECONOMIC- POPULATION
IT WHICH ARE OFTEN HOMELESS OR
TRANSPLANT- DOUBLED UP- THE I
WOULD SAY IT'S NINETY PERCENT-
TITLE ONE SO WE HAVE THE LOWEST
OF THE LOW. BIG BILLS HE DIDN'T
STAY IN AND DAY OUT AND I CAN
TELL YOU RIGHT NOW WITH THE
SHUT DOWN. AND OUR STUDENTS
HAVE ALL BUT DISAPPEARED. THEY
HAVE GONE INTO- YOU'RE NOT AT
HOME LIKE GENERATION THEY'RE
LIVING IN WITH THEIR ABUSERS. I
HAD TO CONSIDER LGBT KILL WHICH
WERE IDENTIFIED AS BEING A
VERY- HIGH NEED POPULATION WHO
ARE TYPICALLY NOT OUT AT HOME.
THERE'S A SPACE IS THE CORE
THEIR IDENTITIES ARE EXPECTED
AND HONORED. AND I AM. NOT SURE
I A IS THE CASE IN NOT LIKE AND
VERY THE STUDENT AND THEIR
FAMILIES. IT'S HARD ENOUGH TO
GET THEM TO AND THEN WILL EVEN
WITH THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THE NEXT
TO GO TO JUST GO CANNOT TELLO
THE GO AHEAD. I THINK IN PUBLIC
HEALTH SACRIFICE WE NINE JOB
NOW YOU WANT TO ACT RIGHT
ALRIGHT TO PRIVACY AND FREEDOM
BY WE GET BACK UP BY THIRTY
RIGHT ON HISTORY I SHALL WE
MUST BE CHANGED THEM IN ORDER.
TO PREVENT ALL MET. GRANT YOU
KNOW LIKE. EVEN BY OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT IS
ARE A TEAM PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
AFTERNOON THAT THE FEDERAL
STATE AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY
AND APPRECIATE THE HEARING ON
THE DEADLY PEERING FROM THE
LOCAL- PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT- COUNTY THAT MADE
ENORMOUS EFFORT THERE ARE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT DURING
THE- ENDEMIC AND ENDEMIC
RESPONSE. WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR AND DOCTOR DEAN OF
THE PASSPORT BUT EVERYBODY AT
THE PH WHO HAVE MOVED OUT TO
GET US TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY
INCLUDING- MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND HAVE A DAY BUT AS
SENATOR MCGUIRE NOTED THERE ARE
STILL TESTING DESERT- AND WE'RE
STILL DESPERATE FOR TESTING
CAPACITY IN THE MAJORITY OF
COUNTY. MALL COUNTY- MORE OUT
OF THE WAY COUNTY- AND THAT IS
CRITICAL TO OF BEING ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE DISEASE IS
AND- HOW AND WHEN WE CAN RE.
BUT OFTEN NEED RAPID TESTING SO
THAT- YOU TO BE COUNTED CAN
AFFORD TO HAVE A SAMPLE TRAVEL
HOURS ONE LANE BUT OURS BUT
ANOTHER WAY- WHEN TRYING TO
TRACE AND TRACK THIS IS THE-
AND LASTLY I WANT TO SAY- I
COMMAND A DOCTOR PAN FOR
COMMENTS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
MEETING WORKFORCE NEEDING
TRAINED WORKFORCE FOR A LONGER
PERIOD THAN A FEW WEEKS- WE-
NEED TO AS WE TALK ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU AND REBUILD. NUMBER
PLATE THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NEXT TWO. FELDER THESE GO AHEAD.
GOOD APP MADAM CHAIR INVOLVED
AROUND HERE WITH THE WHITE
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA OF HEALTH SYSTEM
PHARMACISTS- WERE TESTIFYING
TODAY TO ASK THE PHARMACIST IN
CALIFORNIA BE UTILIZED. TO
ORDER AND ADMINISTER FDA
APPROVED COPE IN TOUCH WE THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SO THAT
WE CAN HELP RAPIDLY EXPAND
TESTING CAPACITY IN THE STATE
IN ADDITION TO THE STATUS THAT
WERE CALLED IN EARLIER BY
SENATOR DODD AND I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FROM 90% OF
THE PUBLIC LIVES WITHIN. FIVE
MILES OF A PHARMACY AND
PHARMACISTS ARE OFTEN THE- ONLY
ADVANCED HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL PROFESSIONAL
THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO PEOPLE IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WORLD
WE ARE AWARE THAT REGULATORY
BARRIERS EXIST IN CALIFORNIA
RELATED TO AUTHORIZE YOU
PHARMACIST TO ORDER AND
ADMINISTER TESTS BUT WE'VE SEEN
OTHER STATES INCLUDING NEW YORK
ILLINOIS AND PENNSYLVANIA THAT
HAVE. DEALT WITH THOSE
ROADBLOCKS BY EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND WERE ENCOURAGING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BE THE SAME
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT IS
THE LANA SANTA MARIA PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME ONLY
NOTHING YEAH AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE MORE THAN FIFTY
FIVE PROGRESSIVE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT MAKE UP THE BUILDING THE
CALIFORNIA JOURNAL AND TODAY
THE ALLIANCE MADE PUBLIC A LIST
OF RECOMMENDATIONS IN RESPONSE
TO THE PANDEMIC THAT READERS.
ISSUE THE ADDRESS TODAY AS WELL
AS FOLK THE- SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICEREFORM. OUR
CURRENT ECONOMIC SYSTEM WHICH
BENEFITS SELECT YOU IS BROKEN.
AND ARE FIFTEEN THAT IS FAR TOO
THING TO PROTECT MOST NOTABLE
CALIFORNIANS IN THE BEST OF
TIMES MUCH LESS DURING A
PANDEMIC. I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS FROM DOCTOR DAVID
TENNANT STOPPAGE ABOUT AS IT
RELATES TO ETHNIC DATA
COLLECTION TO BEST SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THE ALLIANCE LOOK
FORWARD WITH COLLABORATING WITH
THE COMMITTEE IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT WE GO
TO ACTUALLY READS THESE GO
AHEAD. HI YES I AM MICHAEL
BARRON IS THE DATA BREACHES
THAT COME ALONG WITH AND
EXECUTING SOMETHING AS LARGE OF
BEST SPECIALLY WITH. MANY
PEOPLE WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA MY
OTHER CONCERN IS THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
MANDATORY FOR CHILDREN TO
RETURN THE CALL AND PEOPLE TO
RETURN TO THE WORKPLACE. AND AT.
THERE IS ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN VENTURA
COUNTY WHERE THEY'RE SAYING
THAT THEY CAN REMOVE PEOPLE
FROM THEIR HOMES. IF THEY HAVE
ONLY ONE BATHROOM AND YOU KNOW
THAT THEY- CAN I ASK YOU TO
COME OUT OF THE QUESTION OF
PEOPLE. AND I I'M WONDERING WHY
ALL THE HEALTH OFFICIALS BETTER
HERE TODAY ARE LOOKING TO MEET
AND FOR THEM ON ALL OF WHAT A
DYING. AND SHE ACTUALLY CHEAPER
THAN MANY RATHER THAN. GOING ON
UNCONSTITUTIONAL OUT OF
TRACKING AND TREATING YOUR
SENATE THAN. I AM YEAH AND I
THINK THE MATH WE NEED PEOPLE
NEED TO GET BACK TO WORK. AND
WE NEED REAL SOLUTIONS
INCLUDING AROUND TALKING ABOUT
WHY CASTING AND MARK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NEXT IS MARIE COPE. IS YOU HAD.
I DON'T THINK LIKE THE LACK
CALLER BAG IF CON WHAT HAPPENED
WE SHOULD NOT BE TRADE WE
SHOULD NOT BE TRACKED IT IS. SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE AND SO MUCH
ANYTHING CHANGED A NUMBER
MULTIPLE TIMES BUT WHO THAT
AFFECTED FIRST BUMPING THE BIKE
OF A LITTLE SO WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO SHUT DOWN FOR MORE
MONEY EVERY YEAR AS- A FEW
PEOPLE GET THANK. IT'S
ABSOLUTELY UNNECESSARY AND
UNCALLED FOR AND OUR GOVERNMENT
IS MAKING A HUGE OVER. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT THIS IS
ONLY A GRIPPING THIS GUY HAD.
THEY ONLY A GROUPING OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
I WANT TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION
TO A LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
ACNE LOCAL ONE NINE ONE ONE
WHICH IS COMPRISED OF PRIVATE
SECTOR EMS WORKERS- RELATED TO
PAY CASH AND THERE'S AN ISSUE
RIGHT NOW BUT THAT I WANTED TO
AMPLIFY- DURING THIS CRISIS THE
CALL VOLUME FOR MEDICAL
TRANSPORT HAVE DROPPED.
SIGNIFICANTLY AND GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS SOME OF THESE EMG THEY'RE
NOW ELIGIBLE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT-
DUE TO REDUCTION AND AVAILABLE
HOURS MEDIUM HEAT ARE AVAILABLE
WORK FOR WORK FORCE THAT COULD
BE USEFUL IMPORTANT HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM EVEN IN NON TRADITIONAL
ROLES INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED
TO CONTACT TREATING- SPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT FOR PRESS EMS
WORKERS HAVE BEEN DONE TO DATE
AND ACCURATE QUOTE FASHION.
WITHOUT REACH INITIATED BY
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH HOMELAND
SECURITY INDIVIDUAL FACILITIES
AND WE THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE EXPANDED AND
COORDINATED STATEWIDE- BE
SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT HAVE
PROVIDED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS TO MAINTAIN
A FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT.
ALTHOUGH STILL SUPPORT ARE ALSO
SUPPORTING THE NEED WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. EVEN IN A
NONTRADITIONAL. LIKE A MAN
CREATE OF A DAY YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR- I'M ABOUT THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF I.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. A NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
THE NEXT TO GO TO MICHELLE
FORWARD THIS GUY HAD. HI I'M
SORRY DID YOU SAY MICHELLE FORD
YES GO RIGHT AHEAD. I THINK
YOU- SO FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LOVE IT- IF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WOULD SPEND MORE
TIME. BEING CONCERNED ABOUT
EDUCATING OTHERS ON A MILLION
BOOSTING THERAPIES I THINK THAT
SPENDING ILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON- CRIMINALIZING. CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS THIS WAY IS VERY
DIFFICULT- AS A TAXPAYER AS A
PARENT AS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER OF THE PROPERTY OWNER I
THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING ABOUT
IT ALL WRONG. I FEEL THAT
YOU'RE CRIMINALIZING THE GERM
INSTEAD OF HELPING PEOPLE TO BE
HEALTHY AND I'D LIKE TO REMIND
YOU THE PEOPLE THAT ARE A
SYMPTOMATIC ARE A SYMPTOMATIC
BECAUSE THEIR BODIES. HAVE A
STRONG IMMUNE SYSTEM THAT ARE
FIGHTING THOSE OUTWARD
EXPRESSION. SO INSTEAD OF
CRIMINALIZING EVERYBODY WENEED
TO TEACH THE OTHER TWENTY
PERCENT. HOW TO BE HEALTHIER.
AND THAT'S MY PUBLIC COMMENT
SORRY ONE MORE THING I'D LIKE
TO TURN YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
LETTER FROM ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR DATED APRIL TWENTY
SEVEN TO TWENTY TWENTY.
REGARDING BALANCING PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFETY WITH THE
PRESERVATION OF CIVIL RIGHTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
NEXT IS DANNY MARTINEZ THESE GO
AHEAD. HI IS IT ANY MARTINEZ MY
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE COMMENTS TODAY. ACTUALLY
FROM SENATORS DAUGHTER AND
SENATOR JONES REFERENCING OUR
LETTER TO YOU I WOULD SEE A MAY
TO THE GOVERNOR- WE REPRESENT
PHARMACIST IN EVERY HEALTH CARE
SETTING INCLUDING INDEPENDENT
RETAIL AND HEALTH SYSTEMS- WE
WHAT WE LOOK FOR TO- WE
HOPEFULLY RECEIVING THE
AUTHORITY TO EXPAND THE NETWORK
OF TESTING ARE GIVEN ALL THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
TODAY. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU AND
ACTUALLY MODERATE THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS AND MODERATOR WE
PLEASE ASK IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. AND IF SO
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE LEFT. I
WANT COUNTY LIKE TESUQUE IF YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO ENTER THE QUEUE- AT
THIS TIME WE STILL HAVE NINE IN
Q. OKAY. WONDERFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT MODERATOR
AND WE'LL GO ON TO THE NEXT
QUESTION. OR COMMENT NEXT- WE
GO TO LINE OF KATHERINE- POOR
RESULTS SKI PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
COMMENT IS FOR THE PHARMACIST
WHO WANTS TO PUSH DOING
TESTING. LOCALLY IN STORES. YOU
HAVE TO BE AT OF YOUR BIRD.
SHOULD NEVER BE IN A RETAIL
SETTING. WE NEED BODY AUTONOMY
FOR THESE TESTINGS. BRING
TESTING TO THOSE PATIENTS
ESPECIALLY THE HOMELESS. WHO
ARE AT RISK. AND DESPITE
WEARING PP. I FEEL THAT THEY
ARE BEING EXPOSED FROM GETTING
TESTED AND THEN THE FIRST IN
THE FINAL LINE IS SYMPTOMATIC.
DOESN'T KNOW THEY HAVE IT TO
THE TEST COMES BACK BUT THE GUY
AT THE END OF THE LINE NOW. HAS
IT A COUPLE DAYS LATER IT
HAPPENED IN MY CASE IT KILLED
MY HUSBAND DESPITE WHAT HE HAS.
GOING INTO THE HOSPITAL. AND
THIS IS WRONG. NOT BEING ABLE
TO GET YOU WHAT. I'M SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. A NEXT YEAR TO CHRISTY
BALBOA THESE GO HEAD. I THANK
YOU CHRISTY BAMA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. I DO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
VERY BRIEFLY A YOU KNOW THE MEN
AND WOMEN THE FIRE SERVICE
COMING OUT OF THE FRONTLINE-
PROTECTING THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND- HAVE. YOU KNOW CONTINUE TO
SUFFER FROM EXPOSURE I THINK
WHEN YOU ARE TAKING A LOOK AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM THEN
THE CONTACT TRACING AND ALSO
JUST MANAGING. EXPOSURES TO.
REMIND YOU MAYBE TO ALSO LOOK
AT THE EXISTING LAW ONLY
RELATING TO NOTIFICATION OF THE
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE FIELD WHEN
THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE BECAUSE I
REMEMBER FINDING OUT IN THE
MEDIA. WHEN THEY HAVE
TRANSPORTED- RESPONDED ON A
PATIENT THAT HAS BEEN
HOSPITALIZED AT THE MOMENT. TO
COME TO THE DISEASE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR YOUR WORK
THANK YOU CHRISTY APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AS
WELL AS THE NEXT. COMMENT
PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO TO JAIL
ON A CAMP GO AHEAD. HI THERE-
SO WITH THE MILLION UNEMPLOYED
IN CALIFORNIA WITH FORTY
MILLION. CONTACT RATING IS HOW
LONG THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
UNITY ADDS THAT DOCTORS THEY
HAVE TO FIND BUT CLEARLY THAT
HOSPITAL AND HAS BEEN HAVE BEEN
OPEN AND AVAILABLE FOR OVER
THREE WEEKS- SO THE TASK FORCE
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR NON WORKERS
NOT WORKING RIGHT NOW IF YOU
LIVE FORWARD. BY WITH OUT ON
TAX REFORM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. BUT NEXT
YEAR TO LINE OF RESEARCH ESTERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK YOU
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED THE BE
RESTRICTED WILL BE FORCED OUT
MYSELF MY CHILDREN AND I
RESOLVED IT WILL BE A WELCOME
WELL AND THEY- THE CATHOLIC
SCHOOL AND BE REMOVED FROM OUR
HOMES. HOW GOING TO GET THE JOB
WHO ARE WE ONE HUNDRED COUNTRY
RECALL ARE YOU ALREADY ARE YOU
ALREADY DISCUSSED THAT WITH HOW
WE SEE LONG FORTUNATE THREE
LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
GRAFFITI. VIDEO ARE CALLED THE
PEOPLE BEINGBURNED ALIVE. AND
ABLE SOCIAL. I'M NOT WORRIED
ABOUT SO. WHAT WILL BE OUT OF A
HOME TESTING POSITIVE FOR AT
THE CONTACT WITH THE VOTING. IT
WILL BE OPEN YOU THAT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL NEXT COMMON
PLACE. A NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF AMBER READ THESE GO HEAD.
THE COMMITTEE TALKED ABOUT
TEACHING CONTACT THREE THIRTY
OUT OF BIRTH WEIGHT HAS THAT
CAN INDIVIDUALS. TO MAKE A
COUPLE THAT CASTING. WORST AND
AS AN RN I DO NOT REFORM
PROCEDURES OKAY THANKS WITHOUT
INFORMED CONSENT AND THE WAY
THAT IS NOT INFORMED. CONSENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
MODERATOR I JUST ONE MAKE AT A
TIME CHECK HERE HOW MANY MORE-
A TO ATTEND WITNESSES I'M SORRY
DO WE HAVE AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE FIVE MORE IN THE QUEUE OKAY
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THE
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. OKAY NEXT
TO GO TO JUST CUT CABRERA
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HATE I HAVE
CONCERNED ABOUT DOCTOR JEAN
CONSIDERING THERE HAS BEEN AN
OFFICIAL INVESTIGATION THAT
ADMITTED TO THE DOJTO RUNNING
GAME OF LEGAL. ACTION PARTY TO
LEGAL AUTHORIZATION. ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE COMPOUNDING
EFFECT ON A LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE KNOW
ARE BEING GREATLY AFFECTED I
LIKE FOR YOU GUYS TO CONSIDER
WAYS THAT WE CAN BUILD BETTER
COMMUNITY AND HELPING OUR BLACK
AND BROWN COMMITTEES. OTHER
GREAT INTRUSION OF THE FISHER
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. ALSO
CONCERNED WITH. OUR RESULT OF
TESTING ARE MADE PUBLIC WE ARE
GOING TO FACE THE BACKLASH.
LIKE THE ASIAN COMMUNITY
SPEAKING WITH RACISM AND HATE
CRIMES SO THE THING THAT I
WOULD LOVE THE COMPUTER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ARE YOU WORK
WITH EVERYTHING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT
WE GO TO AMY MCCAMLY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THANK YOU I WOULD
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO BE READ
THE CONSTITUTION THE LAST TIME
I CHECKED TO LIVE IN AMERICA MY
BIGGEST CONCERN ABOUT THIS
CONTENT TREATING. BUT ARE NOT
INCLUDED MANDATORY AND YOU
MIGHT SAY WELL NO OF COURSE NOT
GONNA BE MANDATORY. AT THE TWO
SEVEN SEVEN BUT THE MANDATORY.
KIND OF THE HEAD THAT HE DIDN'T
GO AHEAD AND POWER WITH THAT.
ACTED PROBABLY ABLE GO TO
SCHOOL SO AGAIN THE BIGGER
CONCERN IS GOING TO BE WHY ARE
WE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
TO LIVE A LIFE. MY NEXT TO MY
POINT IS. HOW MUCH MONEY WE'RE
SPENDING AND PINE YOU KNOW WE
ARE CREATING NEW JOBS AND NEW
TRAINING A NEW THING. ALL
AROUND THE AYE NAY BUT IN THE
MEANTIME I CAN'T TAKE MY
CHILDREN TO THE DENTIST. I
DOCTOR. YEAH WE REALLY NEED
ABOUT THE BIG PICTURE WILL IN
THOUSAND FOUR RIGHT NOW. AND AT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS PLEASE AT
THE COPY. WE DO LIVE IN AMERICA.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
THE NEXT WE GO TO APRIL MCAT
DISICK PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WE
ARE NOT LIVING IN THE BOOK
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR IT IS
TWENTY TWENTY THE INVISIBLE
ENEMY AS DOCTOR GERM BUT THE
ATTACK OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
FREEDOM AND PRIVACY. BUT I HAD
THE AFTER MEDICAL OZONE THERAPY
WILL KILL LITERALLY ANY JUROR
BANK WITHIN EBOLA- WE JUST NEED
TO HAVE IT AND ALL THE FAR
EASTERN BLOCK THE PHARMACIES.
OBVIOUSLY THEY WANT THAT SO
LET'S PUT MEDICAL OF THE
PHARMACIES AND PEOPLE CAN GO
AND GET THEIR OF MEDICAL OF THE
WATER THEY CAN HAVE A JACKET
AND THEY CAN KILL THE TERM AND
THEN KILL ANY OTHER FUTURE
PANDEMIC THAT OUR PLANET. AT TO
BE COMING OUT AT AND- IT'S
REALLY BAD FOR US TO BE SOCIAL
DISTANCE ENOUGH NOT THAT FAR
NEED JUST DOESN'T. TALK TO ANY
KNOWLEDGE YESTHEY WILL TELL
YOU THAT SOCIAL CONTACT
STRENGTHENS YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM
IT IS WEAKENING ARGUE WITH AN
EXAMPLE OF REACHING HER NUDITY
BY LEADING THAT YOU'D OUR GOD
GIVEN BACK. THE MAKER WHICH IS
OUR BODY. FIND BODY MAKES. NOT
THE GERMAN EXPOSURE HELP YOU
KEEP. WE WILL GET TO UNITY AND
THEN THANK FOR YOUR CALL. STATE
EX CON PLEASE. A NECK TO GO TO
MARK. IS GOOD HI THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE PUBLIC COMMENT. THIS
IS IN REGARDS TO CONTACT
TRACING I'M SURE THAT YOU GUYS
ARE WELL AWARE VERY UNPOPULAR.
THE WHOLE STATE IS VERY VERY
ANGRY AND IT'S GETTING ANGRIER
AND ANGRIER AND CONTACT TRACING
WHICH IS. UNNECESSARY THEY'RE
GONNA SEND US OVER THE BOILING
POINT. SO I'M SURE THAT WHAT
YOU GUYS INTENT IS BUT NINE BUT
IF YOU'RE BUILDING UP HERMAN
SURVEILLANCE STATE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS THE OPPOSITE
OF BENIGN. THANK YOU YOU DUMP
THIS PROGRAM. BUT IF YOU DON'T.
I ADVISE YOU TO PUT A SUNSET
CLAUSE IN IT SO THAT THE REST
OF THE POPULATION KNOWS THIS IS
NOT GOING TO BE PROMINENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND I THINK WE HAVE
OUR FINAL- WITNESS AT THIS
TIME- PLEASE MOVE FORWARD WITH
YOUR COMMENTS. YES OUR FINAL
COMMENT WILL COME FROM CRYSTAL
HERRERA HE'S GOT A HEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CALLING
BECAUSE- WITH THE COMPETITION
AND I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU GUYS
TO NOT DO THE CONTACT YOU CAN
GET THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE IT GOES AGAINST OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS ARE FOR
THE NIGHTMARE RIGHT I CAN'T
NINETY RIGHT AND ARE FOURTEENTH
MY RIGHT. IF I HAVE TO TELL YOU
GUYS THAT THEY NEED A BONE
ALTHOUGH ALSO I THINK THAT YOU.
SHOULD KNOW THE LONG ENOUGH TO
KNOW THAT THIS IS AN FRINGING
UPON OUR HUMAN RIGHTS ARE AND
EIGHT AND ALIEN UP ALL RIGHT-
SO I WOULD JUST LIKE FOR YOU
THEY DON'T. TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND BE SURE TO
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING THANK YOU YOU HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOT A CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD- I JUST WANT TO
CONCLUDE BY SAYING. FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS ARE-
MEMBER- COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS.
WELL AS OUR MADAM PRO TEM.
YOU'RE FINALLY THE EATING FONG
I'M- WE ANNOUNCER IN THE BIG.
THAT WE AREONLY TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT THROUGH THE TELEPHONE
LINE THAT WAS STATED MULTIPLE
TIMES. SO THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SUBMIT YOUR QUESTIONS
YOU CAN DO SO VIA EMAIL AND YOU
CAN ALSO GO ONLINE AS WELL
WE'VE PROVIDED THAT VERY-
ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION AND WE
PROVIDED THAT MULTIPLE TIMES.
THANK YOU SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONCLUDE OUR MEETING AT THIS
TIME AND WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL WHO
PARTICIPATED I THINK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THE
CONVERSATIONS DO NOT AND HERE
THERE WILL BE SUBSEQUENT
MEETINGS WHERE WE WILL HAVE.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION PROVIDED
IN WILL WE MAKE SURE TO.
INCLUDE THE PUBLIC WE WANT TO
THANK THE PUBLIC AS WELL FOR
THEIR- INSIGHTFUL COMMENTS. SO
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES OUR
SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE WE
ARE NOW ADJOURNED.